So. Auf geht's. Leute, kann das sein, dass wir letzte Woche, was heißt wir, in dem Fall garantiert nicht wir, sondern nur ich, letzte Woche fünfmal am Start waren?
Ist ja, was ist denn da los? Guckt euch das mal an. Eins, zwei, drei, vier, fünf. Beziehungsweise mit dem hier fünf, je nachdem, ob man den Sonntag mitrechnet oder den Sonntag mitrechnet.
Fünfmal. Wir waren fünfmal on. Fünf Streams in der Woche. Das ist ja für meine Verhältnisse fast jeden Tag. Oder für meine Verhältnisse fast regelmäßig.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Was ich ja faszinierend finde, dass ausgerechnet ich hasse C++ so viele Zuschauer. Kann ich aber auch verstehen. C++ sackt. Das will jeder sehen, wie C++ geflamed wird.
Aber das ist fast regelmäßig. Sachen gibt's. Anscheinend hat es doch seinen Vorteil, wenn man Homeoffice macht und direkt daheim ist.
Erster. Wupp wupp. Pock. Kleinschreib-Emote-Leute am Start.
Wobei ich ja nicht...
Ich hab hier gar kein Emote. Kein FFZ und Gedöns installiert. Doch, ich muss FFZ installiert haben. Hab ich. Der ist doch da.
Der Franker Z ist installiert.
Ja, aber Leute, jetzt wo ihr gerade hier am Start seid, ich hab's gerade schon gesagt. Guckt euch mal an. Ich hab fast sowas wie regelmäßig gestreamt letzte Woche.
Eins, zwei, drei, vier, fünf Streams. Oder fünf, je nachdem, welchen Sonntag man mitrechnet.
Wie heißt das Plugin? Volumemaster oder so. Ja, Volumemaster.
Ich hab einfach das Plugin genommen, was die beste Bewertung im Shop hatte. Keine Ahnung, ob das irgendwelche Backdoors enthält oder so.
Exzellent. Aber wir verlassen uns mal auf die strengen Qualitätskontrollen im Google App Store, im Chrome App Store. Da kann überhaupt nichts drin sein.
Ich hatte mir ja mal einen Add-on eingefangen mit Backdoor. Und zwar war das, hieß das, ich glaub, Kappa Everywhere.
Es kann auch sein, dass ich jetzt...
Genau, Kappa Everywhere hatte ich mal.
Das war ein E-Mode, was auf jeder Seite Twitch-E-Modes anzeigt.
Äh, das war ein Plugin, kein E-Mode.
Das war ein Plugin, was auf jeder Seite Twitch-E-Modes anzeigt.
Und das wurde dann von irgendwelchen Chinesen übernommen und hatte Backdoors drin.
Exzellent.
Also sprich, da bringt das auch nichts, wenn man das aus dem offiziellen App Store installiert.
Das kann da genauso passieren.
Ja, also bei Google guckt ja auch niemand von Hand den Kram durch.
Vielleicht bei besonders, besonders populären Extensions, aber ansonsten guckt da keiner den Kram durch, ja.
Ich muss grad mal mein Fragen-Board wieder neu starten.
So, Exzellent-Pepega-Board.
Was steht heute an?
Aufwachen.
Erstmal die Fragen von gestern löschen.
Benutzt du deine Waage mit Körperver...
Ja, ja, jeden Tag fast.
Sport.
Omega-Lull.
Nextcloud vs. Oncloud.
Nextcloud.
Aktuelles Buch.
Ja, immer noch das gleiche.
Chat, ich muss euch mal übrigens neu laden.
Chat, ich muss euch neu laden.
Ich sehe nämlich die Zuschaueranzahl grad nicht.
Ah, yes, exzellent.
Jetzt geht's.
Eleven Core ist auch am Start.
Also, C-Sharp-Buch kann ich immer nur das da.
Das da.
Recommenden.
Das hier.
Das ist gut, das ist kostenlos und damit habe ich 2002 oder so auch angefangen.
Hm.
Ne.
Hehehehe, ne.
Kommt FFM-Pack aus Frankfurt?
Das ist tatsächlich eine wahnsinnige Pepega-Frage.
Freue mich echt auf .NET 5.
Ja, ich auch, außer der Benahmung, was dann wieder bei Microsoft abgehen wird.
Ist das...
Gut.
Kannst du mal die Seite von denen zeigen?
Ich finde das gar nicht.
Seite von wem?
Ich habe mich ja verdrängt, um was es ging.
Der Kerl, der macht wohl nur Top-Nintendo-Songs, oder?
Top 1000 Nintendo-Songs, Top 300 Nintendo-Songs.
Ich würde jetzt mal vermuten, dass in den Top 300, dass die Top 300 Nintendo-Songs eigentlich
in den Top 1000 Nintendo-Songs dabei sein müssten.
Würde man jetzt vermuten.
Aber anscheinend ist das zu...
Big Brain.
Heute erst mal gelesen, dass erneut irgendein One-Line-JS-Package eintritt.
Ich glaube, das ist ein guter Punkt.
Das ist ein geiles Projekt.
Echt?
NPM?
Muss ich mal gleich gucken.
Welches?
Ah, hier.
Ach, keine Malware, sondern irgendwas, was es kaputt macht, weil einer unter dem anderen
Namen wieder gepusht hat, oder so.
One-Liner-NPM-Package broke.
NPM ist so kaputt, Alter.
NPM ist so kaputt.
Die Musik.
Epischer Chor für NPM-Break.
Mein zweites Windows hat mir gerade ein Pop-Up rausgehauen.
Windows 10 Update Assistant is already running.
Ah ja, excellent.
Ich habe ihn zwar nicht gestartet, aber es ist gut zu wissen, dass der already running ist.
Da bin ich ja froh.
So.
It's broken serverless.
Leute, wie kann ein JS-Package denn serverless broken?
Da hat man doch gar keinen Server.
Das geht doch gar nicht.
Vielleicht mal wieder ein Hinweis für den Server, dass es absolut eine Kack-Nahme ist.
Du Huck, moin.
Und warum geht das kaputt?
Warum break das?
Kann mir das irgendjemand erklären, der ein bisschen fitter mit JavaScript ist?
Warum hat das alles kaputt gemacht?
Ich checke es gerade nicht.
Was ist da kaputt?
MX-Puppet-Skype.
Check ich nicht.
Warum macht das alles kaputt?
Hat der irgendeine Funktion doppelt definiert?
Ich verstehe JavaScript manchmal, manchmal die Logik nicht.
Zumindest ist man wieder die Sache im Arsch.
Nice.
Ach, ist das...
Ach, jetzt verstehe ich es.
Ist das so ein Ding?
Ist das so ein Ding, was alle als Dependency haben?
Also das ist...
Also das ist quasi so ein Ding, was 30 Milliarden Sachen als Dependency haben.
Und der hat eine neue Version gepusht, die kaputt ist.
Sehe ich das richtig?
Ja, selbst schuld.
Dann liegt das gar nicht bei den NPM.
Das ist dann halt einfach selbst schuld.
Außerdem, warum locken die nicht die Version auf irgendwas und testen es mal, bevor sie es upgraden?
JavaScript, was auch immer.
Muss mich jetzt nicht näher mit beschäftigen im Detail.
Tritt mir nur durch im Kopf.
Ja, wie gesagt hier.
Nochmal, jetzt wo mehrere Leute da sind.
Wir haben fast regelmäßig gestreamt die Woche.
Fünf Mal.
Poggers.
Kannst du mal die Seite von denen zeigen?
Ich habe schon wieder vergessen, um was es geht.
Um was ging es?
Ich gucke jetzt auch in den Chat.
Werwalzw schreibt, das Problem habe ich seit gestern Abend auch.
Ja, ihr habt wahrscheinlich...
Wie gesagt, 3,4 Repos hängen davon ab.
Der Umut schreibt, ich brauche dein Rad.
Ich habe ein NAS.
Oh, der Michael, 50 Billionen ist auch am Start.
Billiarden oder was auch immer.
Große Zahl.
Ich brauche dein Rad.
Ich habe ein NAS, wo ich per Acronis Backup...
Oh, das habe ich ewig schnell mal verwendet.
Acronis Backup drauf spiele, will nun per Windows irgendwie die Backups nach draußen auf meinen Server schieben.
Kannst du...
Ja, kann ich.
Kenne ich.
Das da.
Perfekt.
Also, wenn du es in die Cloud schieben willst.
Ist das top.
Beste.
R-Clone.
Unterstützt alle diese Cloud Provider.
Du kannst einfach irgendwas synchen.
Das ist das beste Tool dafür.
Ansonsten, wenn du sowohl den Server bei dir, als auch deinen Backup Server im Internet kontrollierst, dann mach einfach einen R-Sync und gut ist.
RESTIC ist auch ganz gut, ja.
50 Millionen hast du nachgerechnet.
Oder was heißt gerechnet?
Gezählt.
Zeig mal her.
Das müssen wir jetzt mal kontrollieren.
1, 2, 3.
Millionen.
Ja, 500 Millionen sind es nun.
Sind gar keine Billiarden.
Da brauchst du noch ein paar.
Das ist garantiert Splatoon Musik.
Das hört sich schon so an.
Okay, fast.
Es ist Mario Kart 8 Splatoon Musik.
Bin ich eigentlich der Einzige, der findet, dass die Splatoon Musik übelst nervig ist?
Und man...
Also...
Mir war ja damals schon klar.
Als ich den allerersten...
Trailer zum allerersten Splatoon gesehen habe.
Leute, mir war es damals ja schon klar.
Ich muss es wahrscheinlich gar nicht aussprechen, was mir klar war.
Und ja, das gibt's.
Das war mir, als ich den ersten Trailer gesehen habe, schon komplett klar.
Genau, da bin ich ja ganz erkannt.
Warum machst du so viele Tabs auf?
Weil die sich mit der Zeit angesammelt haben.
So, also.
Mit der Seite habe ich schon wieder verpeilt, um was es ging.
Hat man beantwortet.
Was denkst du zu Zertifikaten?
Hm.
So.
Genau das eigentlich.
Ich denke zu Zertifikaten, je nach Bereich.
Und ob die jeweiligen Arbeitgeber darauf gucken, kann das sinnvoll sein.
Aber ich persönlich, aber ich bin ja auch nicht in der Position.
Ich würde nicht nach Zertifikaten gehen.
Zertifikate, die tatsächlich ein bisschen was aussagen, würde ich sagen, ist...
So die richtig hohen Cisco Dinger.
Die sagen zumindest aus, dass du nicht der totale...
Versager mit Cisco Geräten bist.
Also wenn du...
Wie heißt die höchste Cisco Zertifikat?
Internet Engineer, oder?
Ich glaube, das ist CCIE.
Internet Engineer.
Ich glaube, das ist die höchste.
Oder eine der höchsten.
Wenn du die hast, bist du auf jeden Fall ziemlich pro, was Cisco Hardware angeht.
Warum zeigst du nicht auch dein Gesicht?
Weil ich das seit 10 Jahren auch auf YouTube nicht mache.
Und ich keinen Bock habe, dass ich morgens in der Bahn sitze.
Und Leute sagen.
Sagst du, was geht, Alter?
Stell mal eine Ruhe.
Hat Microsoft nicht so ziemlich alle Zertifikate eingestellt?
Weiß ich nicht.
Ich habe irgendwas gelesen davor.
Vor einer Weile.
Dass Microsoft Zertifikate jetzt nicht mehr weiter verfolgt.
Aber ob die alle eingestellt haben, keine Ahnung.
Kann ich mir nicht vorstellen.
Die ganze Microsoft Zertifizierung ist so ein selbstversorgendes Ökosystem.
Auch die ganzen Azure Zertifizierungen.
Das wollen ja...
Cloud Zertifizierungen sind tatsächlich was.
Was aktuell relativ angesagt ist.
Weil halt sehr viele Leute, weil das neu ist.
Und sehr viele Leute sagen.
Alter, ich bin ein krasser Cloud-Expert.
Haben aber keinen blassen Schimmer.
Und man muss halt auch sagen, dass sowohl die Bedienung von Azure, von AWS, als auch von...
Ich kann mir immer nicht merken, wie das Google-Ding heißt.
Google Clouds...
GCS...
Wie heißt das Google-Ding?
Die Google Cloud.
Ich kann mir den Namen von der Google Cloud nicht merken.
Die haben alle irgendwelche Zertifizierungen, die zumindest sagen...
Google...
G...
GCP?
Ich weiß nicht genau.
Die haben alle irgendwelche...
Oje, Corona am Start wieder.
Nicht Google Drive, ich meine die Google Cloud Plattform.
Wo man Container, Kubernetes, Schiss machen kann drinnen.
Die haben alle irgendwelche Zertifizierungen.
Und die sind auch schon zumindest insofern sinnvoll, dass man sehen kann, derjenige weiß, wie man den Kram bedienen kann.
Und sowohl Google Cloud als auch...
Also ich habe bisher...
In AWS habe ich ehrlich gesagt noch nie groß was gemacht.
Ich habe nur was bisher in Google Cloud und mit Azure gemacht.
Und die Bedienung, die ist bei allen so abartig durch die Brust ins Auge und kompliziert, dass es tatsächlich sinnvoll ist, da eine Zertifizierung sich zeigen zu lassen, wenn einer sagt, er kennt sich damit aus.
Also...
Dann weißt du zumindest, er weiß, was er macht.
Ja.
Du bist in der Suppe geleakt, ich weiß.
Ja...
Was meinst du denn nochmal für eine Seite, die ich zeigen soll?
Ich habe die voll verpeilt.
Was denkst du zu...
Hatten wir?
Hatten wir auch.
LPIC.
Ich habe ehrlich gesagt noch nicht einen gesehen, der einen LPIC hatte und deswegen genommen wurde.
Das ist nicht so verbreitet.
Aber das ist nur meine Meinung.
Also das bedeutet gar nichts.
Das Endzone Gamestar Video, das können wir tatsächlich gucken.
Achso.
Volume Master.
Prom.
Doch, das gibt es noch, das habe ich erst letztens installiert.
Ja.
Volumen Master.
Da ist es.
Von Dipeta.
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass Dipeta jetzt auch Browser Plugins macht.
Cuts FPS approved.
Das Gamestar Video zu...
Ja, das können wir uns angucken.
Irgendwas im Auge.
Man sagt ja immer, wenn man was im Auge hat, so reiben bringt nichts.
Man muss ja eigentlich von außen nach innen, aber ich mache das nicht.
Ich reibe einfach wild am Auge rum, dass es irgendwann weg ist.
Das ist nicht sonderlich optimal, ich weiß.
RIP Auge.
Alter.
Ist ja...
Setz mal raus.
Oh.
Achso, das ist ein Chrome Plugin.
Aber es gibt sowas hundertprozentig auch für Firefox.
Tausendtausendprozentig.
Ja.
Ignorieren und drei Stunden leiden ist excellent advice.
Huge.
Der Kommentator ist am Start.
Moin.
PeepoClap.
Oh, das Emote heißt wirklich PeepoClap.
Ich habe das jetzt einfach nur so bauchgefühlmäßig gesagt und kenne mittlerweile viel zu viele Emotes.
Alter, kann immer das Zeug aus meinem Auge jetzt rausgehen, ey?
Kommt das überhaupt her?
Ich sitze vor dem Rechner und gucke gerade auf den Monitor.
Ich kann überhaupt nichts ins Auge kriegen.
Nehmen wir Fenster auf.
Nehmen wir Fenster auf, nix.
Ja, gucken wir.
Haben wir das schon aufgemacht?
Ja.
Dazu fällt mir nur das hier ein.
Das ist eh ein sehr underusedes Emote, muss ich sagen.
Finde ich fast die beste MonkHS Variante, aber kaum einer benutzt MonkHS.
MonkaGiga ist auch okay, wobei ich MonkHS eigentlich am besten finde.
So, ähm, hatten wir?
Du hast den Internetführerschein.
Excellent.
Den haben nur ganz wenige.
Die wollen einen LPG haben.
Okay.
Nicht schlecht.
Das ist die einzige, die ich bisher gehört habe, gesehen habe, was auch immer Berichte gesehen habe, die einen LPG haben wollen.
Nice.
So, mit was fangen wir heute denn an, Leute?
Mit was fangen wir denn an?
Wir haben sehr viel Zeug zur Auswahl.
Battlefield 5 ist cancelled.
Das müssen wir uns, die Nachricht müssen wir uns tatsächlich mal durchlesen.
Ähm, weil ich habe das auch nur jetzt in ein paar Videos gesehen.
Battlefield 5 steht kurz nach dem Ende.
Spieler fassungslos.
Und was ist die, und was ist die, was hier, derstandard.de.
Das ist nicht irgendeine österreichische News-Seite.
Bisschen leicht Clickbait-Überschrift da.
Ich meine, WTF?
Spieler fassungslos.
Battlefield steht nach kurzer Zeit vor dem Ende.
GameStar hat es erwähnt.
Gucken wir mal bei der GameStar.
Ich bin jemand, der sagt, Gott sei Dank ist Battlefield 5 am Ende.
Da kommt vielleicht irgendwann mal ein gescheites Battlefield.
Battlefield?
Gibt es nicht.
Haben die hier geschrieben, dass das eingestellt wurde?
Das Ende von Battlefield 5 ist traurig, kommt aber nicht unerwartet.
Das Spiel hat halt einfach von Anfang an
so viel gefailt,
das geht auf keine...
Wie heißt das?
Es geht auf keine Kuhhaut.
Was eigentlich ein total beknackter Spruch ist.
Was kann die Kuh dafür?
Wie benutzt du dein Manjaro auf der Arbeit?
Nativ oder auch richtig installiert auf dem Notebook?
Ich entdocke das einfach nicht.
Ich verwende das Notebook eigentlich fast nur stationär.
Mit Kapitel 6 endet der Content Support für Battlefield 5.
Im Juni soll es noch ein Update mit neuen Freedom Analytics 해주-
Wollten die das nicht bis?
Weiß jemand von euch, wie der ursprüngliche Plan war?
Der ursprüngliche Plan war doch,
dass man 2021 erst anfangen will.
Ganz ungewiss.
Und überhaupt mit einem neuen Battlefield oder sowas.
Es ist auf jeden Fall
Ich weiß auch gar nicht, wie viel ursprünglich kommen sollte
an Battlefield 5 für Battlefield 5.
5. Roadmap. Schauen wir mal,
was da ursprünglich gedacht war.
Roadmap.
New Map. Moment,
in welchem Jahr sind wir?
Äh, 2019 ist das, ne?
Chapter 5.
Na gut, die haben es ja auch nur bis Chapter 5
angekündigt, ne?
Und das erste halbe Jahr 2020
ist schon um.
Die wollten bestimmt 10 Kapitel machen.
Naja, was auch immer.
Ähm, mal gucken, was die
Gamestar als größte Fails von Battlefield 5
äh, sieht. Also,
ich kann wenig
aus, also rein aus Spielersicht, wenig
Gutes, noch wenig großartig
Schlechtes über das Game sagen.
Außer, dass es mir, dass es mich
nicht so gecatcht hat, richtig.
Ich hab die Alpha gespielt, da bin ich mit
der Zeit dann immer besser reingekommen. Haben wir ja sogar schon
relativ oft sogar mal gestreamt.
Lief eigentlich auch ganz gut. Dann irgendwie
hat mir aber das ganze Drumherum und auch
vor allem Navic als Map überhaupt nicht gefallen.
Auch diese komischen Kills,
Streak, Raketen, da waren nicht irgendwie
so meins. Und, ähm,
drumherum hat's mir, hat's mir auch nicht so
zugesagt. So, bei Release hab ich mir trotzdem
gekauft im Vergleich zu Battlefield 1.
Fand es gar nicht so
schlecht, auch wenn mir halt Rush
echt gefehlt hat.
Ich weiß, da gab's ganz guter Ersatz.
Und was, also eine Sache, die mir
persönlich, und das hab ich in meinem Review-Video
auch gesagt, dass das nix ist, was das Spiel an sich
schlecht macht, sondern nur so eine persönliche Sache
von mir ist, ähm, die mir
nicht gefallen hat. Eine ganz kleine,
kleine Sache, aber die mir, die mir richtig groß
im Kopf geblieben ist in Battlefield 5,
neben, neben anderen Sachen wie die Waffenentwicklung
und sonst was. Aber eine Sache, die mir echt im Kopf geblieben ist,
ist, ups,
warum such ich jetzt nach 5, äh, nicht, dass sie
weibliche Soldaten hatten oder sowas, das war mir
eigentlich vollkommen egal, sondern,
dass die weiblichen Soldaten so rumgeschrien haben.
Und ich mag Leute
nicht, die rumschreien.
Es ist jetzt egal, ob Frauen oder Männer, aber Frauen,
die hoch, die, wenn sie mit hoher Stimme schreien,
ist dann nochmal,
ist halt besonders nervig,
finde ich. Und
das dann im Spiel, das brauche ich nicht.
Und ich weiß auch nicht,
was, was mit den Soundleuten
los war, ne? Die Battlefield,
ähm, die Battlefield-Soldaten,
die machen, wenn sie erschossen werden,
machen irgendwie, uh, oder irgendwie
sowas, ja? Und die Mädels in Battlefield
machen, ah!
Übelst nervig!
Weiß auch nicht, warum.
Das ist eine Sache, die mir auf Geeks
gegangen ist.
Ja, ähm,
und ansonsten gab's noch ein paar andere Sachen.
Die Waffenentwicklung fand ich ein bisschen fragwürdig.
Mir hat, wie gesagt, der Beta die Maps auch überhaupt nicht gefallen.
Mir hat Rush gefehlt.
Aber ansonsten kann ich weder großartig Gutes
noch Schlechtes über das Game sagen. Ich hab's kaum
gespielt. Das hat mich halt nicht so wirklich
gecatcht. So, also, der Reveal-Trailer
war auf jeden Fall richtiger Fail.
Der war so,
der war so für'n Arsch, der Reveal-Trailer.
Vor allem haben die sich selbst ins eigene Fleisch
geschnitten. Die haben das so verkackt, den
Reveal-Trailer. Die haben nämlich,
vielleicht könnt ihr euch noch dran erinnern,
ähm,
die Maps, die Maps find ich auch,
die Maps find ich auch nicht gut, die ich bisher
gesehen hab. So, also,
die haben nämlich, falls ihr euch noch dran erinnern
könnt,
die sind total abgegangen auf
wie authentisch und
quasi, wie erzählen die Stories
der
unerzählten Geschichten, so nach dem Motto
aus dem Band, das ist das Authentischste
und das Immersivste und
das, das überhaupt
genialste,
World War Two Game aller Zeiten, so.
Das heißt, du hast jetzt eigentlich erwartet,
dass du irgendwie einen ziemlich
nah an der Realität
befindlichen,
recht atmosphärischen,
vielleicht auch brutalen und, und
...
wie nennen wir das? Erwachsenen-Trailer?
Ne, einen, ja einfach einen
atmosphärischen Trailer siehst, wo du
sagst, fuck, ähm,
ich hoffe, ich komm nie
in so eine Situation, so nach dem Motto, ja?
So, so hast du gedacht nach der Ankündigung.
Und dann kommt ein Trailer,
wo, wo Panzer
durch Häuser fahren, Leute mit
schottischer Kriegsbemalung am Start
sind, schwarze Soldaten mit Katana
auf dem Rücken und, und
ne, ne Frau mit Krallenhand.
Und da haben alle schon gedacht, Moment,
ihr habt euch jetzt 45 Minuten
da irgendwie einen runtergeholt drauf,
wie authentisch, immersive
und, und überhaupt toll, da kommt
sowas, da waren alle, da waren alle echt
verwirrt, als sie den Trailer gesehen haben.
Das war auch ein wahnsinniger Fail-Trailer.
Und der nächste Fail war,
der eigentlich schon größere Fail,
der Rest hätte man, den Rest hätte man
noch, noch ändern können und angeblich
haben sie auch einige Sachen daraus entfernt.
Ich mein, im fertigen Spiel gibt's ja anscheinend gar keine
Klauenhand mehr und sowas.
Ähm, ähm, der größte
Fail danach war eigentlich der,
was, der Dice-Chef, der gesagt hat,
irgendwie
erstens, er will seiner Tochter nicht erklären müssen,
warum's, äh, in dem Spiel keine
weiblichen Soldaten gibt und,
ähm, mit
seinen Storys sind sie ja quasi auf der
richtigen Seite
der Geschichte
und wer es nicht mag,
der soll es nicht bestellen, beziehungsweise
nicht kaufen. Und das
war der Punkt, wo's nach unten ging. Weil
einmal haben die Leute das Richtige
gemacht. Anscheinend brauchen die erst die
Genehmigung vom Dice-Chef.
Sie haben es nicht gekauft.
Sie haben's vor allem nicht vorbestellt.
Und die Vorbestellerzahlen von Battlefield
5 waren unglaublich
scheiße.
Und, ähm,
daraufhin haben sie ja dann ein bisschen zurückgerudert.
Der Dice-Typ ist ja auch mittlerweile weg.
Aber mehr
verkacken, mehr verkacken kann man's nicht.
Ich bin immer noch der Meinung, sie hätten
das Spiel so machen sollen,
wie sie ursprünglich wollten, also mit
mit Soldaten mit Katana,
mit Soldaten mit Klauen in der Hand.
Ich bin der Meinung, sie hätten das Spiel genauso machen sollen,
wie es ihnen ursprünglich vorgeschwebt ist.
Allerdings, sie hätten es nicht
verkaufen sollen als, äh, quasi
zweite Weltkriegssimulation,
sondern sie hätten es verkaufen sollen
als, ähm, komplett
neuer Ansatz, quasi was diese
Epoche angeht, nämlich indem sie
sich an nichts halten, was wirklich gewesen
ist, sondern quasi den
den Ablauf, wie er in echt war, so
als grobes Vorbild nehmen und, äh,
so ein alternatives
Realitätsszenario machen.
Da hätte man richtig
geile Storys machen können für den Singleplayer,
ohne sich so den Anschein
geben zu müssen, es wäre, es wäre
realitätsbasiert, und man hätte
den größten Schwachsinn in den Multiplayer
bauen können, aber es hätte keinen gejuckt.
Die hätten das Spiel einfach so machen sollen,
wie sie ursprünglich vorhatten,
bloß, dass sie das Szenario halt als nicht, äh,
hyperrealistische
zweite Weltkriegs, äh,
Atmosphäre und Simulation verkaufen.
Ja. Genau.
Das hier war's, ähm,
Kriegsbemalung um
ohne Klauenhand zu,
der, der Soldat mit dem Katana ist nicht am Start,
hab es, hab es verkackt, ja.
Zu dem Versprechen, ein taktischeres
Battlefield für Hardcore-Fans abzuliefern,
schien die Szene jedenfalls so gar nicht,
das stimmt, das stimmt.
Das Spiel ist auch kein taktisches
Battlefield für Hardcore-Fans, das ist halt
irgendwas zusammengewursteltes von Leuten,
die nicht mehr wissen, wie man ein scheiß Battlefield macht.
Äh, moin, kennt einer von euch das Problem,
dass ihr den Prime-Sub nicht vergeben kommt?
Ähm, ich hatte mal das Problem, da musste ich mich ausloggen,
wieder einloggen, dann hat's funktioniert, ähm,
aber ansonsten hatte ich da noch
keine Probleme, ne.
Oder war das ein, oder war das ein
G-Bait, dass alle mal ausprobieren,
ob sie nicht ihren Prime-Sub noch vergeben können?
Hm...
Dann wär das aber ein ziemlich guter G-Bait
gewesen, wenn's einer war.
Also ich, und diese ganze
Service-Game-Ausrichtung
von Battlefield 5 hab ich ja gar keine Probleme
mit. Ich hätte mir ja schon für
Battlefield 4
damals gewünscht, oder für Battlefield 3,
die hätten das vier Jahre supported.
Mit neuem Content.
Gerade Battlefield 3.
Wer abonniert? Twitch Prime, dankeschön. Huge Sub.
Excellent Sub.
Ähm...
Aber halt
bei nem Game, was ich prinz- äh, grundsätzlich
geil fände, und das war halt Battlefield 5 nicht.
Ja, ähm...
Progression war für'n Arsch,
das stimmt.
Das liegt aber auch mit daran,
ähm, das liegt aber auch mit daran,
wenn das Game an sich den Spielern nicht
reicht, dann schreien sie nach mehr Unlocks
und, ähm, Progression.
Es gab mal ne Zeit, da hat das
Gameplay alleine gereicht.
Das muss nicht unbedingt sein, ja?
Ich find, Bad Company 2 hat's
ganz schön gemacht, auch Battlefield 3.
Das hat richtig lange gedauert, bis du auf Max-Rank,
gerade in Bad Company 2 hat's richtig lange gedauert, bis du auf Max,
maximal im Rang warst.
Da hast du noch die ganzen Kernel-Level im Battlefield 3
gehabt, also, ähm...
Das war, war ganz gut. Ich finde, es braucht gar nicht
riesige Sachen, sondern es ist
einfach nur schön, wenn man sieht, jeder mag das, wenn
irgendwelche Zahlen hochgehen.
Richtig stonksmäßig.
Deswegen. Und wenn man irgendwann mal Kernel 100
hat, ist es doch richtig nice. Vor allem, wenn es auch
ein Achievement ist und nicht, äh, jeder hat's.
Das hin und her mit dem Gunplay.
Oh ja, das hab ich gar nicht mehr mitgekriegt.
Da hab ich ja gar nicht mehr gespielt, großartig.
Ähm...
Aber das war ne riesen Diskussion.
Da haben sie's voll verschissen.
Der mangelnde Content-Nachschub.
Und das, lustigerweise, bei nem Game,
das von Anfang an angekündigt
war als Service-Game.
Das ist eigentlich lächerlich, ne?
Dass man gerade bei nem Game was als, als,
als Langzeit mit regelmäßigem
Content angelegt ist, der Content nicht
nachkommt. Firestorm war,
glaube ich, ziemlich verschwendete
Entwicklerzeit. Keine Sau
spielt mehr Firestorm.
Wisst ihr überhaupt noch, was Firestorm ist?
Ist das Royal Firestorm oder so?
Firestorm...
Fire...
Firestorm!
Wie schreibt man das überhaupt?
Firestorm...
Spielt das überhaupt jemand?
...
Excellent!
Oh!
Ne!
Past Videos!
Doch hier, guck mal!
Hier spielen welche Battlefield!
Mit 24, 57,
9 und 129 Viewer!
Huge!
Massive Viewer!
Das ist rausgekommen, ja, ja?
So.
Angeblich, ja, das hab ich auch gelesen, dass das angeblich gar nicht schlecht war.
Das war auch, das war auch Fail.
Es gab nen neuen Singleplayer. Ach stimmt, es gab
nen neuen Singleplayer.
Singleplayer hab ich mal, hab ich mal versucht,
hab ich fünf Minuten gespielt, hat keinen Bock mehr.
Ja.
Ja, also, da bin ich
echt mal gespannt. Mal gucken, was er hier dazu sagt.
Mal gucken, was
er hier dazu sagt, zu Battlefield Content
eingestellt.
Ich hoffe ja immer noch
drauf, dass
irgendwann mal
oder hoffentlich vielleicht sogar als nächstes,
aber ich glaub ja nicht dran, wenn Bad Company 3
kommt, was von Leuten
gemacht wird, die wissen, was
ein gutes Bad Company ausmacht.
Aber die Hoffnung hab ich eigentlich fast schon aufgegeben.
Boah, der redet ja wieder wahnsinnig geschwind.
Exzellent.
Auf 1,25 geht das doch relativ gut, oder?
Wir müssen, wisst ihr was,
anstatt wir uns das Video angucken,
schauen wir uns einfach mal den
offiziellen Future
of Battlefield, wir gucken uns einfach mal den
offiziellen Post an.
Wie heißt der Typ, Ryan? Ryan
irgendwas. Hier, da.
Also.
Hallo. Gibt's das
auch, ich guck mir mal ganz
gern an, wie sie die Dinger übersetzen.
Ah, nee, gibt's nicht.
Also. Machen wir mal
den Dark Reader aus.
Äh.
Moment, das wird zu grell.
Ah, jetzt.
Moin, Querdos.
Blablabla.
Wären die Spiele ordentlich modbar,
dann würde das auch wunderbar funktionieren.
What's coming after
Battlefield Chapter 6?
Okay.
29. April.
One more,
also ein weiteres Update
im Sommer.
Neue Waffen, Game Tweaks.
Im Juni.
Sag mal, Juni? Juli?
Juni, ne?
Ähm, we are still tackling
challenges from work... Blablabla.
Blablabla.
New Update im Sommer.
Weekly Rewards, juckt mich nicht. Event und
Activities, das braucht auch kein Mensch.
Community Games Update.
Okay.
Ja, lass die Leute die Arbeit machen,
die können es mittlerweile eh besser.
As the battle rages on.
Die schreiben die immer so.
So, wie nennt man das?
Diese Texte sind immer so gefüllt
mit so schönen Zwischendingern.
Anstatt einfach nur einen Satz zu schreiben, so
Battlefield 5 dead.
Lul.
Ähm.
Continue to work anti-cheat, okay.
Weiß ich nicht,
wie gut das funktioniert in Battlefield 4.
Wie ist das anti-cheat so
in Battlefield 4? Äh, äh,
Battlefield 5? Ach Gott, Benahmung von Battlefield.
Eine Fresse. Battlefield 5 meine ich,
nicht Battlefield 4. Vergiss, was ich gesagt habe.
Wie ist das anti-cheat so?
Ähm.
Das war's?
Das ist ja geil.
Das ist ja, das ist wieder so richtig,
wenn man das liest, ne,
wirkt das Ganze eigentlich positiv.
So nach dem Motto, oh cool, der kündigt
ein neues Update an. Aber was er in
Wirklichkeit ankündigt ist,
was man da rauslesen muss eigentlich,
ähm, dass er nichts weiteres ankündigt
ist eigentlich die Sache, die darauf
hindeutet, dass das Ganze eingestellt wird.
Ah, ja.
Listen to community feedback. Da seid
ihr ja huge, huge
brain drin.
Es gibt keine Comments.
Würde mich auch wundern, aber meine Comments.
Okay, was sagt Reddit?
Reddit sagt deleted.
Lul.
Da sind sie immer schnell dabei.
Ach hier, es gibt einen neuen Chat.
Ja. Stimmt.
Eigentlich gibt es im Battlefield wirklich nix,
wo man, was man so mit 2. Weltkrieg
Shooter in Verbindung bringt. Kein D-Day, keine
Ostfront, kein Berlin, ja.
Das stimmt schon, ja.
Na gut, ganz ehrlich,
mich freut's sogar ein bisschen,
ähm, weil wir dann jetzt vielleicht die Chance
haben, ein ordentliches Battlefield
mal wieder zu bekommen.
Weil das sollte ja DICE gezeigt haben, die Leute
haben keinen Bock auf den Scheiß.
Aber ich glaube, die haben einfach keine Leute
mehr, die ordentliches Battlefield machen können.
Ist vorbei.
Meine persönliche Hoffnung
ist ja immer noch auf ein neues Battle,
äh, nicht Battle Royale, was sag ich denn da?
Neues Bad Company.
So, also, was gucken wir jetzt als nächstes?
Burger gucken wir nicht.
Wir gucken jetzt...
Oh!
Hands-on neues Windows 10 Update.
Stimmt, es kam ja ein neues
Windows 10 Update raus.
Schauen wir uns mal an, was es für
bahnbrechende Farbschema-
Änderungen am Windows Calculator wieder gibt.
Viel mehr kann's ja nicht sein.
Dicht ist richtig.
Es gibt jetzt Desktop-Sticky-Notizen.
Was war's das quasi schon?
Das gibt's schon seit 20 Jahren.
30 Jahren gibt's.
Oder gibt's das schon?
Ich verwende das nicht.
Sticky-Notes, ah ne, das gibt's schon.
Das ist gar nichts Neues.
Vergiss, was ich gesagt hab.
Ist gar nichts Neues.
Alles Zeug.
Zeig mal her.
Ich predicte mal.
Ich predicte mal Änderungen in der neuen
Windows 10 Version.
Also ich predicte, dass das
Taschenrechner-Farbschema sich ändert.
Dass irgendwelche Buttons
im Startmenü umsortiert wurden.
Dass die Suche angeblich
jetzt endlich funktioniert.
Wo man natürlich nicht sagt,
die Suche funktioniert endlich,
sondern sagt, die Suche wurde
verbessert und ist jetzt so gut wie nie.
Aber im Prinzip funktioniert die
Windows 10 Version.
Ähm.
Dass der Explorer
Das könnte nämlich endlich mal kommen.
Ach, der hat schon Ribbons.
Okay, ich hab nichts gesagt.
Der Explorer hat Ribbons.
Ich guck da so selten rein.
Okay, der Explorer hat schon Ribbons.
Was könnte als nächstes kommen?
Dass man noch ein paar alte Menüs
geupgradet hat von Windows XP
auf das neue Design.
Und ja, was könnte Microsoft da Neues machen?
Mit Tablet und Stiftsupport
oder Gedöns, was keiner braucht?
Ja, mal gucken.
Ich kann mir nichts großartiges vorstellen.
Ah ja, doch, ich weiß was.
Eins fällt mir noch ein.
Sie haben Cortana mal wieder umgebaut
und die funktioniert jetzt wieder komplett anders.
Der hat auch schon seinen
Mauszeiger auf Cortana.
Sie haben Cortana wieder mal umgebaut.
Weil die bauen ja fast jedes Windows Update
Cortana um. Das haben sie bestimmt wieder gemacht.
In a previous release of Windows 10
von der Windows Search Bar
Ich sag's euch.
Ich wusste es.
Und ihr habt es gesehen.
Ich habe das gesagt, bevor ich es gehört habe.
Ich wusste es. Cortana kommt wieder irgendwie
bauen die wieder irgendwas um.
so that they could focus on improving
the Windows Search Experience.
Als hätte ich es gewusst.
Cortana und Windows Suche.
Cortana on the other hand was severely neglected
and lost much of her previous functionality.
However, Windows 10 version 2004
brought her new functionality back.
Microsoft is rebranding Cortana to a
personal productivity assistant.
From now on Microsoft will focus on integrating
Cortana into Microsoft 365 workflows.
As for her appearance in this release
Microsoft 365 ist übrigens
Office 365
weil Microsoft hat sich bei ihrer
Big Brain Benahmung
also Microsoft, wir hatten es ja gestern von
.NET 5, was jetzt eigentlich
.NET Core 4
Xbox Scarlett, Xbox XS
One, was auch immer.
Was Microsoft mit Benahmung nicht sonderlich hat
haben wir ja schon festgestellt.
Und ähm
Deswegen haben sie auch Office umbenannt.
Jetzt wo sich die Leute merken konnten
Office 365
wird das Ding umbenannt in
Microsoft 365.
Jetzt gerade wo sich die Leute das merken können.
Oh das heißt auch
man kann es komplett deinstallieren.
Ansonsten gibt es noch eine
Benutzt, ernst gemeinte Frage, Chat. Benutzt ihr Cortana? Wir machen jetzt mal eine Umfrage. Da bin ich jetzt mal gespannt. Straw Pool. Also, wir machen jetzt mal eine Umfrage.
Ähm, was benutzt ihr? Welchen Assistant benutzt ihr? Also, was haben wir da einmal? Cortana. Google. Ich glaube, das Ding heißt einfach nur Google Assistant. Siri. Was haben wir noch? Was gibt es noch?
Also, verbreitetes. Was gibt es noch? Alexa.
Ähm, Google Ads. Bixby kenne ich überhaupt. Was ist, was ist? Bix, Bixby? Okay, ich wusste gar nicht, dass es existiert, aber ich nehme es da mit rein.
Okay, also. Allow multiple answers, IP checking, ja, was auch immer. Create. Jetzt bin ich mal gespannt, Leute. Bin ich mal gespannt, ob das überhaupt, ah, gar kein, ja, ähm, ähm, äh, ja, wartet mal, Leute, ich mache das neu.
Haha, ich habe es verkackt. Ich mache das, ich mache das neu. Ich mache das neu. Ihr müsst nicht abstimmen. Ich mache das neu.
Äh, also, Cortana, Google Assistant, Alexa, äh, was war das? Ne, ähm, Siri, oder wie hieß das andere? Bixby? Bixby habe ich noch nie gehört. Keinen. Okay, allow multiple answers, create.
Jetzt aber, Leute, jetzt haben wir es. Hier, das ist der Richtige. Also, results. Jetzt bin ich mal gespannt, ob den Kram jemand benutzt. Boah, der Chat, Alter, hui, hui, hui, hui, hui. Keinen.
Okay. Oh, wir haben einen Cortana-Benutzer. Outet sich der Cortana-Benutzer auch im Chat, wer das ist? Zwei Cortana-Benutzer. Okay, das habe ich so, das, das habe ich so erwartet, dass das ungefähr gleich groß ist.
Ich hätte jetzt persönlich, persönlich hätte ich eigentlich gedacht, dass Alexa vorne ist.
Weil es ja nicht an irgendwelche Smartphone-Geschichten oder sonst wie gebunden ist. Ich weiß, Google Assistant auch nicht, aber Alexa gibt es ja zig weitere Produkte dazu. Okay, nice. Ähm, ja, schön, dass so viele mitgemacht haben. Ich meine, guck mal, 142 Votes von 250 Zuschauern, das ist ziemlich, ziemlich massive.
Ähm, also, was man daran schön erkennen kann, die meisten Leute verwenden keinen Voice Assistant. Da gehöre ich auch dazu. Ich verwende keinen Voice Assistant. Bixby verwendet auch kaum einer. Ich habe es noch nie gehört.
Ich habe, ich wusste bis eben gar nicht, dass es, dass es existiert. Ähm, ich habe erwartet, dass die ungefähr gleich auf sind. Wobei ich persönlich gedacht habe, dass Alexa vorne liegt. So ein paar Prozent oder so.
Weil es halt auch zusätzliche Alexa-Geräte gibt. Also du hast diese ganzen, diese ganzen Echo-Dinger und sonst was. Ich habe eigentlich gedacht, dass Alexa ein bisschen vorne liegt. Aber okay, es ist, es ist ziemlich genau. Was ja auch Sinn ergibt, Apple, Google verteilt sich so, da war, also sagen wir mal so, Verbreitung ist hier mehr.
Aber die Apple-Fans finden alles, was Apple macht, geil. Das gleicht sich ein bisschen aus. Also anteilmäßig denke ich mal, dass mehr Leute Siri verwenden, die Apple haben, als Google Assistant, die Google-Produkte verwenden.
Aber das wundert mich, dass Alexa nicht ein bisschen weiter vorne liegt und Cortana verwendet auch so gut wie keiner. Also Bixby und Cortana ist beides nicht so, nicht so beliebt.
Ähm, ich habe mal, ich habe mal ein bisschen rumprobiert auf meinem Shield-TV, sowohl mit Alexa.
Da gab es ja eine zusätzliche Alexa-App, die man installieren konnte, über den Custom-App-Store und mit Google Assistant.
Und ich habe festgestellt, es bringt absolut gar nichts, weil die Integration massiv suckt.
Was richtig cool gewesen wäre, ähm, die, das, das alte Shield-TV hatte eine Fernbedienung dabei, da musst du so einen Knopf drücken, nur dann hat sich das Mikro eingeschaltet, das war schon mal gut.
Ähm, was richtig cool wäre, wenn du hättest sagen können, ähm, was ich, nehmen, nehmen, 20.15 Uhr Tagesschau aufnehmen.
Oder sowas. Nicht, dass ich Tagesschau aufnehmen würde, aber so als Beispiel.
Das wäre eigentlich ganz cool gewesen, aber das hat nicht funktioniert.
Deswegen.
Und seitdem habe ich mich damit nie mit, nie wieder beschäftigt.
Und ansonsten bin ich ja auch der Meinung, so schnell wie ich den Kram tippe, und so schnell wie ich quasi weiß, was ich tippen will und machen will, ist kein Voice Assistant.
Also, so schnell ich mein Notizprogramm aufgemacht habe und was reingeschrieben habe und gesaved habe, bis ich dann gesagt habe, ähm,
Alexa-Style, ähm, irgendwie, Alexa, sag Notizprogramm, ähm, öffne Notiz, äh, füge Notiz hinzu, ich will jetzt öfter streamen, Notiz Ende, immer, ähm, ja, da habe ich das schon fünfmal selbst gemacht.
Aber interessant, das Ergebnis speichere ich mir mal, das kann ich vielleicht mal für ein Video brauchen.
Kann man Votes eigentlich closen, dass jetzt nicht irgendjemand krassen Troll-Votes macht danach?
Nee, geht nicht.
Screenshot, na, Screenshot ist outdated, overrated, jebated, Screenshot machen wir nicht.
Okay, weiter, weiter gucken, was es für Windows-Funktionen gibt.
Screenshot, nee, nee, nee, so oldschool-Sachen machen wir gar nicht.
Moment, wo ist der mal stehen geblieben?
Ach, stimmt, Cortana.
Cortana.
Leute, ich habe euch gesagt, Cortana.
Cortana und Windows-Suche, und zack, was kommt als erstes?
Cortana und Windows-Suche.
Gibt's das nicht jetzt schon?
Das gibt's doch jetzt schon, oder?
Wo ist überhaupt meine Suchleiste?
So, Leute, wo ist meine Suchleiste?
Ist die weg? Wo ist die hin?
Ist die nicht immer da normalerweise?
Nee, nur ein Monitor.
Search, hab ich Search ausgeblendet?
Search.
Ah, Search-Icon, okay, nice.
Guck, das ist doch jetzt schon da.
Das ist doch gar nichts Neues.
Okay, Wetter.
In Bruchköbel, nee, nicht so ganz.
Ist zwar nicht weit weg, aber nicht so ganz.
15 Grad, excellent.
Was hast du für eine Windows-Version?
Ähm, wo sieht man das?
CMD?
Da gab's doch ein Winfair oder so.
Win...
Nee, äh...
Moment, warum hab ich hier immer noch das Windows 98 ISO?
Winfair?
1903 hab ich.
Ich bin richtig outdated.
Ich bin ein Jahr hinten dran mit Updates, Leute.
Mon KS.
Ich muss mal wieder updaten, ja?
Live.
Also, ein Reverse-Search-Button ist jetzt auf der Windows-Search-Page präsent.
Visual Search ist eine Reverse-Image-Search-Feature, die seit einigen Jahren in Bing präsent ist.
Was?
Microsoft integriert diese Feature jetzt in mehrere ihrer Produkte,
insbesondere Windows-Fotos und Windows-Search.
Klicken Sie den Visual-Search-Button auf der Windows-Search-Page,
lassen Sie eine Seite deines Bildschirms schnippen,
die es dann benutzt, um ähnliche Bilder online zu finden.
Okay, das ist doch...
Ist doch ganz nett.
Werd ich wahrscheinlich nie verwenden, aber ist doch ganz nett.
Pfh.
Erstmal der Minecraft-Turm hier.
...Better Spell Correction Algorithm for app and settings searches.
Windows will do a better job at returning local search results for apps and settings whose...
Habt ihr gesehen? Was hat er denn da in der Startleiste drin?
Instagram Template...
...Instagram Template...
...Instagram Template... und Minecraft.
Excellent.
...Windows will do a better job at returning local search results for apps and settings whose names you've misspelled in the search bar.
For instance, a pitten will bring up the search bar...
Ich habe im Vorfeld auch gesagt, ich erwarte, dass das Calculator-Farbschema sich ändert.
Leute, ich schwöre euch, ich habe das Video vorher nicht geguckt.
Ich hatte keine Ahnung. Das war einfach random, was ich erzählt habe.
Und irgendwie stimmt das alles.
Ups, irgendwie stimmt das alles.
Ja, das habe ich schon immer gebraucht.
Always on top Calculator, den habe ich schon immer gebraucht.
Ja, das wäre ja auch nicht auszudenken, weil Microsoft eine neue Sache ankündigt
und dann auf einen Schlag alle Sachen aktualisiert werden.
Stimmt, das Farbschema ist nicht anders. Tatsächlich ist es der Calculator, der on top steht.
Das stimmt, da hatte ich nicht recht. Das ist richtig.
Aber das ist so Microsoft-typisch, so nach dem Motto, wir haben eine neue Icon-Richtlinie.
Ja, wie? Wir sollen alle unsere eigenen Icons aktualisieren?
Nee, nee, nee, das machen wir nicht. Das machen wir vielleicht über die nächsten fünf Jahre in Updates.
In Windows 10 Version 2004 könnt ihr jetzt die Temperatur eurer Grafikkarte in der Performance-Taste bemerken.
Das haben wir schon mal in einem Video gesehen, dass der Task-Manager das jetzt kann.
Da haben wir uns damals schon drüber kaputt gelacht.
Huge.
Oh, das ist geil.
Using the keyboard shortcut Windows-Key-Plus-G in an open game, the game bar will appear with various sections like capture and performance.
If you open and pin the performance tab, you will see the performance tab.
Your CPU, GPU, RAM and FPS-Stats will remain visible over any open game.
So it's sort of like a little mini-Task-Manager that you can always keep open.
Okay, warum nicht? Aber ich mach das...
Ich mein, brauchen wir das echt? Ich mein, jeder Grafiktreiber hat so ein Kram dabei.
Aber warum nicht? Ja, dann ist es eine einheitliche Oberfläche.
Mich würde halt interessieren, sind die auch... Wie sieht's da mit der Performance aus? Das würde mich interessieren.
Weil ich weiß, dass halt die ganze Shadowplay-Geschichte und all das ist...
Bezieht im Endeffekt nichts.
So, wie es da aussieht, weiß ich nicht.
Klar hat Nvidia eine Overlay für FPS...
Achso, RAM-Usage. Das stimmt, das stimmt.
RAM-Usage haben sie, aber was interessiert mich RAM-Usage?
FPS-Overlay, natürlich hat Nvidia FPS-Overlay.
Das ist doch das Einzige, was sie haben.
Hier, da.
Hier.
Da.
Kannst du einplayen.
Fps-Counter.
Alt-Z.
Big-Brain-Shortcut.
Das ist das Emoji, ne?
Macht's doch jetzt schon.
Muss man dafür GeForce-Experience installiert haben? Ja, ja, klar.
Emoji? K-Emoji? Ich weiß nicht, ob ich das richtig bezeichne.
Ach stimmt, der Kram ist jetzt neu, ja. Das hab ich auch schon mal gelesen.
Version 2004 introduces several new K-Emoji.
I'll just stick with that pronunciation.
Okay.
Wenn man's braucht.
Moving on.
If there is one thing you can always count on with a new release of Windows 10,
it's new features coming to the Windows Settings.
Windows 10 2004 continues the long quest of moving pieces from the control panel over to the Windows Settings.
In the Network and Internet section, Microsoft updated the Network Status page
with a new design that highlights networks you're currently connected to on your PC.
In this page you can also view data usage and set data...
Nur mit dem Unterschied, dass die Netzwerks-Settings in dem neuen Settings-Menü immer noch wahnsinnig scheiße sind.
Ich hab's mal versucht...
Ihr guckt mal. Also.
Nur mal zum Vergleich.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie komm ich denn da überhaupt jetzt hin?
Äh...
Hier. So.
Mal angenommen, ich will jetzt rauskriegen, wie ist denn meine MAC-Adresse?
Ethernet.
Connected?
Zwei?
Aha.
Immerhin.
Da steht sie.
Ähm...
Edit?
Okay, man kann mittlerweile DNS und alles ändern.
Wie mach ich das Interface an und aus?
Also mal angenommen, ich will jetzt das Interface ausschalten.
Wie mach ich das?
Geht nicht, oder?
Change Adapter Options?
Ah, das ist das alte.
Ja klar, dass es über das alte Menü geht, weiß ich.
Ne?
Dass es über das alte Menü geht mit Disable, das weiß ich.
Aber, ähm...
Über das neue?
Da ist nur die Hälfte wieder drin.
Ich hör, was ist mit Microsoft los?
Ah, bitte.
Auch diese ganzen Dinger, die man so gut wie nie braucht, aber man kann einfach...
Ich weiß auch nicht, warum sie das unbedingt...
Und ich muss euch ehrlich sagen, ich hab's nicht verstanden.
Und ich muss euch ehrlich sagen, ja.
Ähm...
So altbacken das manchmal wirkt...
Geht überhaupt OBS noch, ja?
So altbacken das manchmal wirkt, dieses...
Ähm...
Diese Menüs hier, ich find die eigentlich ganz schick.
Die XP-Style-Menüs.
Ich find die eigentlich ganz schick.
Die haben so den...
Die haben die Zeit ganz gut überstanden.
Da gibt's doch eigentlich...
Da gibt's doch nix großartiges gegen zu sagen.
Das sind relativ hübsche Icons.
Du erkennst...
Du erkennst gleich, ob der Kram an und aus ist.
Das hier sieht auch halbwegs okay aus.
Also, ich versteh die Existenzberechtigung dieser neuen Settings-Menüs ehrlich gesagt nicht.
Man hätte hier sicherlich die Sachen ein bisschen aufgeräumter machen können.
Ein bisschen logischer, ein bisschen schöner machen können.
Keine Frage.
Aber wozu braucht man überhaupt das neue Settings-Menü?
Hab ich seit Anfang an nicht verstanden.
Wegen Tablet-Freundlichkeit.
Dann sollte man das konsequent machen.
Und das ist was, was Microsoft nicht kann.
Wenn man es wegen Tablet-Freundlichkeit...
Wenn man sagt, ja, ist Tablet-Freundlichkeit...
Das ist natürlich Tablet-mäßig scheiße zu bedienen.
Das geht nicht.
Wenn man sagt, ja, wir wollen es Tablet-freundlich machen.
Und wir können das alte nicht Tablet-freundlich umbauen.
Wir machen was Neues.
Dann konsequent.
Man muss sich mal vorstellen, die brauchen jetzt...
Wann kam Windows 10 raus?
2015 oder so?
Oder 2017?
Wann war Windows 10 Release?
2015.
Die machen jetzt 5 Jahre, 5 Jahre an diesem Settings-Menü rum.
Und die Optionen, die halt nur manchmal wichtig sind,
aber dafür dann ziemlich wichtig,
die haben es immer noch nicht reingeschafft.
Seit 5 Jahren.
Also sowas Halbherziges habe ich selten gesehen.
Das war ja auch nicht was da mit Microsoft los ist.
Das ist ganz cool,
dass man jetzt einzelne Anwendungen anscheinend limitieren kann.
Okay, nice.
...Limits for your networks individually.
Additionally, Windows 10 Version 2004 will now let users control
how much internet bandwidth Windows Update can use in the background.
Das ist tatsächlich ganz gut.
...update and security, delivery optimization, advanced options
and configure the settings here.
Ich meine, aber jetzt mal ernsthaft, das ist doch kein schönes Menü.
Das ist doch ernsthaft kein schönes Menü.
Das sieht aus wie eine HTML-Form.
Ohne jegliches Styling.
Das sieht hässlich wie die Nacht aus.
Einfach untereinander, einfach untereinander Form-Dinger geschrieben.
Das sieht nicht gut aus.
Und übersichtlich schon mal gar nicht.
Das ist wirklich eine HTML-Form,
wo dann vielleicht jemand noch so pro war und hat gesagt,
Body, Background, Color, Black.
Fertig.
...where you can now change the pointer speed of your mouse
directly from the Windows settings.
Previously you had to click on a link that would redirect you to an old control panel.
Und was da fehlt, oh, ich wollte gerade sagen, was da fehlt, sind Zahlen,
aber wenigstens kommt die Zahl beim Overlay.
...page to change this.
Wo kann man die Mausbeschleunigung ausschalten?
Wo ist Mausbeschleunigung?
Wie kann man die Mausbeschleunigung ausschalten?
Das muss ich jetzt mal kurz gucken hier.
Maus.
Das geht nur über das alte Mausmenü.
Moment, wo ist es denn?
Ne, Moment, wo ist es denn?
Das da, ne?
Enhanced Pointer Position ist Mausbeschleunigung, oder?
Was ist das doch?
Das ist doch lächerlich.
Das ist doch ein Witz.
Mausbeschleunigung ist das erste, was man als Gamer braucht, was man ausschaltet.
Das ist so, so, so was, so, ich wollte gerade sagen, nichts Halbes und nichts Ganzes,
aber das ist eher ein Viertel und nichts Ganzes.
Außerdem, in der Ease-of-Access-Sektion in den Windows-Settings,
haben Kursor und Pointer sich in ihre eigenen Pages separiert.
Ja, das hat er.
Das habe ich schon immer gebraucht, so ein Ding.
Aber das ist ja alles ganz nett.
Das ist ja alles ganz nett.
Es ist ja auch okay, dass das da ist,
aber wie wäre es denn erst mal, die Sachen, die man schon vor fünf Jahren angefangen hat,
mal ordentlich fertig zu machen?
Endlich.
Na, endlich.
Wie wäre es mit ganz normalem, ich gebe ein Passwort, einen Login und dann geht mir Windows nicht mehr auf den Sack?
Endlich.
Die Passwort-Option wurde immer auf der Lock-Screen aufgestellt,
im Gegensatz zu anderen Sign-In-Methoden, die Sie aufgestellt haben.
In Windows 10 2004 können Sie jetzt die Passwort-Login von der Lock-Screen auswählen,
um nur eine Windows Hello-Pin, Face oder Fingerprint-Unlock zu signen.
Sie können diese Settings konfigurieren,
wenn Sie auf die Accounts und Sign-In-Options navigieren.
Um diese neuen Sign-In-Changes zu komplementieren,
kann Microsoft Windows Hello-Sign-In,
beziehungsweise Pin, Biometrik, Fingerprint, Face usw.,
wenn Sie Windows in Safe-Mode nutzen.
Für diejenigen, die es nicht wissen,
ist Safe-Mode eine Feature, die Windows mit einem bekannten Set von Fahrzeugen und Features startet.
Wo ist der Unterschied zwischen Pin und Passwort?
Ich würde sagen, Pin ist diese Geschichte mit Nummer und Block
und nach dreimal falsch eingeben irgendwie warten
und Passwort ist halt Passwort, wie man will.
Würde ich jetzt mal vermuten.
...which can be useful for troubleshooting and diagnosing issues on your PC.
When you sign out or shut down your Windows PC with apps running,
Windows will attempt to reopen those apps when you sign back in.
In Windows 10 Version 2004,
EWP-Apps will now be able to restart automatically in addition to the...
Ha! UWP!
UWP ist so dead.
Ist auch wieder sowas, was Microsoft verschissen hat.
An sich finde ich, also das UI von UWP ist eine super Geschichte.
Also wenn man WPF und diese ganze SAML-Geschichte mag,
ist das UI von UWP gut, der Rest drumherum ist furchtbar.
Zumal man als Hobby-Entwickler gar keine UWP-Apps programmieren kann,
weil man ein Codesign-Zertifikat braucht und niemand,
wirklich niemand, der hobbymäßig Anwendungen entwickelt,
hat ein Codesigning-Zertifikat für irgendwie 350 Euro im Jahr.
...the existing list of registered legacy desktop apps,
which were able to do so previously.
You can find this setting under Accounts and Sign-In Options...
Zeitläutung ist einfacher geworden.
...du bist in der Lage, das zu machen.
Du brauchst aber immer noch ein gültiges Zertifikat.
Oder aber, oder aber, die Leute müssen...
Doch, brauchst du.
Oder aber, außer bei dir auf dem Rechner.
Oder aber, die Leute müssen dein Self-Sign-Zertifikat akzeptieren.
Ja, ich weiß, dass Self-Sign geht,
aber dann kriegen die Leute einen Pop-up,
wo sie erstens Admin-Rechte für brauchen, für Self-Sign.
Du brauchst Admin-Rechte für Self-Sign
um das in den Trust-Store einzufügen.
Und die Leute müssen der Sache vertrauen.
Das ist Fail.
Das ist einfach nur Fail.
Deswegen macht keine Hobby-mäßig-UWP-Apps.
Ich habe kein neues Mikrofon.
Ich habe ein bisschen Kompressor-Settings rumgestellt.
Du brauchst Admin-Berechtigung
und die Leute müssen einen zusätzlichen Installer-Schritt machen,
indem sie ein Zertifikat vertrauen.
Was der normale User mal wieder überhaupt nicht checkt.
Ich habe gedacht, was ist das für ein scheiß Installer?
Warum geht denn das nicht?
Einfach Fail.
Deswegen macht auch niemand UWP-Apps.
Wenn du dein PC von den Windows-Settings wieder aufbauen kannst,
kannst du jetzt wählen,
dass du dein PC wieder aufbauen kannst
via einen Cloud-Download,
der eine neue Kopie von Windows 10 aufbaut,
um Microsoft auf deinem PC zu reinstalieren,
anstatt eine Kopie von dem, die du bereits aufbauen hast.
Ich hätte eine Idee.
Microsoft könnte einfach auf ihre Seite schreiben,
hier ISO-Download.
Habe ich euch eigentlich schon.
Habe ich.
Aber ich zeige es euch nochmal.
Kennt ihr eigentlich den geilsten,
den besten Windows-Hack 2020?
Den zeige ich euch jetzt hier.
Exklusiv hier.
Windows-Hack-Sore.
Ultra-Hack-Sore-Hyper-Trick.
Jede Nicht-UWP-App mit einem Installer,
der nach 10...
Ja, das stimmt, da hast du recht.
Aber ich installiere die meisten Sachen.
Die meisten Sachen brauchen keine Admin-Berechtigung.
Du installierst einfach ein App in App-Folder.
So, also.
Geht nicht.
Man kann ja keine...
Keine ISOs mehr runterladen von Microsoft.
Aber jetzt kommt es.
Der Kommentator kennt es noch oder wusste es schon.
Man kann ja nur noch dieses komische Tool runterladen.
Aber, wenn man jetzt hier in die Browser-Settings geht
und die mobile Ansicht einschaltet,
dann...
Wow, fuck.
Ich habe es kaputt gemacht.
Wenn man die mobile Ansicht einschaltet
und erstmal reloadet
und ihr seht es,
schon, schon kann man ein ISO runterladen.
Excellent, oder?
Schon kann man ein ISO runterladen.
Easy.
Man muss einfach...
Seinen Browser auf Mobile-Device stellen.
Und schon kann man ein Windows-ISO runterladen.
64-Bit, Windows 10, Englisch, ISO.
Eats.
Das ist mal Big Brain, oder?
So muss das sein.
Warum darf der Mauszeiger vor meinem...
Warum darf der Mauszeiger vor meinem Bild sein hier?
Anzeige ist raus.
So, jetzt habe ich euch den Hyper-Windows-Hack gezeigt.
Reveal.
Nur hier.
Worldwide first.
This option can be useful for achieving a...
cleaner, I guess, installation of Windows.
Finally, Windows 10 Version 2004 makes it easier to configure
how you receive notifications on your PC.
When a notification post appears...
Das Notification-Menü.
Ich könnte jetzt ja wieder eine Umfrage machen.
Verwendet jemand das Notification-Menü?
Ich gucke da nie rein.
Ich verwende es nicht.
Ich habe schon mal im Stream gefragt, ob es Leute verwenden.
Und ich weiß, dass tatsächlich es ein paar Leute verwenden.
Um die Notifications loszuladen.
Ich verwende gar kein Windows.
Ja, komme ich leider nicht drumherum.
Würde ich auch gerne.
Ja, das verwendet irgendwie kein Mensch.
Oder wenige, wenige.
Es hat jetzt ein kleines Settings-Button.
Dieses Settings-Button lässt euch die Notifikationen von dieser App komplett auswählen.
Oder ihr könnt...
Es gibt zusätzliche Optionen für Notifikationen von dieser App in den Windows-Settings.
Windows 10 ist mittlerweile so ein komischer Hybrid aus Touch, Mobile und Desktop-Betriebssystem,
was an keiner Stelle weiß, was es sein will.
Das ist der Wahnsinn.
SwiftPair ist eine Feature, die von vielen Microsoft-Bluetooth-Anschlüssen unterstützt wird.
In Windows 10 Version 2004 ist es jetzt einfacher, ein unterstütztes SwiftPair-Device zu verbinden.
Einfach drücken und halten den Bluetooth-Button auf deinem Anlass.
Und eine Notifikation.
Eine Notifikation wird auf deinem PC erscheinen, die dich dazu ermittelt, das Gerät zu verbinden.
Durch Klicken auf Verbinden wird dein Gerät zu deinem PC verbunden, ohne weitere Schritte.
Es gibt viele weitere Änderungen zu dieser Eröffnung von Windows 10,
inklusive extender Sprache- und Zugangssicherheit und große Verbesserungen zu dem Windows-Subsystem für Linux 2.
Du kannst mehr detaillierte Informationen finden,
über all diese Features und Blog-Posts von den Ingenieuren bei Microsoft.
Außer der kleinen Liste von neuen Features,
erhöht Windows 10 Version 2004 die Sicherheit und Verliebtheit von Windows 10.
Diese Update wird in der Zeit nach dem Jahr 2004 für das genaue Publikum starten.
Wenn diese Zeit kommt, kannst du sie durch die Update-Seite in der Windows-Update-Sektion der Windows-Settings beobachten.
Das war ich, Cody von onmicrosoft.com.
Wenn dir dieses Video geholfen hat, abonniere, like dieses Video und schau auf onmicrosoft.com für mehr Info.
Danke und bis bald.
Das war ein ganz guter Witz am Ende.
Ist voll untergegangen.
Gut.
Ähm, ja.
Wir wissen, dass nichts wirklich Bahnbrechendes Neues kommt im neuen Windows.
Juckt uns, juckt mich persönlich gar nicht.
Ja, das war Minecraft.
Das hat man gesehen, als der den Kirchenturm gescreenshottet hat.
Geh, was macht denn der Auer Neues?
Wir haben eine AMD-CPU auf über 8,1 GHz getaktet.
Oh, da kommt flüssig Stickstoff wieder an den Start.
Gucken wir uns mal an.
Aber vielleicht spulen wir ein bisschen vor, wo es losgeht.
Hallo zusammen, herzlich willkommen zu einem weiteren Video.
Heute machen wir flüssig Stickstoff-Overclocking und zwar mit einem AMD FX8000.
Wann kommt WSL2? Ist das nicht schon?
...150. Die CPU besitze ich schon mehrere Jahre.
Ich habe mir damals eine einzige von diesen CPUs gekauft.
Hatte einfach unfassbares Glück mit dieser CPU.
Lief extrem gut damals.
War eine der besten CPUs, die es damals bei HWBoot gab.
Ist, glaube ich, immer noch in den Top 20 CPUs, der jemals am höchsten erreichten.
Bei den höchsten Frequenzen, wie auch immer.
Und damals habe ich das mit einem Asus Crosshair 5-Formular gemacht.
Also einem Mainboard, das schon deutlich in die Jahre gekommen ist.
Und mittlerweile gibt es ja das Asus 970 Pro Gaming Aura.
Also gibt es ja auch schon seit einigen Jahren.
Pro Gaming Aura.
Guter Mainboard-Namen.
Aber es ist ein deutlich besseres Board für Sockel AM3.
Deswegen dachte ich, wir probieren das nochmal aus.
Ob wir die Ergebnisse reproduzieren können von damals oder vielleicht sogar übertreffen können.
Weil wir haben eine deutlich bessere Spannungsversorgung bei dem 970 Pro Gaming.
Und ich habe auch noch zusätzlich ein relativ cooles Feature dran hier.
Diese kleine Platine.
Ich würde jetzt sagen, ich zeige euch einfach mal was das ist.
Ich habe es am Anfang nicht richtig aufgepasst.
Was hat er denn für eine CPU?
Dieses Video wird unterstützt von der neuen Wireless-FPS-Gaming-Maus Darkie.
Der macht genau das entgegengesetzte Ende von Linus Tech Tips.
Linus Tech Tips macht das immer so richtig smooth integriert.
Und bei ihm denke ich immer, okay, er liest jetzt einfach den Zettel ab.
Den mir der Hersteller geschickt hat.
SX8350, oje, das ist ja wirklich alt.
RGB Pro SE von Corsair.
Die kabellose Premium-Maus eignet sich entgegen...
Der liest das immer so geil ab.
...Urteile durch die Corsair Slip.
Auch die...
... und bietet...
Das Board ist auch noch nicht vorbereitet für Extreme Overclocking.
Das müssen wir gleich machen.
Aktuell ein AMD Boxkühler drauf.
Den habe ich einfach draufgepackt, dass ich Windows vorbereiten konnte.
Windows ist hier...
RGB-Kühler, der Beste.
Wir haben zwei Corsair Vengeance DDR3 Sticks.
2666 C10.
Sehr, sehr gute RAM-Riegel.
Werden wir aber nicht wirklich verwenden heute.
Weil wir eigentlich nur CPU-Z validieren wollen.
Vielleicht ein bisschen Cinebench machen wollen.
Das ist so der Fokus für heute.
Und ihr seht hier oben.
Hier habe ich ein Kabel ran gelötet.
Hier oben ist so ein...
Oh, Hacker, Hacker-Man.
...ein Schluss.
Normalerweise sind da einfach nur drei Lötpunkte.
Da ist nichts drauf.
Ich habe dann eine Stiftleiste drauf gelötet.
Und dann dieses Kabel angeschlossen.
Und dieses Kabel geht zu dieser kleinen Platine.
Morpheus hat Subscribed.
Dankeschön.
Drei Monate.
Huge Sub.
Hier seht ihr jetzt die ELMO EVC 2 Software.
Hier angeschlossen an den I2C Bus 1.
Da klickt man hier einfach auf Find Device.
Dann stellt er schon fest.
Wir haben hier den CHL3.
I2C habe ich noch nie gehört.
Ich kenne nur die englische I2C.
Aber ich habe mir das noch nicht überlegt,
wenn man das auf Deutsch ausspricht.
Warum Windows für Overclocking?
Ich vermute mal, weil es die ganze Software
nur für Windows gibt,
die immer die Profi-Overclocker benutzen.
8128.
Das ist unser Spannungswandler-Controller.
Den kann man dann hier links auswählen.
Dann hat man hier alle möglichen Werte,
die im Spannungswandler hinterlegt sind.
Also die Schaltfrequenz zum Beispiel.
300 Kilohertz ist hier eingestellt.
Wir haben Details.
Ich wollte immer schon mal die Schaltfrequenz
von meinem Spannungswandler.
Halibration-Konfigurierung.
Stellsohn 99 ist auch da.
Ist hier alles schon hinterlegt.
High-IQ-Software.
Also auch natürlich von diesem Spannungswandler-Controller.
Dann haben wir hier auch die volle Kontrolle.
Stimmt.
Die Software muss ja auf einem anderen Rechner sein.
Sonst könnte er ja nicht während er übertaktet das benutzen.
Das habe ich schon gemacht.
Gamer-VID-Type Override.
Und dann kann ich hier ganz einfach
die CPU-Kernspannung extern einstellen.
Und das Coole daran ist,
viele Boards, gerade wenn die jetzt nicht unbedingt
für Extreme-Overclocking gemacht sind,
haben diverse Spannungslimits.
Also die können dann zum Beispiel
über 1,55 Volt gehen oder sowas.
Und ihr seht, wenn ich jetzt hier runterscrolle,
könnte ich problemlos 2,5 Volt einstellen.
Das wäre natürlich das Ende für die CPU.
Das wollen wir nicht.
Aber wir können jetzt einfach mal beispielsweise
1,3 ist gerade eingestellt.
Dann stellen wir das auf 1,325.
Ihr seht auch hier Output-Voltage.
Das wird hier auch gerade alles...
Man sollte einfach seine CPU mit 48 Volt PoE betreiben.
Für Maximum-Overclock.
Aktiv gemessen.
Dann haben wir nicht nur die CPU-Kernspannung,
sondern wir haben auch die Leistung,
was sehr interessant ist.
Wir haben hier immer wieder so Spitzen.
Ich weiß nicht genau, was Windows da macht.
Also im Idle immer so...
Das weiß Windows selber nicht.
10, 20 Watt.
Also interessante Lastspitzen,
die da immer wieder kommen.
Wenn wir jetzt auf Apply Changes gehen
und drücken OK, dann seht ihr hier...
Exzellente, exzellente Warnung, oder?
Interessante Lastspitzen,
die da immer wieder kommen.
Wenn wir jetzt auf Apply Changes gehen...
Ah, right.
D2 gleich D330.
Alles klar.
Und drücken OK.
Dann seht ihr hier...
Da, wo jetzt mein Cursor ist,
hatten wir 1,3 Volt.
Wie zufrieden bist du mit dem Doorbird
als Türsprecheranlage?
Den hatte ich mir nämlich auch mal angeguckt.
Wenn wir jetzt hier ganz nach rechts gehen quasi,
auf den aktuellen Punkt,
haben wir 1,326 Volt.
Also so können wir jetzt im laufenden Betrieb
ganz einfach die Kernspannung ändern,
ohne dass wir eine Software verwenden müssen
am System.
Und ohne,
dass wir ein spezielles BIOS brauchen,
wo die Werte freigeschaltet sind.
Also das ist wirklich eine extrem coole Sache.
Funktioniert mit einer riesen Anzahl von Mainboards
und natürlich auch mit Grafikkarten.
Also sehr, sehr interessantes Tool.
Das ELMO EVC ist da wirklich ein extrem hilfreiches Tool.
Das haben wir auch schon in vielen von meinen Videos verwendet,
damals als wir Epic zum Beispiel übertaktet haben.
Da kann man auch lustige Sachen mitmachen,
wie Mainboard BIOS zu flashen,
die eigentlich gar nicht dafür gedacht sind.
Wir haben damals zum Beispiel ein MSI BIOS
auf ein Asus Board geflasht.
Weil das EVC 2 auch erlaubt,
quasi einen Hardflash zu machen.
Man überschreibt einfach alles,
was auf dem BIOS Baustein drauf ist.
Kann man sehr, sehr cool mit dem Experiment...
Das sind aber so Sachen,
so Sachen macht man aber nur,
wenn man auf die Hardware nicht angewiesen ist.
Einfach mal so random,
irgendwelche BIOS Versionen,
die nicht für das Board sind, zu flashen.
Ist glaube ich,
wenn man den Rechner auch braucht,
keine gute Idee.
Den kostet auch nur 35 Dollar,
wenn ich es richtig in Erinnerung habe.
Ich weiß auch nicht,
wie lange es das Teil noch gibt.
Deswegen,
falls ihr auch so viel experimentiert,
kann ich euch nur ans Herz legen.
Schaut euch das sehr, sehr gerne mal an.
Wie gesagt,
erlaubt bei den meisten Mainboards
und Grafikkarten,
die Spannung zu ändern,
wenn es ein digitaler Controller ist.
Erlaubt aber das auch,
wenn es kein digitaler ist.
Das ist ein bisschen schwieriger.
Vielleicht covern wir das mal
in einem extra Video,
wie man das macht,
wenn euch das interessiert.
Ansonsten habe ich das Setup
soweit schon fertig vorbereitet.
Windows ist drauf.
EVC ist dran.
Das EVC haben wir übrigens dran.
Das was?
Dass wir, wenn wir
die Frequenz ändern,
gerade so im absoluten Grenzbereich,
dass wir dann nicht mehr
die Spannung anfassen müssen.
Was?
Was ist das EVC?
Ah, okay.
Das Ding, wo wir gerade
das Tool vorhin gesehen haben, oder wie?
Manchmal ist es auch so,
wenn man,
ich sag mal,
sich in der Region von 7 GHz,
8 GHz bewegt
und die CPU so am absoluten Limit läuft.
Einfach mal 8 GHz.
Manchmal crasht die dann so ein bisschen,
wenn man zu sehr übers Limit geht.
Wenn man dann die Spannung noch erhöht,
dann fängt die sich manchmal wieder.
Dann kriegt man das System wieder stabil.
Man kann das aber dann nicht am System selber machen,
weil logischerweise dann die Software
im Moment gar nicht funktionieren würde.
Deswegen ist es extrem hilfreich,
das Ganze extern über einen extra Laptop zu machen.
Dann hat man volle Kontrolle darüber,
ohne per Software was ändern zu müssen.
Das ist der Grund,
warum ich das gemacht habe
und dass wir auch,
vielleicht interessanterweise,
während wir extrem hohe Frequenzen haben,
uns anschauen,
wie verändert sich die Leistungsaufnahme von der CPU.
Oh mein Gott.
Ich weiß nicht,
was ich gerade mehr hassen soll.
Mich selbst oder
mal wieder die AMD-Halterung.
Die klebt mal wieder an der CPU.
Dann schön abkratzen jetzt.
Kühler, die CPU.
Ja.
Und hier sind leider einige Pins verbogen.
Verdammt.
Ich hoffe,
ich kriege die gerade gebogen,
ohne dass die abbrechen.
Ich würde mich wirklich, wirklich hassen,
wenn das jetzt einfach in die Hose geht.
Wenn es abbricht,
kein Problem,
einfach wieder dranlöten.
Eats.
Und passt.
Ja.
Nice.
Okay, die CPU ist jetzt wieder im Sockel.
Ich habe jetzt mal provisorisch
noch mal schnell alles aufgebaut,
bevor wir gleich anfangen,
das Mainboard zu isolieren
und alles vorzubereiten für Steam-Overclocking.
Lieber noch mal schnell CPU einbauen,
schauen, ob alles funktioniert.
Dafür kurz noch eine ältere PCI-Debug-Karte reingesteckt
und dann schauen wir mal kurz,
was passiert.
Das sieht gut aus.
Moment.
Das Mainboard hat ein PCI?
Sehe ich das richtig?
Warum hat das Mainboard ein PCI?
Ah, das ist ja kein neues Mainboard.
Das ist ja,
ah, ja, ja, stimmt,
hast du recht.
Das ist ja,
ich habe,
ich habe es ganz verdrängt,
dass das ja eine uralte CPU ist.
Das,
das,
ja, ja,
das ist ja eine uralte,
ich war gerade,
ich habe gerade,
ja, ja,
logisch.
Das ist zehn Jahre alt.
Bei den CPUs der FX-Reihe,
also alles,
was 8000er-Generation ist,
wie das hier
oder auch 9000er,
4000er und so weiter,
können wir Full-Pod machen.
Das bedeutet,
wir füllen den Flüssig-Schickstoff-Container komplett,
haben dadurch circa minus 190 Grad Celsius bei der CPU.
Excellent.
Und das führt natürlich dazu,
dass da alles ziemlich schnell ein-eist
und auch relativ viel Kondenswasser sich bilden kann.
Dementsprechend müssen wir das Board
ein bisschen vorbereiten,
weil das wurde noch nie verwendet
für Flüssig-Schickstoff- oder Extreme-Overclocking.
Das heißt,
wir müssen die Heatsinks abbauen,
weil hier ist es so,
in dem Bereich,
da ist es so kalt,
da bildet sich kein Kondenswasser.
Da wäre alles Eis.
Eis ist nicht elektrisch leistbar.
Das heißt,
es ist nicht zeitfähig.
Da wäre es kein Problem.
In diesem Bereich
und gerade,
weil wir Abwärme hier drunter haben,
bildet sich hier sehr schnell an dieser Grenze Kondenswasser.
Das bedeutet,
Heatsinks abbauen
und darunter auf jeden Fall isolieren.
An dem Hobby muss man Spaß haben.
Übrigens öfter,
wenn man mal...
Also wirklich springen tut es ja nichts.
Das ist einfach so,
wie ich auch an irgendwelchen Technik-Sachen
stundenlang rumbasteln kann.
Einfach weil es nice ist
und nicht,
weil es jetzt irgendwie großartig was bringt.
Das waren da Kühler
oder generell Kühler mit Wärmeleitpads entfernt.
Findet sich so ein Bild.
Das sieht dann aus,
als wäre irgendwas ausgelaufen.
Und das ist in der Regel einfach Silikonöl,
das sich aus den Wärmeleitpads herausgelöst hat.
Kein Problem.
Ist ja auch nicht elektrisch leistfähig.
Aber wir wollen Flüssiggummi auftragen
und dafür müssen wir das Öl entfernen.
Einfach mit ein bisschen Aceton abwischen.
Wenn ich was isolieren wollte,
würde ich wahrscheinlich einfach
mit meinem Heißkleber einmal drüber heißkleben.
Und gut ist.
Was du wahrscheinlich schlecht wieder abkriegst.
Ja, ist keine gute Idee.
Stimmt schon.
Wir brauchen ein Video mit dir und dem Bauer.
Ich wüsste nicht,
ich bin nicht der große Overclocker.
Keine Ahnung, was man da zusammen machen könnte.
Und naja,
das ist glaube ich keine so fruchtbare Cooperation.
Zumal ich auf YouTube absolut nichts mache gerade.
Soweit ist jetzt wieder alles montiert.
Die Isolation ist getrocknet.
Jetzt noch Wärmeleitpaste drauf.
CPU-Kühler montieren.
Temperatursensor im CPU-Kühler.
Das ist hier für den Tank, oder?
Nicht vergessen.
Und dann ein bisschen mit Küchpapier oder Klopapier.
Wie kommt man an flüssigen Stillstoff ran?
Kann man wohl im Baumarkt holen oder so?
Irgendeiner, da habe ich mich letztens auch gefragt.
Und irgendjemand meinte, kriegt man im Baumarkt.
Weiß nicht, ob das stimmt.
Habe ich noch nie gekauft.
Hast du noch Kontakt mit dem Friseur?
Klar.
Der Friseur spielt komische Mobile Games.
Wir hoffen, dass wir gegebenenfalls entstehendes Kondenswasser auffangen.
Und dann geht's los.
Made in Germany.
Ist das nicht gefährlich, den Stickstoff so reinzuschütten?
Nö.
Muss halt treffen.
Alles klar.
Die Plattform läuft soweit.
Ich habe jetzt kurz ein bisschen Flüssigstickstoff reingekippt,
damit das Ganze nicht überhitzt.
Wir haben aktuell eine Temperatur am Kühlerboden von knapp 30 Grad Celsius.
Cinebench R15 läuft gerade durch im Multi.
Und wir starten mit einem CPU-Takt von 3 GHz auf allen Kernen,
weil wir ja nur ein Modul hochtakten wollen.
Die anderen drei Module bleiben ein bisschen niedriger.
Ah, so.
Ja gut, ist ja auch klar.
Kannst ja nicht alle, wie viele Kerne hatte das?
Vier oder so?
Oder acht?
Diese acht Fake-Kerne hatte das keine Ahnung.
Kannst nicht alles übertakten.
Einer macht das garantiert nicht mit.
Skategirl.
Was ist denn das? Skategirl?
Läuft auf 2000 MHz.
CL9 spielt für das, was wir heute machen wollen, eigentlich keine große Rolle.
Haben jetzt ein relativ niedriges Ergebnis von 460 Punkten.
Das passt aber, weil die CPU ja relativ niedrig getaktet ist im Moment.
Und in der ELMO EVC-Software passt auch alles.
Hier können wir sehen, hatten wir zum Beispiel während dem Benchmark-Run
CPU-Leistungsaufnahme ca. 160 Watt im R15.
Boah, die CPU hat ja richtig Strom gefressen damals.
WTF?
16 Watt.
Und hier rechts sehen wir dann zum Beispiel auch sehr, sehr gut.
Spannungsveränderung der Temperatur war hier maximal bei 66 Grad Celsius.
Also auch sehr, sehr guter Wert.
Jetzt wird geschüttet.
Blubber, blubber, blubber.
Full Pot.
Jetzt wird es schön kühl.
Was ist das für eine CPU? Irgendeine uralte FX.
Ich habe es vergessen. FX8000 irgendwas.
Und jetzt wird noch gepustet?
Ah, zieht der...
Ist das irgendwie das Gas, was da rauskommt?
Für was ist der Lüfter?
Wegsaugen in Kondenswasser.
Wow.
Was zum...
Warum hat er da jetzt noch die Dings, die Heißluft reingestoben?
Warum?
Verstehe ich nicht.
Das wurde zu kalt.
Im Moment habe ich folgendes Problem.
Und zwar...
Alles ist schon relativ kühl.
Wir haben hier circa minus 125 Grad Celsius.
Und wenn ich jetzt runterkühle auf minus 160, dann geht alles aus.
Also ich muss gerade herausfinden, warum wir einen Cold Bug auf dieser Plattform haben.
Was normalerweise bei diesen CPUs nicht der Fall sein sollte.
Ah, wenn es zu kalt ist, geht es kaputt.
Jetzt bin ich bei minus 170.
Und es funktioniert noch.
Das ist ja wieder ein typischer Vorführ-Effekt.
Ich sitze jetzt gerade seit einer halben Stunde an diesem Problem.
Gut, ich habe jetzt gerade im BIOS ein bisschen was umgestellt.
Habe ein paar Features deaktiviert.
Also ein paar CPU-Features, Onboard-Features.
Vielleicht hat das...
Relativ kühl.
Ach komm, es ist nur 170.
Das ist ja geil.
Minus 170.
Wir sind gerade bei 1,9 Volt.
Das ist schon relativ viel.
Im Elmore EVC habe ich 1,85 V-Core.
Wir haben circa 50 bis 70 Watt gerade unter Last, obwohl wir nichts machen.
Das ist einfach nur, weil die Frequenz so hoch ist.
Sieht man auch hier relativ gut.
30 Ampere.
Die Spannungswerte natürlich lesen nur noch 1 Grad Celsius aus.
7800.
1,9 Volt ist ordentlich.
Ich weiß nicht, was die Dinger normalerweise hatten für eine V-Core-Dingspannung.
Aber 1,9 erscheint mir jetzt relativ hoch.
Wahrscheinlich ist es normal 1,3 oder 1,2.
Ich weiß nicht, was da normal ist.
1,3, ja.
Das ist auf jeden Fall ordentlich.
Da haben wir es.
8 V-Cores auf der CPU.
Was ist normal?
Was hat der normal?
FX 8053.
Was ist Standard?
Boost ist 4,2.
Okay, es ist auf jeden Fall mehr als das Doppelte.
Hier sieht man übrigens sehr, sehr gut, was Extreme Overclocking so einem Mainboard antun
kann.
Ich hoffe, ihr könnt sehen, wie stark das Mainboard gebogen ist.
Und es ist nicht wegen dem Flüssigkeits-Signal, sondern es ist nicht wegen dem Flüssigkeits-Signal,
sondern es ist nicht wegen dem Flüssigkeits-Signal, sondern es ist nicht wegen dem Flüssigkeits-Signal,
sondern weil eben das alles so kalt ist und da unterschiedliche Kupferlayer drauf sind
in unterschiedlichen Dicken, in unterschiedlichen Ebenen und somit verzieht sich das Board durch
kälte einfach enorm weil wir hier gerade erst mal schön erst mal schön drauf klopfen 80 grad
celsius haben aber im moment läuft eigentlich alles ganz gut ich probiere es jetzt ungefähr
zum zehnten mal so richtung 8,2 gigahertz zu gehen ist nicht ganz einfach aber ich bin noch dran
wohl wohl kam kälte wohl kann man sollte jetzt sich vielleicht nicht verschütten das system
läuft weiter fröhlich vor sich hin ist natürlich mittlerweile schon gut eingeheizt nach circa zwei
oder drei stunden die ich jetzt schon dabei bin würde ich mal schätzen und gerade mache ich noch
einen cinebench f 15 single core bei knapp 7,5 gigahertz einfach mal rein aus interesse also
man sieht schon das dauert relativ lang aber ich wollte einfach mal wissen wieso eine cpu bei 7,5
gigahertz ist von der geschwindigkeit verglichen mit einer cpu heute stock ich glaube dass das
diese cpu selbst bei 7,5 gigahertz noch deutlich langsamer sein wird 172 punkte das ist gar nicht
so schlecht das ist so ein bisschen über dem niveau von dem 47 70 k schauen wir mal ob noch
höher geht wir haben hierbei übrigens eine leistungsaufnahme von circa 100 watt wenn man
das bedenkt dass das nur ein einzelner cpu kann ist das ist natürlich schon echt enorm damit sind
wir jetzt auch tatsächlich schon am ende angekommen denn ich habe einfach keinen flüssigstichstoff mehr
ich hatte insgesamt 30 liter die habe ich auch noch von der anderen cpu benutzt das video
kommt in einigen wochen trotzdem 8350 einfach sehr sehr sehr schöne cpu einfach die tatsache
dass man damit relativ einfach 8 gigahertz erreichen kann was mit keiner anderen heutigen
cpu möglich ist egal ob es ein aktueller ryzen ist egal ob es eine aktuelle intel cpu ist die
aktuellen intel cpus schaffen mit flüssigstichstoff etwas über 7 gigahertz mit flüssig helium etwa 7,5
7,7 gigahertz aber auch die erreichen keine 8 gigahertz dementsprechend sind diese cpus bulldozer
sehr speziell machen absolut spaß und war sehr sehr cool das mal wieder zu testen auch interessanter
so eine cpu mit 8 gigahertz von der single-core leistung nicht mal im ansatz an den aktuellen
ryzen 3000 dran kommt da sieht man einfach wie groß dann letztendlich doch klein letzten zehn
jahren wird was getan sind man hätte natürlich im single-core score noch ein bisschen was rausholen
können wenn man den rahmen jetzt weiter getwegen hätte aber der ramm lief relativ entspannt dass
ich einfach so hoch wie möglich takten kann und da jetzt wie das cpu auch in japan hergestellt werden kann.
kein Limit entsteht. Damit hoffe ich,
das Video hat euch gefallen
und wir beenden das Ganze mit noch ein paar
Klopfen in diesem Lüftchen-System.
Das ist so richtig schön abgedrehtes
Zeug.
Ciao.
GG.
Hat wirklich was weihnachtliches, ja.
Cool.
So, was haben wir denn sonst noch zu bieten?
Gamestervideo zu Endzone?
Weiß nicht, was haben wir hier?
Double Nuke. Ich habe schon ewig kein
MW2 mehr geguckt. Der beste Burger?
Äh,
Linus, der sich über das neue MacBook auslässt.
Äh, irgendwelche
Schlösserknack-Sachen.
Den Plank-Mesa-Test, den wollte ich mir schon lange mal
angucken. Äh, wie man
eine Custom-Firmware
für
Smart-Cams
mit Backdoors ausstattet oder so.
Ähm,
was man mit einer
Public-IP-Adresse machen kann. Das ist wahrscheinlich
irgend so ein, ich meine, eine Bewertung ist
schlecht.
Hast du Alex gespielt? Nee, ich habe kein
VR.
Ähm,
Linus, ja, guck mal.
Raspbian XP
WTF?
Ah, warum?
Warum macht man sowas
freiwillig?
Ah, MonkaS.
Muss das sein?
Ah.
Was habe ich denn da auf?
Rain Gutter Power, also sprich
ähm,
wie heißt Regen, Regenrinne.
Energiegewinnung aus Regen.
WTF, was ist mit den Leuten los?
Tour of my Home Network.
Und war Windows ME wirklich
so schlecht? Oh, das können wir nachher auch noch gucken.
Okay, gucken wir uns erstmal den Macbook Hate an.
...
da habe ich bisher alles abgelehnt was ich gekriegt habe zu world of tanks alles komplett
wollte ich nichts mehr zu tun habe ich habe wirklich alles und die sind ja schon seit
jahren immer wieder am start mit irgendwas
lauter
moment
ach nee das ist dell
wollte gerade sagen 3,5 mm klinke was ist denn mit apple auf einmal los
macbook haben noch 3,5 mm klinke ohr
poggers
ohr
die kombination of a shocking amount of bass and dolby atmos
produces a sound that somehow feels twice as big as the machine itself
the only problem is that to produce this much sound out of such little speakers
it's very clear that there's a lot of software trickery at play
which is where the hp spectre x360 comes in for the kill
although the x360 cannot produce the lower notes that the macbook air can
at medium volumes it does produce
a sound that can make speech easier to understand
which can be really important for things like video calls
as for the xps 13 well you're going to have an exceptional listening experience
with a set of dollar store earphones that you dug out from under the couch cushions
from the outside there's another striking difference between these laptops
the macbook air has 6 different speakers
it doesn't matter at all
even if
er's a lot of work
the specificity of the same products is pretty much the same
and this can be quite shocking
we're also only talking about the particular supporting features
on the screen
the x360 x360 x360 x360 x360 x360 x360 x360 x360 x360 x360 x360 x360 x360 x360 x360 x360 x360 x360 x360 x360 x360 x360 x360 x360 x360 x360 x360 x3
both of them have a better sound than the xs
and that makes me wonder
why the xs is better than the xs
the xs is better at communication
Entscheidung, aber die meisten Leute, die ein Apple Gerät kaufen wollen doch gerade
macOS haben. Und das haben sie hier nicht.
Das kann er echt immer gut. Also ich würde mir lieber das 30 Kilo, das 30 Kilo Notebook
kaufen, was der Bauer da letztens vorgestellt hat. Das war gar nicht so schwer, ich weiß
aber es war ein riesen fettes Ding mit irgendwie 40 Minuten Akkulaufzeit.
Wisst ihr, was die beste Notebook-Tastatur ist? Keine Notebook-Tastatur.
Ja ok, das leuchtet mir ein.
Ok, ja das ist das...
Das ist auch eine Sache, die mir immer auf den Keks geht bei Notebook-Tastaturen.
Ah, exzellent.
Starks.
Ich fühle mich diskriminiert. Warum dürfen auf dem MacBook Air 92% der Frauen ordentlich
schreiben und nur 77% der Männer? Was ist da los?
Abmahnung ist raus.
Also das ist einfach exzeptionell.
Auf diesem Thema haben alle unserer Test-Systeme exzeptionelle Displays, die reiche Farben
für den Aussichtspersonen ja auch bieten. Aber da ist eine Sache wo Apple es wirklich
geschafft hat, nämlich die Resolution. 2560x1600 ist eine 16x10-Version von QHD.
Die Resolution, die wir gesagt haben, sollte bis von However-Auf hen alt-Laptopern
jahreslang Standard sein. Ja, ja Dell und HP haben beide 4K Display-Optionen, die dir mehr
Pixels geben als Apple.
Hello!
Das stimmt. Ja, da hat er recht.
Da hat er recht. 13 Zoll Display ist jetzt auch nicht groß.
Ja, da hat er recht.
Das ist ein Thema, was komplett an mir vorbeigeht, weil das Notebook, was ich verwende auf der Arbeit, verwende ich eigentlich 99% stationär.
Daheim habe ich kein Notebook, was ich regelmäßig verwende, da verwende ich nur mein Desktop.
Ähm, ja.
Na gut, da brauchst du aber eine...
Da brauchst du aber eine MacBook Watch.
Ich, ich bin, ich mag, also Smartwatches ist eine Sache, so ein Trend, der ist wirklich auch an mir vorbeigegangen.
Ich bin froh, seit, dass ich keine Uhr mehr anziehen muss, seitdem ich ein Smartphone habe.
Ich würde, ich würde mir freiwillig, es sei denn die einzige Sache, wo ich verstehe ist, also als Fitness-Tracker, das ist okay, das leuchtet mir noch irgendwo ein.
Ähm, aber mich würde es eher nerven, wenn ich wieder eine Uhr anziehen müsste.
Bringen wir uns zu macOS.
Ich bin, ich bin jetzt an dem Punkt, wo ich nicht wirklich verstehe, dass das Hate, entweder Art und Weise geht.
Ja, es wird ein paar Tage dauern, bis eine technische, wissenschaftliche Person sich an die verschiedenen Shortcuts und den generellen Workflow befindet.
Aber mit so web-zentriert, fast alles, was wir jetzt tun, ist, dass ich für viele Leute, außer App-Kompatibilität, was auch immer du professionell machst,
außer das, der Fakt, dass du auf einem komplett anderen Operationssystem bist,
ist wahrscheinlich, dass es nicht funktioniert.
Da hat er, da hat er nicht unrecht.
The only thing that, it's a little thing, but that continually annoyed me, was that, to get a window, to take up half of the display,
I have to like long press full screen and then use this stupid little menu.
Why the heck do I have to install a paid app to get proper window snapping functionality?
Oh, Microsoft.
Er könnte, er könnte ja auch, er könnte ja auch, äh, i3-WM unter Linux verwenden, dann hat er gar keine Probleme mehr.
Aber dafür hat er viele andere Sachen, die nicht mal funktionieren.
...attentive window snapping, that's a dick move, dick move, anyway, everything's been pretty positive so far and I promised a problem here, didn't I?
I could point at its webcam, especially right now, with work from home...
Ja, aber Umut, meine Frage, wenn du, wenn du einen Alert auf die Apple Watch bekommst, wenn dein Server nicht mehr läuft,
wo ist der Vorteil davon, den Alert auf die Apple Watch zu kommen, bekommen, anstatt sie einfach aufs Smartphone zu bekommen?
...aufs Smartphone?
Aufs Smartphone hast du ja sogar mehr Display-Platz, ähm, dass du was sehen kannst.
Quite frankly, all of them are bad, so I guess we're gonna have to wait for Sway.
Sway hab ich nur mal kurz ausprobiert und Wayland hat mich abgefuckt.
...to make the first move and this isn't gonna be it.
But there's a bigger one, it's performance.
For some reason, Apple has decided to include only a Wi-Fi 5 network card,
which probably isn't a huge deal right now, but as Wi-Fi 6 becomes more commonplace...
Also bei so einem teuren Notebook...
...becomes more commonplace, that's, yes.
Würde ich das auch erwarten.
...X-13 und X360-Owners are going to enjoy significantly faster Wi-Fi.
And, as for the Processor, well, the base model still has a dual-core i3,
which we find truly unacceptable in 2020.
Ja, das ist wirklich nicht wahr.
...which we find truly unacceptable in 2020.
Ja, das stimmt.
Even something like a background app install or an update
can make a dual-core machine feel sluggish.
But the good news is, even if it costs extra,
at least you can get...
Echt, um und gibt's das noch, wo man kein Handy mitnehmen muss?
darf okay das hat das hatte ich in letzter lage nicht mehr a quad core in
the macbook air now so far too late for its decent balance between price da kommt
der ram da kriegst du ja schon da kriegst du ja schon fast 32 g oder was
dafür ist a lot better than last gen unfortunately it's not actively cool or
at least not directly there is a fan in the chassis but there's no heat pipe on
the small wimpy heatsink assembly for the cpu connecting it to some kind of
radiator and the exhaust of that fan what that means is that the macbook air
2020 only has about 10 watts of cpu power to play with before it would
overheat so needless to say it gets absolutely flogged by the xps 13 and
spectre x3
60 with their 25 watts of apple cpu consuming last power means more battery
life though right brentz verbrennst du dir dann auch die hose wenn es auf dem
schoß liegen hast
im hand display keyboard and speakers bei all the parts that you would interact
beitrag mit der gyali er excellent by last part this is a 1950 dollar machine
that will fall behind very fast
er denn writing derその die wirkliche mann hat seit hievs of people don't need
to do much more than that and with the improved keyboard it really is a lot
better and the additional power with brilliant lot better for you that said heaps of people dont need to do much more than that and with the improved keyboard it really is a lot better and the additional power which really is a lot better than the xfile 6's nice I have noticed that that works really well.
This is a much more compelling machine than last gen.
Furthermore, no matter what the price or performance, the XPS and the X360 are also really expensive
and they will never come with macOS.
Ja, das ist das, was ich am Anfang gesagt habe.
Die meisten Leute, die sich einen Mac kaufen, die wollen ja gerade macOS haben.
Es gibt ein paar, die installieren sich Windows Dual Boot drauf.
Die meisten wollen macOS haben.
Ja, den letzten Zählerhaut guckt man sich.
Okay, bleibt doch jetzt als Fazit, das MacBook ist, wenn man halt Apple macOS haben will,
dann ist das ganz okay, kann man kaufen.
Na gut, ich kaufe es mir trotzdem nicht, weil wozu?
So, was haben wir sonst noch zu bieten?
Windows ME, war es wirklich so schlecht?
Ach, das muss ich mir jetzt sagen, guck mal.
Also, meine, bevor er anfängt zu erzählen, meine Erinnerung an Windows ME,
ich meine, das dürfte dieses Jahr 20 Jahre alt werden.
Meine Erinnerung, oh, Alter, bin ich alt, ey.
Das ist 20 Jahre her.
Ich kann mich immer noch daran erinnern, wo ich den Scheiß installiert habe.
WTF.
So lange ist das her, das ist doch nicht normal.
F, RIP.
Ähm, ja, also meine Erfahrung zu Windows ME, ich habe den Hate damals nicht so ganz verstanden,
muss ich ehrlich sagen.
Es war genauso scheiße wie Windows 98, also wenn man, wenn man die Windows 98, ähm, Windows 95 Linie scheiße findet,
dann findet man auch Windows ME scheiße.
Aber für die damalige Windows 98 Linie war das scheiße.
Die ganze Zeit im Heimbereich zum Spielen war das halt das einzige, was vorhanden war.
Und, ähm, da war Windows ME genauso kacke wie Windows 98 oder genauso gut wie Windows 98.
Da gab es eigentlich kaum Unterschiede.
Nur, dass Windows ME ein bisschen hübscher ausgesehen hat.
Windows 98 war dann irgendwann schon irgendwie ziemlich angestaubt.
Ähm, aber glücklicherweise gab es ja dann Windows 2000, mehr oder weniger parallel,
auf dem man auch schon sehr viele Sachen machen konnte und spätestens mit Windows XP,
ähm,
mit Windows XP war die Sache eh gegessen.
Nur, kann ich verstehen, ja,
so ein, so ein abschließendes Fazit wäre bei vielen Review-Videos wirklich gut.
Greetings and welcome to an LGR thing about, äh, Windows...
Ist das, ist das original verpackt?
Yes, it is, it is time to die...
Ist das ein original verpacktes Windows ME?
Hier unten, guck mal, hier unten sieht man den Plastik.
Ein original verpacktes Windows ME, das muss der erstmal finden noch.
Und, äh,
Let's see if it really was better living in the digital world.
You know, this is a fascinating product, really.
Despite my own mixed personal experiences with it,
just looking back at this thing's release, its reception and...
Nicht öffnen, ja, da ist wahrscheinlich von, ähm,
man kriegt ein bisschen Geld zu, geöffnet ist man bei...
Null.
...twenty years of people deriding it.
I mean, it's just become one of the most...
Warte mal, wann, wann kam das denn raus?
Ich glaube 2000.
Oder 99.
Ja, September 2000.
September 2000.
Ja.
Guck mal, Windows XP war auch nicht mal lange hin.
So, und Windows 2000 gab's auch schon.
Ja.
Deswegen, ich hab's auch nicht lange verwendet.
...after my wine and...
Ich kann mich noch dran erinnern, oh Scheiße, das muss ich jetzt echt mal sagen.
Wo mir grad wieder auffällt, wie alt ich bin.
Ich kann mich noch dran erinnern, wo wir die Beta-Version von Windows XP installiert haben.
Ich glaub Whistler hieß der Kram.
Windows Whistler oder so, war das nicht?
Windows XP?
Ja.
Haben wir die Beta-Version von Windows XP installiert.
Und fanden den Wiesenhintergrund, damals haben wir uns voll gehypt auf die Wiese.
Weiß nicht, was man an so einer Wiese toll finden kann.
...weiß nicht, was man an so einer Wiese toll finden kann.
Gibt's einen Grund, warum du immer eine 1 hinschreibst, ja?
Mach mal Ausrufezeichen, 1 ausgeschrieben im Chat.
...Ach sooo scheiße, war das nicht.
...das war genauso gut und schlecht, wie Windows 98.
Es wird oft so genannt wie Mistake Edition oder Major Embarrassment oder Multiple Enemas oder was auch immer man sagen möchte, was E.M.M.E. eigentlich bedeutet.
Die ständige Narrative ist, dass es so schlecht war, dass es die Leute führte, Windows 2000 zu bewegen oder einfach Windows 98 SE zu downgradieren.
Und Spiele auch, aber das wurde dann immer zunehmend besser, sodass man spätestens mit Windows XP konnte man umsteigen.
Windows XP habe ich ziemlich zur Release gleich geholt. Beste.
Was ist das für eine komische Wurst?
Du gehst jetzt pennen, Michael. Ja, dann schlaf gut.
Das ist eine komische Wurst, ja.
Aber das war mal eine Zeit lang tatsächlich ein Trend, dass man versucht hat, alles möglichst rund und weich zu bauen.
Ihr kennt ja bestimmt auch diese ergonomischen Keyboards von damals.
Ich bin eher auch der Windows-ME-Sager.
Es gibt viele Meet-Me-Ads und Me ist das Operationssystem für mich und so weiter.
Es ist immer noch so, dass es sich um die Wurst handelt.
Es gibt auch noch Initialism, die auf Millennium Edition steht, natürlich.
Aber die PR wollte wirklich versuchen, es von den 2000ern zu differenzieren.
Microsoft-Benahmung war damals schon genauso schlecht wie heute.
Es wurde am gleichen Zeitpunkt umsonst verkauft.
Und es war wirklich für die Geschäfts- und Enterprise-Helfer,
ein richtiger Nachfolger von Windows NT 4.0,
wobei Millennium Edition der nächste große,
mainstreamen Konsum-Operationssystem gewesen war.
Und ursprünglich war es eigentlich aufgrund des NT-Kernels und des Filesystems,
Mir fällt da immer zu ein, wenn ich Windows 2000 sehe, wo man wieder sieht, dass Noobs eine ganz andere Verbindung zu Technik haben als Leute, die sich damit auskennen.
Und zwar, mein Vater, der hatte damals einen AMD Duron 800. Das ist ein uraltes Ding. Das ist so alt, das war 2000 rum.
Da hatten wir dann auch Windows 2000 drauf. Und der sagt bis heute, aber wahrscheinlich, weil es einfach so angepasst ist.
Weil es so angenehm war, von Windows 98 auf 2000 umzusteigen. Der sagt heute noch, mein AMD Duron, das war der beste Rechner, den ich je hatte.
Als hat die Low-Budget-CPU damit irgendwas zu tun. Das war der Umstieg von Windows 98 auf Windows 2000, der ihm so gut gefallen hat und nicht die CPU.
Die Dinger konnte man aber, glaube ich, sogar ganz gut übertanken damals.
Guck mal, CPUs, wo man noch was mitpackt.
Bloß im Auge erkannt hat.
Ich bin interessiert, ob es wirklich der beste Internet-Experiment war.
Tja, damals hatte ich auch noch Internet Explorer. Was war das? Internet Explorer 5 oder so, oder 4.
Und ich bilde mir ein, es gab damals schon die erste Firefox-Version.
Noch Firebird hieß der. Firefox hieß ja mal Firebird, bevor es Firefox hieß.
Gibt es da eine ordentliche Version? Das war 0.2 oder sowas.
Das kommt doch ungefähr hin von der Zeit her.
Initial Release? Ja, genau, das sah noch so komisch aus, das Firebird-Logo.
Wann war der Release? Die Seiten sind übelst unübersichtlich.
Wow! Hier, hier sieht man es schon, Firefox Timeline.
Okay, nee, das muss dann doch ein Ticken später gewesen sein mit Firefox.
2002 ist ein bisschen spät für Windows ME.
Okay.
Äh, ja genau, Thunderbird ist das Mail, beziehungsweise PIM-Programm.
Nee, Netscape hab ich nicht mal verwendet.
Netscape hat mir damals auch nicht gefallen.
Ähm, ich hab meine erste, meine erste Website hab ich mal, hab ich mit dem Netscape Composer
gemacht.
Kennt ihr noch jemand?
Netscape.
NetScape Composer, kennt noch jemand NetScape Composer, huge, huge Software hier, PC-Welt-Test-Pager, ja, so sah der Kram aus, ja, NetScape Composer, das war so ein WYSIWYG-Editor für HTML und danach habe ich abgegradet, da habe ich mir gedacht, okay, damit kann man keine ordentlichen Websites machen, Frontpage habe ich nie richtig verwendet, damit habe ich festgestellt, damit kann man keine ordentlichen Websites machen und dann habe ich das verwendet,
was alle coolen Leute so 2000 rumverwendet haben, Dreamweaver, so irgendwie 2000 rum oder so, Macromedia Dreamweaver, ja, excellent, genau, der Kram hier und damit konnte man tatsächlich ganz gute Webseiten machen für die damalige Zeit, die hatten auch eine ziemlich gute Autovervollständigung, Moment, was, es gibt ein Tutorial für Dreamweaver 8, im Hintergrund hörst du,
warum ist das ein Video von 2014, für Dreamweaver, what the fuck, huge Tutorial, Wahnsinn, gut, aber jetzt kommen wir zum eigentlichen Video mal zurück, hättest du mal, wie es, wer von euch hat auch Dreamweaver verwendet damals, falls es euch überhaupt schon gegeben hat,
ah, okay, hatten wir ein paar,
hättest du mal,
ach, 210, boah, war das teuer, 210 Dollar für Windows ME, fuck, war das teuer, ich muss, ich, jetzt kann ich das ja machen, das ist ja schon verjährt, ähm, ich bin mir eigentlich ziemlich sicher, dass ich für Windows ME damals nicht verwendet habe,
as we have right here, and this is also one that if you bought it from CompUSA, then you'd get a limited edition Windows ME watch, with the purchase of one of the first 25,000 units sold at those stores, hmm, well, I don't have one of those watches here, but I do have the original packaging, so, yeah, let's just open it up and see what is packed inside, I mean, I'm pretty sure,
das ist aber auch ein High-Skill-Messer, was er da hat,
microsoft
Didn't exactly go crazy with their
Box ist es ein klapp ist es ein klapp teppichmesser sehe ich das richtig
also klappt klappbares teppichmesser
Exzellent
Einschülerin OS content still though. I'm curious. What is contained?
Minus 200 euro leute
The seal all right
Einfach wieder einschweißen danach
In this is what you get man. Look at that. You get that holo holo cd
The way this is worded amuses me the product ships with an advanced hologram technology. I just imagine like tupac popping out of the box
Die booteskette ist auch dabei
Windows millennium edition disk in person and honestly that looks
cool
I'm legitimately impressed that looks so much cooler than any other version of windows. I have honestly that's a
fast wie geldschein
products key on the back you are important to us steht auf der diskette
Ich habe noch nicht aus 98 cd irgendwo
edition boot disk
Always cool the include this for a couple of reasons actually for this version of windows
Ich habe irgendwo eine windows auf 9 cd
for
amerika online gold
version 5.0
try it for
500 hours free
indeed
Yeah, die waren überall drinne damals
Die war damals überall drinne aol cds überall überall du wurdest voll geschissen mit aol cds
aol
anyway microsoft
aol hat meine aol hat auch ziemlich verschissen
das war so eines der größten provider und sachen die es überhaupt gab
aber jetzt ist nix davon übrig
die postgres datenbank hat kekse verschwendet
f
quick start guide
The bummer that it doesn't come with any kind of actual manual or full documentation or anything
But hey, you know, that's just what they were doing at this point. One of the things they were pushing. There was the
interactive help system was
Supposedly much more improved. I mean it was improved over
What came with like windows 95 and 98, but yeah, this really is
Stimmt das war das erste windows mit internet connection sharing
Kann also jemand ics
internet connection sharing
Das haben wir damals auch verwendet
Weiß ich noch da habe ich im kumpel aus der schule zusammen bei mir daheim gesessen ich habe internet connection sharing angemacht
Oh nee
gab es das auch bei 98 schon echt
Ich kann sie wieder dran erinnern internet connection sharing ist hat sogar ganz gut funktioniert das hat nass gemacht
Da konnte es einfach eine internetverbindung das modem hat es ja damals direkt am rechner dran
Deswegen wurden ja auch so viele windows windows rechner mit billigster software gehackt
das modem war direkt am
Browser am rechner dran und dann hast du die internetverbindung geschert internet korrekt das hat einfach nach
geroutet hat router gemacht
Nichts großartig besonderes
dem die erste
die
aber dann haben wir relativ schnell festgestellt dass
internet connection sharing sagt
Und dann haben wir was dann haben wir das hier verwende ich weiß nicht ob es das jetzt noch gibt
Von lelux und sachen haben wir damals keinen plan ja und von richtiger netzwerk hat werden wir auch keinen plan wir haben das hier verwendet damals
win root light
Ja 4.0 4.0
4.2
ja
dass da haben wir damals verwendet für
netzwerk freigabe das andere rechner im netzwerk auch das internet verwenden konnten
wenn gut leicht
genau das ding
windraut genau windraut
Ja
Und dieses alle zeug start enden stoppen warum was immer dafür klopft gibt ja und danach gab es so eine komische fake firewall
naja ja nein
Also dass da hat sich auch mal jemand
bezahlt
Und hier auch noch eine
Sache
Naja also
ist ja
Es gibt zwar
so
die
Karte
wo sie
Hier
Zeit
gekommen
dass
die
ganze
Da ist
die ganze
haben diese sachen mit dem man anfängt merkt man sich eh ich weiß nicht das das brennt sich irgendwie ein und wir großen an ich weiß nicht was ich vor 5 Minuten im Chat gesagt habe aber das weiß ich noch ein quick startup guide so
Anyway, this is all you get inside here.
Let's get this delightful-looking CD installed on the LGR Megaluminum Monster.
Äh, er hat ja, BNC mit Terminator hatte ich auch noch.
Guess now it's gonna have Millennium Edition on it.
At least for today.
Das kennt heute, glaubt keiner mehr.
BNC-Kabel mit Terminator, ey.
Alright, got the LGR Megaluminum Monster here.
Keine Uhr.
Nee, er hat keine Uhr dabei gehabt, weil die Uhr war nur bei den ersten 25.000 Exemplaren dabei.
...see it. It will be booted into Windows me.
Let's get this CD in here.
Blub, blub.
Ah, der Sound, hä?
Excellent.
This CD-ROM contains the newer version of Windows and the one you're presently using.
Would you like to upgrade it?
Yes!
I mean, we don't have to do it from here.
We could just reboot and do things like that.
But, yeah, why not?
I'm gonna try the...
On the fly.
...on the fly.
...sort of.
Yeah, I'm just gonna try the upgrade version of this first.
Just taking 98SE and upgrading it to Millennium Edition.
See how that goes, I've read mixed results may occur, so that could be fun.
And if it's a complete disaster, we will try a clean install, but upgrade is first.
Welcome to Windows me Setup.
Congratulations on choosing Windows Millennium Edition.
I'm not sure if I chose it or if you guys chose it by requesting it for years,
but anyway, there we go.
Now checking my hard disk for problems.
There is no hard disk, this is running off of SD cards.
There's a SCSI 2 SD installed in here, which is nice because I don't plan on keeping this
running Millennium Edition after this, so I can just swap back to a Windows 98 SD card.
I've got them cloned and everything, so I actually just swap them out all the time,
but anyway, behind-the-scenes stuff.
Windows just got better.
Helps you get the most out of your computer, by the way.
Diese Fotos hatten sie in den 90ern übelst gerne, solche, solche, das haben sie ja heute
noch, ganze Familie von Notebook und freut sich, aber so Fotos hatten sie damals besonders
gerne.
Und diese Sache, dass Windows wurde besser und Windows ist das beste Windows, das es
je gab, das kam ja in jedem Installer.
By providing the best in digital media, improved user experience, enhanced home networking,
rich internet.
Yes, they were hyping.
Those four.
Aspects in particular, constantly in all the marketing that I've been looking up here
recently.
It's fascinating though, because a lot of those enhancements were actually available
on Windows 98 SE without the need for Millennium Edition, even though, I mean, they're advertised
right here in the back, showing like Windows Media Player 7, for instance, and talking
about Internet Explorer 5.5.
Windows Media Player 7, ja, da wo es noch einen ordentlichen Media Player gab, den man sogar
skinnen konnte und alles.
Es ist teilweise erstaunlich zu sehen, wie, wie der, was ist, was wir da so machen können,
was wir da so machen können.
Also, ich glaube, das ist, was wir da so machen können.
Also, ich glaube, das ist, was wir da so machen können, was wir da so machen können.
Und was wir in manchen Bereichen für Rückschritte gemacht haben.
Man konnte Windows XP und die ganzen ollen Windows XP Programme, die konnten wir alle
stylen, stylen, customizen bis zum geht nicht mehr.
Und heute hast du ein Windows Mail Programm, was noch nicht mal richtig Bilder runterladen
kann.
Those were available as free updates, free downloads from Microsoft online for 98 SE.
You didn't need me for that.
Winamp.
And it led a lot of people.
Winamp?
Moment, Winamp Lama?
Winamp? Wer kennt das noch?
Lama.
Winamp.
Das hat sich auch
eingebrannt, ja.
Stimmt, MSN Messenger.
Stimmt!
Windows Movie Maker.
Der war gar nicht so schlecht.
Familiar looking Windows
setup. Setup?
At least visually. Alrighty, I believe that was it.
So, let's see if it works.
First boot here about half an hour later.
Oh, that splash screen.
I feel like I need a crucifix.
Ah, yes.
Now there's
a startup I haven't heard in a very
long time.
Wow, seems like everything is working.
I was expecting at least one
thing to maybe need to be installed or whatever,
but, ah man,
it's just straight up working.
3DFX-Tools.
I didn't have, like, the latest drivers
for my Aureal Vortex sound card
and the Voodoo 3 graphics card.
I was wondering, because I have two sound cards
in there, an A64 Gold
and the Vortex 2.
I have the game port disabled on that one
and it's enabled on the A64 and it kept that too.
Like, everything is in here.
Working perfectly, it looks like,
so far.
I'll be honest, that is a bit of a surprise.
I was expecting at least one or two drivers
not to be okay.
But, hmm, we've got some
extra things. So, we've got the new
Media Player 7 here.
Ooh, how exciting.
Oh, man, I haven't seen that in forever.
Oh,
gotta stop that, because copyright,
I forgot that it played back.
Look at all this.
Like, the skins and crazy stuff.
Yeah, das war doch cool.
Das war doch cool.
Das war doch cool. Und heute hast du einen Media Player
dabei, wo du nicht mal Dateien öffnen kannst.
Ja, guck mal.
Groove Music.
Wenn ich da Dateien öffnen will,
das hat kein Datei öffnen...
Ich weiß, ich hab bis heute nicht verstanden,
wie ich hier Dateien öffne drin.
Ich bin da einfach zu dumm für.
Ich weiß nicht, wie man Dateien öffnet.
Ich bin nicht in der Lage, in diesem
neuen Media Player Dateien zu öffnen.
Es gibt keinen Knopf für, es gibt nix.
Ich weiß nicht, wie man Dateien öffnet.
Track'n'trop geht übrigens nicht.
... not everywhere.
I need higher...
... resolution.
Huh, I can't.
Ach, RIP.
Well, why not?
Okay, so there we go.
I made the monitor the DX700
by Game Maker.
Flimmer, flimmer, flimmer, flimmer.
Sechster Scherz.
You can actually change that.
Ah, yes.
Good stuff.
So, now we can get all the
the full nonsense of Media Player 7 here.
This brings back so many weird memories
immediately.
All these terrible skins and such.
Die waren richtig mies.
Die waren richtig...
Ich fand's aber cool, dass man den Kram
skinnen kann irgendwo.
Man konnte das komplette Windows skinnen.
Kind of aesthetic, what in the world.
All these terrible designs.
The eyeballs.
Oh man, look at this.
Just, what in the world.
The whole design language of the time period.
UI, UX, it was just a nightmare.
It's kind of oddly appealing in a retro...
Find ich auch.
Es ist merkwürdig.
... Windows Update, ah yes.
This was a new thing.
Just have it connect straight here, you know, and it would download...
... Windows Update, ah yes.
This was a new thing.
Just have it connect straight here, you know, and it would download...
Big brain skin.
... things every day if you wanted it to and keep your Windows updated.
Geht das heute noch?
Kann man heute noch Windows M-E updaten?
Übers Internet?
Funktioniert der Updater noch?
... instead of having to go to a website and download individual files or whatever.
Which is probably what I will do if I end up updating this,
because I am not gonna connect to the Internet.
Just copy files over.
Let's see, desktop themes.
This is also something that came with a lot of them from like Plus.
Let's see, desktop themes. This is also something that came with a lot of them from like Plus.
I think I installed on here already.
Which I don't even know which ones were new, but yeah.
All these classic themes, man.
I loved Inside the Computer...
I mean who didn't?
Ja das hatte ich auch.
All those sounds.
Yeah like I said, these were on 98 as well, so.
Ja genau.
The crap hatte ich auch damals.
It came with a bunch of them.
And this one is...
I guess...
Woof.
What in a world.
Stimmt, die Sounds, wenn du Fenster minimiert hast.
Ich habe das noch nie genutzt, du kannst es nur, äh, das wird es nicht machen, weil es ein frischer Install ist, aber nur individuelle Dinge, die du am meisten in dem Startmenü benutzt hast, ich mag das nicht, ich habe das nie. Es gab auch Auto-Komplett, ja, also das war eine Sache, ich war so, oh Mann, du musst es nicht unbedingt erinnern, genau, was auf deinem Herzen ist, das Auto-Komplett-Tool, wow, du hast es, 3D in hier irgendwo, da ist es, das war auf der Zeit spannend,
es kam auch mit ein paar neuen Spiele, die ich immer genutzt habe, also du hast die Internet-Spiele, also Internet-Backend und Checker, die gehen nicht mehr, die sind abgeschaltet, die gehen bestimmt nicht mehr.
Das war alles neu in Millennium Edition, natürlich musst du online sein und durch die MSN-Spielzone spielen, Spider Solitaire war auch neu, das gibt es nicht mehr,
Timeless Classic, genau da, oder so wurde es, richtig, ich erinnere mich nicht mehr, wie ich das spielen kann,
und du hast Classic Solitaire,
wie es jetzt genannt wird, nur Classic Solitaire, um es zu differenzieren, und dann, natürlich,
Pinball, ja, die hatten auch einen, es gab da auch einen Level-Editor für, da habe ich relativ viel rumgespielt früher,
für den 3D-Pinball-Space-Kadett, wiederum, das wurde in ein paar der Versionen von Plus vorgeschlagen, und natürlich wurde es später in XP eingeführt,
aber du musst Imi Präsenz geben, um einen Klassik für das erste Mal in Windows zu inkludieren,
und diese finden wir auch noch, ich persönlich habe sie noch nicht in der Version, die hat ich noch nicht veröffentlicht,
aber sie können in super besten Gründen, wie die ersten Web-Papier-Szenen, die wir hatten, es whopping 27,000,
und die werden jetzt voices versioniert, so wie die ersten Videos von Wolfgang 두 Kroben,
weil die haben wir schon mal im Anfang gesehen, und, und, und, und, und, und, und, und, und, und, und, und, und, und, und, und, und, und, und, und, und, und, und, und, und, und.
Und dann, das drin.
Aahh, Windows Millennium Edition Preview.
Ich habe sie noch mal gesehen.
Ist das Flash?
Ich auch nicht. Ich wusste gar nicht, dass es Restore-Pulse gab.
Also, lasst uns nur einen Punkt erzeugen.
Als ich das gelesen habe, waren einige Leute damals nicht wirklich Fan davon,
weil es nicht nur ausgesucht hat,
sondern es hat auch eine gute Menge Harddisk-Einheit genommen,
etwa 150-200 MB oder so, pro Restore-Pulse.
Und es hat auch Sachen im Hintergrund gedreht
und den Computer gedreht,
sodass du also eine niedrigere Leistung als Windows 98 bekommst.
Aber da sind wir. Es hat einen Restore-Pulse erzeugt.
Schaut euch das an.
Großartiges Hilfe- und Unterstützungssystem.
Ja, das war ziemlich vorrangig, Mann.
Erst mal eine halbe Stunde laden.
Das war noch pre-Internet-Wikipedia und alles.
Der Movie-Maker. Jawoll.
Jawoll.
Wow.
Okay.
Musik für jedes...
Ja.
Hier!
ações,
das heißt diesem Camerasicht,
ammentically made those clips.
Huge quality!
Großartiges Qualität...
TIME TO PROGRESS 1
Huge quality!
Back-Bitmap.
Put that right here.
Import.
I guess we can just do WAV-Files.
Yeah, we'll add some sound effects.
This is gonna be the best video.
I don't believe this one actually lets you put
like static text boxes or anything like that in this one.
I may be wrong, I don't know,
but I'm not seeing that anyway.
Huge video.
Pfff.
I'm gonna save that movie.
Highest quality.
Which is what?
256k BPS.
396k BPS.
Das ist geil.
So viel habe ich als Sound-Bitrate eingestellt.
Das ist meine Sound-Bitrate gerade,
was High-Quality-Video bei denen ist.
File Size.
Saving it as a Windows Media Player.
Video File.
Look at that, Encoder Go.
Ah, magnificent.
Yes, watch it now.
Hahaha, huge quality.
Hahaha.
Aber das Geile ist,
damals hat man sich darüber gefreut,
über den Scheiß.
Hahaha.
Genial.
Das Baby müsste man heute interviewen,
ja, das stimmt.
Ja.
Genau.
Only one of the biggest changes is the fact that there is no longer an MS-DOS mode.
I mean, it's here.
This is still built on top of DOS, but they straight up hid it.
And you'd have to re-enable it through ways.
It wasn't actually long at all before some folks online and journalists and whatnot
were sharing methods of,
Restoring the MS-DOS
Functionality, or you know, making it
easier to access, because it's still here.
Wisst ihr, was ich nie verstanden habe damals, wofür
das gewesen ist?
My Briefcase.
Weiß gar nicht mehr, wie der Kram auf
deutschen Windows hieß. Arbeits...
Akter...
Aktenordner?
Aktenordner, kann das sein?
Aktenkoffer!
Aktenkoffer hieß es auf Deutsch, genau.
Ähm, Arbeitsmappe?
Arbeits, nee, Arbeitsmappe
war, glaube ich, in Visual Studio was anderes.
Ähm, zumindest
ich habe den Sinn davon nie
verstanden.
Games...
But others worked perfectly fine.
So yeah, Jazz Jackrabbit, it works.
Then you have games like Epic Pinball
that aren't ideal
running under Windows. You get some weird
choppiness with the scrolling.
Skipped, uh...
I never liked that.
Tearing.
So yeah, if you could run that under
actual DOS mode, then that'd be great.
Normally you'd...
just be able to, you know, go in here
and create, like, a piff or whatever,
and you'd just tell it to go into DOS
mode, but it's straight up not even an
option anymore.
Do 3D though, I mean, you know.
Geht das eigentlich immer noch?
Zum Blutfall, kann ich immer noch
Shortcuts erstellen unter Windows?
Also, und die Vorschau-Icons ändern?
Also, nehmen wir jetzt mal das hier,
sagen Create Shortcut.
Kann ich immer noch die Icons ändern?
Geht das? Change Icon.
Oh, guck mal!
Das ist...
Das ist das Windows-95-Icon-Feld.
Da hat sich nix getan seit 20 Jahren.
Guck mal, kein Unterschied.
Also, der Zeichenträger,
das ist ja wirklich kein Unterschied mehr.
Die Bilder sehen auch noch genauso hässlich aus
wie in Windows-95.
Da hat sich ja gar nichts getan bei Microsoft, ey.
Was ist das?
MSN, ja, das MSN-Icon
brauche ich unbedingt dafür.
Da sieht man mal, was Windows 10
mittlerweile für eine Ansammlung
aus unterschiedlichsten Zeiträumen ist.
Ja, das wollte ich schon immer mal
für die Datei haben hier.
Ja, exzellent.
Wurscht.
Windows Millennium Edition.
It's pretty deadly.
Hast du Windows von euch selber benutzt?
Ja, klar.
Despite a lot of my favorites working fine,
there's a number of games and programs
that just won't work properly
or at all without DOS running in real mode.
Not a problem.
In older versions of Windows
where you can just restart and...
Das war die Zeit, wo die Eltern gedacht haben,
Mortal Kombat ist das schlimmste Spiel aller Zeiten.
...MS-DOS-Mode at any time.
Weil er so gewaltverherrlichend und verrohend und so, oder?
There are a few well-known methods I tried out.
First is writing a boot disk
or just using the one Millennium Edition came with,
which will boot into a menu,
letting you select Windows or DOS-Mode
either with or without CD-ROM-Support.
Same as you could on Windows 95 and 98 and such.
This is definitely...
Heute denken die Eltern,
während Fortnite wäre das schlimmste Spiel.
Ja, da haben sie es ja auch recht.
...MS-DOS-Mode in me, MS-DOS 8.0 in this case.
You won't have Sound Blaster or Mouse Support yet,
but I imagine amending the disks,
auto-exec and running the needed TSRs is an option.
Next up I tried Manifest Destiny's
real-mode DOS-Patch version 1.3,
something hosted all over the web back in the day
and even got a write-up in InfoWorld Magazine
in October of 2000.
It's a simple patcher program
where you copy three different Windows
system files into a new folder,
run the program...
Damals hast du so viel sinnvolle, sinnlose Sachen
in Windows rum, track and drop in Systemordner
und alles in der Hoffnung, danach hat's funktioniert.
Irgendwelche Hacks, irgendwelche komischen DLLs
aus dem Internet geladen, registriert und geguckt,
ah, jetzt funktioniert's.
Ich hab sogar einmal die Explorer-Axe von Windows 98
rübergeschoben zu Windows ME
und das hat, glaube ich, auch funktioniert,
nur dass irgendwelche Menüs nicht funktionierten
und so, ganz merkwürdig.
...and it'll modify things so you're ready
to overwrite the original.
Add a couple lines to config.sys
and autoexec.bat and that's that.
Basically, this tricks Windows ME
into thinking it's always running a boot disk
no matter what, which is
somewhat annoying personally, but it does work.
The last one I tried is
DOS FixMe version 3.0
from Overclockers Australia,
supposedly the last and best version
from them. In contrast
to the manual nature of the other methods,
this one presents you with a comparatively
nice menu system, letting you
apply and undo the menu.
Huge DOS-Menü.
...as well as disable potentially unwanted features
like PC health and system restore.
Unfortunately, it didn't seem to work
for me at all, completely messing up
a whole load of system files
to the point where the undo didn't work
and the system became unbootable.
Whatever, man, even if it did work,
it still wouldn't restore features.
Man kann heute übrigens noch ein Explorer-Fenster
von Windows 3.11 finden in Windows 10.
Echt? Welches denn?
...to tell DOS-Program information files
to boot a program in real DOS-Mode
or enable
restarting in MS-DOS-Mode
from the Start-Menü,
each of which I use all the dang time
on Windows 98 SE. So, yeah,
even with the patches and workarounds,
Windows Me simply isn't the operating
system of choice if you need a proper
DOS. Again, the majority of games
I've tried work just fine under a Windows
DOS prompt, at least as well as they do
under Windows 98. Better than
I remember, honestly. But
it's just not ideal, if you have the
choice. But what about the Windows
side of gaming? After all, Windows
Me is a flavor of 98.
So, anything designed for 95 and 98
should work just as well, right?
Well, maybe. Something I ran
across in my research is that the
edition is consistently slower than
98 SE, even using the exact
same hardware and drivers when
running certain games and benchmarks.
So I figured I'd run it for you myself.
Yeah, and the tournament hatten wir am Start,
Half-Life 1 hatten wir am Start.
I've just got this running a time
demo on the intro sequence at
800x600 resolution, V-Sync
disabled and 16-bit
cut.
Since this is running a 16-megabyte
Voodoo 3 graphics card.
Damals dachte man sich so geil bei der Grafik,
aber ich hab gesagt, boah, ist das krass.
Same drivers, same DirectX 7, same
everything between Me and 98.
And at first glance, they look pretty
darn similar. But the final numbers
reveal that 98 SE ran
the game slightly faster
at 69.49
frames per second average, whereas
Me pulled off 68.75.
Not enough to make a visual
difference, but there it is.
Heldchen Grenzen.
Provided similar testing with the
time demo playing a match I recorded
to provide some hard numbers for
us to peruse.
Still running at 16-bit 800x600
resolution, by the way.
And yeah, once again 98 SE
came out on top by a narrow margin.
71.3 FPS average
on 98, 68.8
FPS on Millennium Edition.
Intrigging.
Next I decided to try Need for
Speed Portia Unleashed, since
die Zeit als Need for Speed noch gut
war.
One of the top games I played on my Compact
running me back then it doesn't have a built-in time demo or benchmark so i just recorded a race
replay and ran fraps on each os and yeah without any totals or averages at the end it's just a
framerate counter in the top left it's tough to say which is better though i'd wager windows 98
wins by a tiny amount if the other examples are any indication either way it's not enough
difference to matter finally i had to try 3d mark 2000 since it runs a whole string of tests
of varying types and gives a nice overall score at the end and yeah no surprise here that the
final results were crazy close just like all the others 4229 3d marks on 98 se versus 4226
on windows 2000 within the margin of error was was war das 3d mark 97 wo man mit dem drache im
kreis geflogen
ist das war glaube ich 3d mark 3 97 or as far as i'm concerned so yeah in terms of direct 3d
open gl and glide mode gaming i can't say it's worth choosing one os over the other there are
no doubt outliers that'll work on 98 and not me and perhaps vice versa but i haven't come across
any on this particular setup yet and i think that's worth noting one more time as we wrap
up here i've built this pc piece by piece over the years to be as awesome as possible
at running the exact games i want in the exact way that i want this is all solid hardware with
excellent vendor support and i already had well made drivers and software set up and ready to go
on 98 se when millennium edition took the reigns here so i've really given it the best possible
chance to succeed and i think that may be one reason it's working so well considering the weird
point in time that me came out in regards to things like low quality sound and graphics hardware wonky
56k modul
Irgendwie, ich muss sagen, das ist zwar ziemlich, das war damals nicht schön zu benutzen teilweise und auch die Videos und so, die Sounds und Themes, das war schon ein bisschen cringe alles.
Irgendwie hat das einen gewissen Charme, ich kann mir das auch nicht erklären.
Oh, die Klammer.
Das stimmt.
Karl Klammer war der Beste.
Und der Verlust eines einfachen MS-DOS-Modes allein ist ein persönlicher Deal-Breaker.
Was für eine erhebliche, arbitrarische Veränderung, Mann.
Ich weiß, Microsoft hat es gemacht, um die Boot-Zeiten zu steigern und die Konflikte zu minimieren.
Und ja, es ist schneller zu starten und ich habe noch keine Bluescreen von Tod so weit.
Aber der Verlust ist nicht wirklich wert, zumindest nicht auf dieser Maschine.
Das gesagt, denke ich, ich werde es auf einem anderen PC installieren.
Etwas, das ich nicht so viel für LGR-Dinge benutze.
Weil...
Ich weiß nicht, warum nicht.
Es ist seltsam, wieder zurück zu gehen und mit Millennium Edition zu messen, das sage ich.
Nicht etwas, was ich je gesagt hätte, aber...
Ja.
Ich verstehe absolut die verletzten Gefühle, ich bin da gewesen.
Aber ich denke auch nicht, dass all der Schmerz auch garantiert ist.
Das heißt nicht, dass ich es empfehlen würde, oder sogar viel Liebe dafür habe.
Windows 98 SE ist immer noch die bessere Wahl für PC-Gaming von 1994 bis 2001.
Und dann einfach mit Windows XP nach dem.
Aber es ist auch nicht das Ende.
Es ist das Ende der Welt, zumindest wenn man sich auf einem sauberen, vertrauten System befindet.
Ich würde sagen, Windows ME ist eigentlich ein bisschen lustig.
In diesem blöden Turn-of-the-Millennium-Grund.
Und das ist zumindest etwas wert.
Das hat er recht.
Ja, das war ein cooles Video.
Wie gesagt, ich kann es mir auch schlecht erklären.
Das hatte irgendwie so einen eigenen Charme, das olle Zeug.
Wenn du dieses LGR-Video genutzt hast, dann warst du sicher...
Das hatte irgendwie so einen eigenen Charme.
Das war halt...
Es war schon vieles ziemlicher Crap im Vergleich zu heute.
Also ich rede jetzt gar nicht mal von Hardware-Leistung oder mehreren CPU-Kernen oder sowas.
Aber andere Sachen waren richtig cool.
Du konntest bis Windows...
Also inklusive Windows XP konntest du Windows komplett stylen, wie du wolltest.
komplett steilen wie du wolltest das sah dann sah dann komplett anders aus da
gab es eine richtige windows styling community die sich dinge rausgebracht
hat das ist auch dieses style xp oder wie dieses komische ding hieß genau das
zeug da konnte alles mögliche steilen übelst nice und du hast dich damals auch
wieder krasse hacker hexer gefühlt wenn irgendwelche registry dinger gemacht
hast und damals musstest du ja viele sachen sogar noch direkt mehr registry
macht ja das war schon da ist das haben wir sonst noch hier zu bieten
bürger ich habe hunger leute muss essen bestellen
back doing smartphone kamera windows xp rain gutter power was ein stumpf sinne
warum sowas denn machen ich muss jetzt mal kurz gucken was der
was was da was da rauskommt bei seinem rain gutter power ich meine da kommt
nicht sonderlich viel regen die regen renne runter hier hat das guckt euch mal
ernsthaft
gibt bestimmt wahnsinnig viel energie das ding was will er damit betreiben was
will er damit betreiben am ende die leute okay cooles hobbyprojekt da wahnsinn
dreht sich
oh
so ein du hast doch noch die ganz liebe
aber den du kannst ja schon kochen
genau was will damit betreiben damit kannst du kriegst du nicht mal
raspberry betrieben kann das ein auto auf
ich überleg gerade was könnte man sinnvolles damit betreiben vielleicht
ich wollte gerade sagen denn den temperatur sensor irgendwie im garten
oder so aber das ist ja nicht dauerhaft das schau dir die später okay das heißt es wird noch weiter in den späteren folgen
also die spät auch es wird noch advanced sondern später folgen aber das ist ja nicht dauerhaft aber das ist ja nicht dauerhaft aber das ist ja nicht dauerhaft aber das ist ja nicht dauerhaft
Oh, es wird immer advancer, Leute.
Es wird immer advancer hier.
WTF.
Okay, wie viel kriegt er raus?
105 Milliampere.
0.8 Watt.
Na ja, damit kannst du schon ein bisschen was anfangen.
Also für einen,
sag mal so, für einen ESP32
reicht's
aus.
Ich überlege gerade, was könnte man
damit schön betreiben?
Er guckt voll stolz. Da kann man doch auch stolz drauf
sein. Das ist ja auch eine nice Geschichte.
Ich meine, also wirklich,
ob da jetzt so wirklich was Sinnvolles mit betrieben
werden kann, weiß ich nicht.
Mir fällt jetzt nichts ein.
Was man damit sinnvoll
betreiben kann, was man
an Stellen braucht, wo man ab und zu mal
Energie über Regenwasser kriegt.
Könnte man da
betreiben? Irgendeine, vielleicht eine
Pumpensteuerung für einen Teich oder so?
Wenn man da ab und zu mal
irgendwas,
irgendwie Sauerstoff, keine Ahnung.
Und wenn es dann nicht regnet, verrecken alle Fische oder wie?
Ne. Also mir fällt jetzt gerade wirklich
nicht viel Sinnvolles ein.
Die Regenmenge messen.
Das kannst du einfacher haben,
die Regenmenge messen.
Dann nimmst du eine Tonne und einen Ultraschallsensor.
Weil die Regenmenge
messen tatsächlich gar nicht so schlecht ist.
Das wäre tatsächlich noch recht
eine sinnvolle Geschichte damit, ja.
Eine LED?
Ne, ne, ne.
Da kannst du deutlich mehr als eine LED mit
mit. Da kannst du, da kannst du
naja
vielleicht, vielleicht eine LED
ein LED-Strip, wenn du ihn
ganz, ganz dunkel stellst, kannst du damit betreiben.
Ja, cooles, cooles Zeug.
Was? Tour of my home network.
Okay.
Was ist das hier?
Was hat er hier am Start?
Was hat er denn da?
Ähm, eine USV?
Irgendein Storage-Ding?
Und was ist das?
Ach, ist das, das ist eine Konsole, oder?
Ist das eine Konsole?
Das sieht aus wie eine Konsole.
Alter, was die Leute alles daheim haben.
Ich denke, ich denke schon immer, ich bin
übertrieben, was ich hier am Start habe.
Mit meinem Mini-Rack und dem 10G-Switch
und sowas. Und dann sehe ich immer Leute
mit ihren Patch-Panels und 48-Port-Switch.
Wobei, das ist kein 48-Port-Switch, das ist ein 24-Port-Switch, ne.
Ähm, ja.
Die gehen teilweise übertrieben ab.
Und das, ich, ich, ich hätte ja
prinzipiell, fände ich es ja auch cool,
mehr daheim zu betreiben.
Also, ein richtig echter, cooler Hardware.
Aber das Problem ist, die Stromkosten sind es nicht wert
für das, was man gewinnt.
Im NA-Pubhouse
kann man einfacher verlegen, das stimmt.
Stimmt! Jetzt ergibt das Sinn.
Jetzt das Wasser aus der Regengrinne.
Dann brauche ich, ja, dann ist easy. Easy.
Fünf Server.
So, you'll see.
That's, äh, my, my fiber
to the home internet connection plugged directly in.
And this has been working solid
for months now.
I very much enjoy
not having to use any of my ISP's.
Das ist eine Konsole. Ziemlich sicher, das ist eine Konsole.
Below that, we've got my Lenovo RD240.
Which, again, you may have seen in my...
Sind das, sind das nur 2,5 Zoll?
Sieht aus wie nur 2,5 Zoll-Platten.
...Unraid-Video.
Ähm, it's still missing that drive
that was dead.
I do have the drive that was dead.
I have the tray and...
Ich habe meine USV übrigens immer noch nicht repariert.
Ist immer noch rip.
...it is actually at my post office box
just down across the border
in the United States, but of course
with COVID I'm not allowed to go down and pick it up.
So that'll have to wait a little bit longer.
Moment, was ist das? Was ist da drinne?
...longer.
Pick it up.
48G! Pff! Okay, das ist eine ältere, ältere
Kiste. 48G ECC
DDR3. Das ist last,
last, bis vor,
last gen. Ähm, dann hat er 7x8G
SAS Drives. Das frisst viel zu viel Strom
für das, was es bringt. But why? Warum
habe ich 7x8G SAS Drives?
Warum? Das ist preis-leistungsmäßig voll
für den Arsch. Und dann irgendeinen älteren
Xeon, was ist denn das? Ein Dualcore?
Quadcore? Keine Ahnung. Aber 2x8G SAS Drives?
Das ist kaum Speicher. Und es zieht Strom wie Sau.
Ein Hexcore. Okay, ordentlich.
So, that'll have to wait a little bit longer.
And, uh, below that we've got my APC, um,
3000... Ne, ne, der meint nicht 8TB, der meint ziemlich sicher 8GB.
...a UPS. Bei der alten Kiste.
I don't currently have it running on a 30A circuit, so I'm not able to actually pull the full 30A out, otherwise it'll just trip the breaker.
But, um, again, in a future video, um, with my little ambitious project that I plan...
Ich will immer noch sehen, was das da oben ist. Ich glaube, das ist ne Konsole.
...we will be running that off a 30A circuit, so we can take full advantage of what this UPS...
Sieht zumindest aus wie ne Konsole.
...just got a old rack-mount HP, uh...
Zeig? Ja, das ist ne Konsole.
...monitor here. Unfortunately, I don't have any of the rails, so it's kind of useless.
Eigentlich komplett, komplett useless, wenn man das, wie ich, um die Ecke stehen hat, aber ich find Konsolen, ich find das irgendwie cool.
...und ich find das irgendwie cool.
Ja? Ich hab keine. Ich hab keine.
Ich brauch auch keine, weil ich könnte einfach nen Monitor oben drauf stellen, überhaupt absolut unnötig, ja?
Aber irgendwie find ich so rack-mounted Konsolen cool.
Was macht man mit dem Ding? Das ist im Prinzip ne Notebook.
Das ist im Prinzip ne Notebook, was du direkt an die Server anschließen kannst, dass du, äh, Tastatur und Monitor für die Server hast.
Das ist nichts anderes wie ne Tastatur und ne Monitor.
Du schlöpselst, du kannst genauso gut ne USB-Tastatur, äh, USB-Tastatur und Monitor oben aufs Rack stellen,
...wenn das so klein ist.
So baubar ist auch kein Problem.
Viel, viel billiger, der Scheiß ist unglaublich teuer und eigentlich komplett sinnlos.
Aber, ich find's trotzdem..., ich find sincer, ich find so rack-mounted Konsolen trotzdem cool.
Und die ganzen Server haben ja heute noch VGA-Ausgänge...
S sana e i ostia,weit ich grad mal utilise, und weil der eigentlich nen transpose Übriger war,
...m Playersverlauf für Flub gapte,
Das ist übrigens kein VGA-Ausgang.
Sayonara,
Das ist eine serielle Schnittstelle für die Konsole.
Aber das Super-Mikro-Chassis gefällt mir.
Ah, so im Detail müssen wir uns das jetzt nicht angucken.
Dass er 8TB meint, 8TB-Platten finde ich aber ganz schön viel, 8TB-SAS-Platten in dem ollen Ding.
Außerdem sind 8TB-SAS-Platten ziemlich teuer.
Ah, gibt's gar nicht zu kaufen.
Aber wenn er 8TB meint, dann lasse ich mir gefallen, das zu betreiben.
Von der, wie alt das ist, hätte ich mir eher 8GB vorstellen können.
Allerdings, nee, 8TB ist sinnvoller, weil 8GB ist noch älter, noch viel älter.
Das hätten, wenn das SAS-Platten gewesen wäre, dann hätte es so 300, 300G oder 270G oder irgendwie sowas sein müssen.
Ja, 8TB, okay. Das war aber ordentlich teuer.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7 und vielleicht 8 hier unten noch, wo gerade nichts eingebaut ist.
8, 8TB-SAS-Platten, das geht ein bisschen ins Geld.
Hast du schon mal die Rack-Hardware von Patchbox gesehen?
Finde die ganz cool, aber deutlich, weil man kein...
Sagt mir jetzt nichts, nee.
Patchbox-Rack.
Das da?
Oh, sieht sehr stylisch aus.
Setup-Exe?
Ah, wollte lustig sein, okay.
Habe ich doch nie im Einsatz gesehen.
Sieht doch aber sehr stylisch aus und sehr, sehr gut organisiert.
Ist ein Raspberry Pi als Grundlage für ein einfaches NAS-Backup-System?
Nee.
Es sei denn, du hast keinerlei Ansprüche an dein NAS.
Dann schon.
Das Problem beim Raspberry Pi, also fangen wir mal an.
Wenn überhaupt, dann eh ein Raspberry Pi.
4.
Alle anderen Raspberry Pis waren sowohl netzwerktechnisch als auch plattenmäßig, USB-plattenmäßig, was auch immer,
viel zu langsam angebunden, dass man es ernsthaft als NAS in Erwägung ziehen könnte.
Beim Raspberry Pi 4 ist es ein bisschen besser.
Die sind jetzt, da ist jetzt alles ein bisschen schneller angebunden.
Zwar immer noch nicht so wahnsinnig schnell, aber man kriegt halbwegs...
Nicht richtig Gigabit, aber sowas in der Richtung wie Gigabit kriegt man raus.
Das Problem ist, dass die Komplettkabeln...
Das Problem ist, dass die Komplettkabeln nicht gespart haben beim Raspberry Pi 4, was die CPU angeht.
Die ARM-CPU, die da drauf ist auf dem Raspberry Pi 4, die hätte eigentlich Crypto-Extensions, aber da haben sich die Raspberry-Leute gedacht, die Crypto-Extensions, die lizenzieren wir nicht.
Der Raspberry Pi 4 mit Crypto-Extensions wäre eigentlich ein ganz brauchbares NAS-System gewesen.
Und ohne Crypto-Extensions ist halt die Frage, wie sinnvoll ein NAS ist.
Wenn man das nicht...
Wenn man die Platten nicht verschlüsseln kann.
Wenn du wirklich nur ein ganz basic NAS haben willst, ohne Plattenverschlüsselung und jetzt ohne wahnsinnig große Performance, dann kannst du ein Raspberry Pi 4 nehmen.
Das funktioniert.
Aber das ist wirklich absolut basic NAS, ohne dass man da irgendwie großartig Sprünge mitmachen kann.
Und ich finde, ein NAS braucht einfach verschlüsselte Platten.
Allein schon aus dem Grund, weil man die Dinger einfach wegschmeißen kann, wenn man sie wegschmeißen will.
Man muss nichts verpassen.
Wenn die Platte kaputt ist und du kannst die Platte nicht löschen, dann musst du die Platte quasi erst mal zerstören, weil du sie nicht überschreiben kannst.
Wenn du auf Nummer sicher gehen willst, dass keiner irgendwie deinen Passwortmanager ausliest oder so, was Schwachsinn ist, was keiner für dich machen wird.
Aber wenn schon, könnte man es auch richtig machen.
Ich würde...
Also wenn es ein Single-Bot-Computer sein muss, würde ich was anderes nehmen.
Ansonsten irgend so ein Low-End-Celeron sind auch nicht schlecht.
Habe ich ja auch gerade hier am Laufen.
Ja, das...
Und da kannst du auch wenigstens dein NAS verschlüsseln und gut ist.
Zumal es gar nicht so verkehrt ist, muss ich jetzt vielleicht mal sagen.
Es ist gar nicht so schlecht, weil dann hast du auch ein ordentliches Gehäuse, weil du musst die Platten doch eh irgendwo hin machen.
Ansonsten hat man einen Raspberry Pi da stehen mit zwei, drei externen USB-Festplatten dran, die auch Platz wegnehmen.
Da kann man auch sich einen halbwegs...
Ordentliches 2HE-Gehäuse kaufen.
Dort einen Low-End-Quasi-Board mit aufgelöteter CPU von Intel reinklatschen.
Die brauchen auch nicht viel Strom, haben deutlich mehr Leistung als ein Raspberry Pi.
Und du kannst auch gleich in das Gehäuse noch ordentlich die Platten einbauen.
Schon Erfahrung mit WireGuard als simples VPN gemacht.
Ja, funktioniert wunderbar.
Viel angenehmer als OpenVPN.
Synology ist okay.
Ich habe keins.
Ich hatte auch noch nie eins.
Aber alles, was man sieht, scheinen die Dinger ganz okay zu sein.
Ein 10-Gig-Netzwerk versus ein 1-Gig.
Also bevor ich weiter gehe, werde ich dir ein bisschen erzählen, wie die Netzwerke aufgebaut werden.
Also wir operieren...
...just because it's such a...
PF-Sense.
PF-Sense habe ich rausgeschmissen bei mir.
Was würdest du empfehlen, damit niemand mehr auf eine alte Festplatte zukommen kann?
Einfach überschreiben.
Wenn sie noch geht, einfach überschreiben.
Einmal reicht.
Einmal überschreiben.
Oder einfach mal 0DD...
...von Anfang bis Ende, dann ist weg.
Keine Chance, was wieder herzustellen.
Wenn du die komplett überschreibst.
Einmalig reicht.
Du musst die nicht 73-mal sonst wie überschreiben.
Einmal mit Nullen überschreiben und gut ist.
Was, Leute?
Guest-WiFi?
Wi-Fi for Guests?
Was?
Was habe ich jetzt?
Hier.
Guest-WiFi.
Was ist daran jetzt so lustig?
Chat, verstehe ich nicht.
Ach, hier unten.
Guest-WiFi.
Wi-Fi for Guests.
Ja, das hätte man vorne nicht erkannt.
Der wollte halt überall, wenn er da schon eine Klammer dahinter macht,
wollte er da auch noch eine Klammer dahinter machen.
Kannst du ein Tool dafür empfehlen?
Ja, DD.
DD, IF, gleich DEV0, OF, gleich DEV, SD, C.
Keine Ahnung, was du da für eine Platte hast.
Dann noch Block Size und gut ist.
DD, einfach drüber DD.
Nullen drüber.
Über DD, über die Platte und gut ist.
Dann ist die von niemandem wiederherzustellen.
Also außer theoretische Maßnahmen geht da nicht.
Also mit Nullen drüber komplett überschreiben, das ist sicher genug.
Was ist D-Bahn?
DD.
Das ist bei jedem Linux vorinstalliert.
Hier, hups, jetzt habe ich es ausgeschaltet aus Versehen.
Das ist total simpel.
Du hast einfach DD, aber musst aufpassen.
Das überschreibt ja auch, wenn du die falsche Platte angibst,
dass du, ne, auch alles andere.
DD, IF, DEV0, OF, gleich DEV.
Und hier machst du die Platte rein.
Machen wir mal hier DEV RAM.
Haben wir das geladen?
Nee, haben wir nicht.
Wie lädt man das?
Laut RAM, DEV RAM.
Wie lädt man den Kram nochmal?
Wow.
What the fuck?
Genau, wie kann man den Kram laden?
Ich lade jetzt mal eine Mini RAM Disk,
dass ich euch zeigen kann, wie das funktioniert.
Äh, was?
Was muss ich für ein, für ein Kernelmodul laden?
Load RAM.
Wie ging der Kram nochmal?
Modprobe.
Man konnte sich doch so Mini RAM Disks in Linux laden.
Wie ging das hier?
Das, ah, RAM 1, ah, ich habe Load Kinox.
Ja, genau, den Kram will ich haben.
Welches Kernelmodul braucht man dafür?
DEV RAM, genau, DEV RAM will ich haben.
DEV RAM, wie lädt man den Kram?
Module.
RAM Disk, hier oder da?
RAM Disk Science, ne, ne, ne.
Alter, das kann doch nicht so kompliziert sein.
Da muss man irgendein Modul laden und dann hat man den Kram.
Okay, wäre gerade so Noob-Style für.
Was, BRD?
Okay, BRD.
BRD.
Und dann?
Habe ich jetzt DEV, DEV RAM?
Ah, excellent.
Jetzt habe ich eine 1 MB große RAM-Disk.
Okay, jetzt kann ich euch das nämlich zeigen.
Also, du sagst, wenn du eine Festplatte, wir gehen jetzt mal davon aus, das hier wäre meine Festplatte.
Du sagst einfach IF DEV 0, Output Device, in dem Fall DEV RAM 0.
Dann sagst du noch eine Block Size von 4K.
Und das war's.
Bäm.
Ja.
Bäm, fertig.
Ja, gut, das ist nur 1 MB groß.
Was auch immer.
Und zack, ist die Festplatte leer.
Ja.
Das dauert dann ein bisschen.
Das dauert dann, je nach Festplatte dauert das schon so 1-2 Stunden, aber dann ist, oder schneller, je nachdem was für eine Platte ist.
Und dann ist sie weg.
Wir reden jetzt von Magnetplatten, nicht von SSDs.
Auf SSDs kannst du eh nicht so wirklich gut was wiederherstellen.
Deswegen ist das auch cool, wenn man einfach standardmäßig encrypted hat.
Dann kann man den Kram in den Müll schmeißen und gut ist.
Also, so, so.
Platte löschen.
BS.
4K, dann geht's schneller.
Ja.
So.
Also, was hat er, was hat er noch alles daheim?
Wifi for Guests.
Das haben wir schon gesehen.
Also, was verwendet er denn für PFSense?
Wie gesagt, ich habe meinen PFSense schon vor zwei Jahren oder so gekickt.
Ich habe jetzt meinen Mikrotik-Router und gut ist.
Der, der, der, guck mal, der macht voll happy Eindruck.
Guck mal, hat er auch einen Unify-WLAN.
Sehr schön.
Qualitativ super.
Kann man empfehlen.
Ich habe auch zwei Unify-Access-Points.
Funktioniert wunderbar.
Ohne Count überschreibe ich nicht alles.
Doch.
Ohne Count überschreibst du alles bis zum Schluss?
Oder nicht?
Bin ich jetzt ziemlich sicher?
Überschreibst du alles ohne Count?
Oder machst du nur einmal?
Nee, oder?
Nee, 100.
Du überschreibst alles, oder?
Nicht?
Bin ich jetzt...
Ha!
Ich glaube, man braucht keinen Count.
Ohne Count macht er alles.
Probier es auf dev.sda.
Wir können das ein bisschen größer machen hier.
Oh, hier kann man anscheinend Sachen angeben.
Guck mal, wie groß die RAM-Desk sein soll.
Huge.
RD-Size.
Okay, machen wir mal.
Mod-Probe.
Minus R.
Löschen wir den Kram mal wieder.
Jetzt ist dev-RAM weg.
So.
Jetzt machen wir das Gleiche wieder.
Mod-Probe.
Ja.
BRD.
Das da.
Das sind Bytes, ha?
Nee.
Was?
Ach so, Sudo.
Sind das Bytes?
So, wie groß ist der Kram jetzt?
Wird er nur eins?
Warum ist es wieder nur eins?
Oh.
4,38G.
Excellent.
Da können wir jetzt ordentlich draufhauen.
DD.
RAM-Zero.
4K.
Block-Size.
Bam.
Der ohne Count überschreibt da alles.
Ohne Count überschreibt da alles.
War so, wie ich das erwartet habe.
Wir können noch Procreate.
Wie ging das?
Progress.
DD.
Stats.
Progress.
Können wir anzeigen lassen.
Dann sieht man auch, was er macht.
Der schreibt mit irgendwie 900 MB die Sekunde jetzt 4 GB RAM voll.
Easy.
Ist keine so gute Idee, weil ich habe, glaube nur, 8 GB RAM.
Aber du siehst, so kannst du deine Festplatte de-deen.
Einfach sagen, genau so, wie ich es hier angegeben habe.
Dev-Zero.
Hier schreibst du das Device hin von deiner Festplatte.
Anstatt jetzt, wo ich RAM Null stehen habe.
Block-Size 4K ist gut.
Und Status, dass du siehst, wie weit er ist.
Und druff.
Und dann läuft das Ganze ein bisschen und deine Platte ist geseroed.
Und nicht wiederherstellbar.
So ohne weiteres.
Eigentlich gar nicht wiederherstellbar.
So, die Dinger lohnen sich echt.
Die UniFi Dinger.
Die sind richtig gut.
Was hatte ich denn sonst noch am Start?
Alright, moving up.
We've got my two main switches here.
And we've got a Procurve 2824.
Braucht wahrscheinlich viel zu viel Strom.
Das sind so ehemalige Switche, die die mittlerweile im RZ ausgemustert haben.
Und die Dinger sind halt weder leise noch stromsparend.
My main network switch.
And then on top of that is an old Nortel PoE switch.
That's a Base-Stack 5520-24T.
And that gives me 1 Gigabit on every port.
So that I use for my APs as well as a lot of my IOT devices.
And I've built a lot of them myself.
So this is an example.
Das war dein Damenstart.
But I've been using these PoE-Splitters as they're called.
Auf die Idee bin ich noch gar nicht gekommen, einen ESP mit einem PoE-Splitter zu betreiben.
Eigentlich voll die Energie...
Nein, was heißt Energie?
Bei dem Bereich nicht wirklich.
Aber da musste 48 Volt auf 3,3...
Dota-Joker, ja das meine ich, genau das.
Das sind so die ollen Switche, die alle schon ausrangiert haben.
Felix Tegi, 8 Monate, huge subscriber.
Nice, dankeschön für den Sub.
Das ist vor allem ein riesen IOT-Device, was hat er denn da drin?
Remote-Modules running options in the house and this one...
...to the network.
One of the things I did when I moved into this house...
Was sagst du eigentlich zum neuen O-Troid C4?
Haben die einen neuen?
Wusste ich gar nicht.
Müssen wir doch gleich mal gucken, ob es ein schönes Review auf YouTube gibt.
Ja, das gucken wir uns gleich nochmal an.
Wir sind eh ganz schön lang heute am Start, kann das sein?
Drei Stunden schon.
Egal, weiter geht's.
Eats.
...room where I thought I would have computers.
And that's what these...
Den gucken wir uns gleich mal an.
Alex, dankeschön für den Sub.
Zwei Monate, huge.
DerAlex14319999999999
Bist du...bist du...äh...kennst du den...
... Michael500000000000?
Euer Benutzername erinnert mich irgendwie an ander.
Dankeschön für zwei Monate Subs.
Huge.
HyperSubScrimer.
Das ist die Ami Wand.
Die Ami Wände, ey.
Die Ami-Wände.
Probiert mal sowas bei euch in die Wand zu kriegen.
Da stürzt vorher das Haus ein, bevor ihr das in der Wand drin habt.
Was hat er da ohne drin?
Löscher.
NA-Wand.
Für zukünftige Verwendung.
Was?
Ja.
Das finde ich auch.
Das finde ich gut.
Es ist nie verkehrt, überall Netzwerkanschlüsse zu haben.
Das haben wir hier im Haus ein bisschen verkackt, ehrlich gesagt.
Und das, obwohl ich...
Es hätte eigentlich besser wissen müssen.
Wir haben nicht an allen Stellen Leerrohre.
Und wir haben an viel zu wenig Stellen Strom...
Steckdosen und Netzwerkkabel gelegt.
Da bin ich selber dran schuld.
Da habe ich nicht richtig aufgepasst damals, als wir hier umgebaut haben.
Das war ein ziemlicher Fail von mir.
Aber das Beste ist, eine Sache ist ganz gut.
Das heißt, man kann alles irgendwie noch ein bisschen fixen.
Es läuft einmal laufen sechs Netzwerkkabel vom Keller über das Erdgeschoss in meinen Serverraum rein.
Die sind alle bis auf zwei oder so.
Unbenutzt.
Das heißt, ich habe da massig, massig Verbindungskabel noch zwischen den Stockwerken.
An einer ganz günstigen Position.
Und dort, wo ich euch das Bild von der Gegensprechanlage gezeigt habe, im Flur,
dort sind Leerrohre in der Wand.
Also sprich, da kann ich vom Keller in die einzelnen Stockwerke noch Kabel ziehen, wenn ich will.
Das funktioniert.
Ohne Riesenakt.
Aber trotzdem zu wenig.
Beispielsweise komme ich jetzt...
Nicht so ohne weiteres mehr Strom im Flur.
Oder ein Netzwerkkabel, sagen wir mal, jetzt an der Stelle vom Flur bei mir ins Schlafzimmer,
falls ich da irgendwie irgendwas noch hinstellen will.
Access Point oder so.
Das funktioniert nicht.
Das ist halt...
Das ist halt Sack ein bisschen.
Hättest du die Wände aus NA, Pappe?
Ja, das stimmt.
Wir haben noch zwei Katz 6 Jacks drin.
Ah, das ist ein typischer NA-Klimaanlage.
Ah, Custom Firmware.
Der Mann weiß, wovon er redet.
Das ist so eine typische NA-Klimaanlage.
Ah, Home Assistant.
Der weiß, wovon er redet.
Guter Mann.
Da hat er seine Unify Access Points.
Der hat es übrigens richtig gemacht.
Der hat die an die Decke montiert.
Die Dinger...
Die Dinger sind auch für Deckenmontage gedacht.
Sowohl von der Charakteristik, wie sich quasi das mit den Antennen da drin verhält,
als auch...
Auch von den Montagelöchern.
Die sind für Deckenmontage gedacht.
Und nicht, wie bei mir, dass die auf der Erde liegen.
Ubiquiti ist der Hersteller.
Unify ist die Serie von Netzwerkgeräten,
die sich über so einen zentralen Controller verwalten lässt bei denen.
Das ist mein Haupt-Ansatzpunkt,
der UAP-AC-Pro.
Was ich dir empfehlen kann, Dota-Joker,
was was bringt bei Reichweite ist,
wenn du statt 5 GHz WLAN 2,4 GHz WLAN verwendest.
2,4 GHz WLAN geht ein bisschen leichter durch Wände durch
und geht ein bisschen weiter als 5 GHz WLAN.
Das könntest du mal ausprobieren.
Ob das was bringt bei dir.
Und das ist ziemlich dediziert
zu unseren Smartphones
und Laptops.
Kein IOT-Device kann das.
Eigentlich eine Sache zu bemerken,
sogar der upstairs hat das,
aber es ist in den Atem.
Ah, das ist ein Unify-Controller.
Ne, das ist ein 2,4 GHz WLAN ist aber absolut lahm.
Ach was, 2,4 GHz WLAN mit ordentlichem Empfang reicht locker.
Und wenn ich die Auswahl habe zwischen
5 GHz WLAN mit Scheiß-Empfang,
der laufend abbricht,
zu 2,4 GHz WLAN mit ausreichendem Empfang,
dann ist das ein Dildo.
Und dann ist klar, was ich nehme.
Äh, ist ein PoE.
Was konvertert das Ding eigentlich?
Was?
Converts?
Passive PoE-Devices into 802.3af?
Hä?
Was macht das?
Ah, verstehe.
Die Unify-Dinger brauchen
Special PoE.
Na dann.
Funktioniert.
Kein Grund, was zu erinnern, wenn es gut funktioniert.
Da hat ganz schön viele verteilt.
Sorry about the bad digital Zoom quality there.
This one is, uh, so I still have good 5G signal
when I'm outside here doing...
Würde mich mal interessieren,
ob man das ordentlich abgesichert hat.
Nicht, dass da jetzt einer über den Zaun geht
und mal einen Laptop an sein Netzwerkkabel anschließt.
Wieso braucht er WLAN im Carport?
Vielleicht schraubt er öfters was am Auto rum.
Braucht er irgendwie Radio, Internet,
sonst was zum Nachgucken.
Also ich, ich hab auch geguckt,
dass ich möglichst gute WLAN-Abdeckung hab.
Ähm, also ich hab hier komplett im Haus,
Hof, Terrasse geht auch,
Eingang zum Garten geht,
aber ab dem, ab dem Garten,
ab dem Garten ist kein, kein WLAN-Empfang mehr.
Bei, bei mir.
Und ich hab mir überlegt,
ob ich nicht in den, äh, in den Schuppen,
also da in die, in den, was heißt Schuppen,
in den, in die, in die, in die Werkstatt,
ob ich da nicht noch einen Access-Point stellen soll,
aber ich bin so selten im Garten,
wo ich irgendwas mache, wo ich WLAN bräuchte.
Im Zweifelsfall hab ich mein Smartphone mit
und der hat 3G-Empfang im Garten
oder wahrscheinlich sogar, äh, LTE-Empfang im Garten.
Das brauch ich nicht unbedingt.
Das bräuchte ich nur, wenn ich auf irgendwelche internen Sachen
aus dem Garten zugreifen will
und, pff, hatte ich bis jetzt noch nicht.
Whatever I do out here.
So, I've got four direct-barry lines that go out.
Three of them are right here.
Uh, two of them go to my shed.
Um, one of them's connected directly to my shed access point.
And the other one goes into a switch,
which we'll talk about in a few minutes.
And then, uh, my other two lines,
one is currently feeding an outdoor camera.
The fourth line is actually plugged into this,
and this is actually just running an outdoor light right now,
um, that is supposed to be a camera position at some point.
So, this is my shed.
And this is the future home of my home server room,
which is gonna be built somewhere behind me.
Yes, that's right.
I'm gonna be moving all my servers into this shed.
That's a project that...
So, dass schön jeder an die Sachen drankommt,
wenn er mal kurz über den, über den Zaun steigt.
Excellent.
If you wanna see more about, make sure you subscribe,
because I'll show you what I do have.
Wahrscheinlich hat seine Frau gesagt,
Alter, mach mal die Dinger hier weg.
So hässliche Elektronikgeräte will ich nicht sehen.
Zu laut, zu warm, zu hässlich.
Ich kann, ich kann die Abneigung von, von, äh,
gerade Mädels, ist es ja zum, zum überwiegenden Teil,
äh, gegen nackte Elektronikteile nicht verstehen.
Ganz viele, also, nicht nur Mädels,
es gibt auch genug nicht so technikaffine, ähm, Leute,
die mögen Technikteile nicht, die nach Technik aussehen.
Also, sprich, wenn ihr da,
äh, einen, äh, Mac, Mac Mini hinstellt,
sagen die Leute, ah, yes, Mac Mini passt,
kann man hinstellen, sieht schick aus.
Wenn ihr dort einen Raspberry Pi hinstellt,
mit einem durchsichtigen Gehäuse,
sagen die Leute, äh, Technikkram, macht es weg da.
Ja.
Versteh, ich versteh die Abneigung gegen, gegen Technik,
die nach Technik aussieht, gar nicht.
Das ist doch gerade, das ist doch gerade,
das ist doch noch viel besser,
wenn die Technik nach Technik aussieht.
Äh, Cat 6 Direct Burial Lines, I was talking about,
äh, going to a, äh,
surface mount, äh, wall jack there.
One of those goes directly to the outdoor access point,
and then another one goes to my...
Wow!
Excellent!
Was hat er denn da am Start?
Irgendwelche Relays, würde ich sagen,
das sind irgendwelche Relays zum Schalten,
von was auch immer.
Das ist ein Arduino, ha, ein oller,
ein oller Arduino, könnte das sein.
Oder ist das ein,
es sieht nicht nach einem Raspberry aus,
es ist bestimmt ein oller Arduino,
von einer, von einer,
wie, wie fett das Ding ist,
und von den, von den Anschlüssen.
Das ist irgendein, ein Uno oder so,
ein alter Arduino,
alter Arduino und ein Board mit, äh, Relays dran.
Wo fällt dann so ein Intel NUC hin?
Ach, das ist wahrscheinlich auch okay für die meisten Leute.
Solange man in Technik nicht Technik sieht,
haben die meisten Leute damit wenig Probleme.
Das ist irgendwas zum Draufklemmen.
Ich würde sagen, das ist ein Arduino,
der, äh, irgendwelche Relays an- und ausschaltet für ihn.
Der restliche Kram, kein Schimmer.
Ja.
Wenn da mal das Dach unsicht, undicht ist, ja.
Das ist ein Arduino, das ist ein Arduino mit, ähm,
mit ein paar Relays zum, so, so ein Relay Board zum Schalten.
Da stellst du da der PoE Switch.
Ja.
Ah, war doch ganz nett.
Was kann jemand mit meinem IP-Adress tun?
Okay, ich ahne Schlimmes, wenn ich das Video und den Titel schon höre.
Was hast du mit deinem Excelent? Ich habe sie nicht mal alle.
Das ist das Problem, was das angeht.
Oder gleich schläft er ein.
Und heute werden wir darüber sprechen, was kann jemand mit meinem IP-Adress tun?
Also, ja, das ist mein eigentliche IP-Adress, hier.
Und es zeigt, welches Staat ich bin, nämlich WI Wisconsin.
Und es zeigt mein ISP, das ist Comcast.
Also, was ist davon? Ich habe keine Angst, mein IP-Adress zu zeigen.
Wenn du mich offline hinstellen wirst, fühl dich bereit, es zu tun.
Du kannst es nicht. Und wenn du es tust, weißt du,
jede Verbindung, die durch mein Modem kommt,
logge ich. Und ich schicke Logge nach den richtigen
Behörden.
Geil.
Erst mal seine Public-IP hinschreiben
und dann sagen, ich logge alle IPs mit
und zeige euch an, oder was?
What the fuck?
Das ist NA-Logik. Mal ganz davon abgesehen,
es kann ja wohl kaum verboten sein,
wenn er hier online öffentlich seine IP zeigt,
mal einen Portscan drauf zu machen.
Ein Portscan ist doch nichts Verbotenes.
Ich könnte mir wirklich weniger kümmern.
Und wenn du denkst, dass du mehr davon tun kannst,
bin ich bereit für eine Herausforderung.
Ich bin immer bereit für eine Herausforderung.
Okay, also, was können wir mit einem IP-Adress tun?
Aber bevor wir anfangen,
wenn ihr mir einen großen Glückwunsch machen könnt,
dann abonniert den Kanal.
Ja, total schockierend. Geile Logik, oder?
Es kann überhaupt nichts passieren. Keine Angst.
Aber wenn, ich verklag euch.
Wenn ich live oder ein Video veröffentliche,
dann werdet ihr bemerkt, wenn ihr Fragen habt.
Vor allem, wenn ich live streamen mache.
Kommt bitte rein.
Wenn ihr mir fragt, ob ich etwas Illegales tue,
oder wie man etwas Illegales macht,
dann wird das nicht passieren.
Haltet das aus eurem Kopf.
Ich helfe euch nicht mit irgendeiner Illegalen-Aktivität.
Ich habe auch einen zweiten Kanal,
der Codex4Games ist.
Ja, komm, genug Werbung jetzt.
Lasst uns über das Gute und das Böse sprechen.
Das Gute ist,
lasst uns hier einen Command-Prompt öffnen.
Oh, ja.
Let's upon a time,
back in the early 1990s,
we had nothing but...
Was kommt denn jetzt?
Put that down.
Back in the early 1990s,
we had nothing but IP-Addresses to memorize.
So, for example...
Moment, DNS gab es damals auch schon.
Kiffken, acht Monate.
Huge subscriber.
Dankeschön.
Excellent IQ-Subscriber.
High IQ-Chat heute wieder.
Google.com.
Well, you need an IP-Address.
Nein!
Du hast für Google.com noch nie die IP...
What the fuck?
Das Ding heißt nicht umsonst Google.com.
Okay, vielleicht habe ich auch nicht richtig zugehört,
was er gesagt hat.
So, for example,
how do you get to Google.com?
Well, you need an IP-Address.
Das stimmt.
Hat er recht.
Ich habe es falsch interpretiert.
Ich dachte, er wollte mir damals erzählen,
er muss für Google die IP eingeben.
Nee, nee.
Der will wahrscheinlich auf DNS jetzt raus.
Okay, nee.
Ich habe Mist erzählt.
Okay.
So.
Und dann solutioniert er,
dass er auch dort oder oder.
Okay.
Yes, okay.
Let's bring up Google here.
It's probably going to give us an IPv6.
Okay.
So this is the IPv6.
We want an IPv4.
Let's go ahead and cancel out of that.
Ping IP chicken.
I am pretty sureider.
Okay.
IPv4.
This is an IPv4.
So, back in the early 1990s,
we needed to connect with a IPv4-Address.
Domains weren't a thing.
Was?!
Was?
Also, ich kann mich an keine Zeit erinnern, wo es kein DNS gab. Echt nicht.
Also, es gibt Leute, die natürlich lokal bei sich im Netzwerk keine DNS-Namen verwenden, einfach IPs.
Ich habe bei mir auch nicht alles DNS-Namen vergeben, wozu.
Aber alles, was online war, ich kann mich an keine Zeit erinnern.
Und es wäre auch sehr, sehr merkwürdig, wenn man dort in seinen Browser IPs eingegeben hat, statt Domains.
Seit es zu dieser normalen www-Browser-Geschichte, man hat nur Domain-Names verwendet.
Was ein Schwachsinn.
Außerdem ist DNS überhaupt nichts Neues.
Okay, wenn er die Zeit meint, wo es nur fünf Server im Internet gab, dann ja, aber das ist ganz schön so fast-stretched irgendwie.
BTX hieß das Ding.
BTX von der Telekom.
Everybody and every business, every service, anybody that has the Internet has an IP address.
This is no news.
So, that is the legitimacy.
Er hat da eigentlich die Xbox-App auf.
Ach, der rekordet mit der...
Nee, jetzt läuft jetzt da unten die Playstation.
Was ist das da unten?
Was läuft da unten überhaupt durch?
To identify each other.
So, I could be running a gaming server, like, I don't know, Minecraft server.
And you guys would need my IP address to connect.
And that's how IP addressing works.
Das ist heute immer noch so.
Getting towards its destination.
Now, that's the legitimacy of things.
But what about malicious things?
Oh, jetzt kommt's.
Let's say, for example, I am running a website and you're gonna be needing my IP address.
So, let's just say you obtain my IP...
Okay, well, you've obtained my IP address.
Okay, was will er uns eigentlich mitteilen?
Let's just say, with my IP address, since you have it now...
Verdammt, liegt.
Okay, here's where things are gonna get...
Wtf, was will er eigentlich?
Ich krieg Anfälle.
Über dem Video.
...a little bit technical.
And before I get into that, I just wanna let it be known that if you guys are too skeptical of when somebody has your IP
and you keep getting booting offline or something worse,
is I do have videos of how to protect yourself, how to change your IP,
how to connect to a VPN on a computer or...
Ey, jetzt erst mal NordVPN-Sponsor.
Das erste, was ich jetzt mal machen würde, ist,
wie alt ist das Video, wollen wir mal ein Nmap auf seine IP machen?
Ne, das ist zu alt, die gilt nicht immer.
Das erste, was ich machen würde, ist erst mal mit einem Port-Scan drauf machen
und feststellen, dass wahrscheinlich nichts offen ist und ich nicht weitergucken.
Ich meine, es kann natürlich auch sein, dass was offen ist, aber der Port-Scan ist nicht erkennt,
aber wahrscheinlich würde ich einen Port-Scan machen und feststellen, ah, ist nix auf und tschüss.
Vergebene Mühe.
PlayStation, Xbox, Links will be in the description down below.
So, if you ever need to change your IP or get a VPN,
I do have tutorials on that, I'll put it in the description.
Everything resourceful for you will be in the bad and a little bit more technical stuff.
So, you have my IP address.
I mean, yeah, sure, if I didn't have a Cisco modem slash router...
Router?
Yeah, you'd probably be able to hit me off.
Then, oh well, all I gotta do is just unplug my modem and plug it back in,
then my IP address will change.
Big deal.
Nicht unbedingt.
Also, bei den ganzen Kabelanbietern ist das zum Beispiel nicht so.
Ich bezweifle, dass die meisten Leute die Kapazität und Brain überhaupt dazu haben,
selbst wenn sie eine IP-Adresse von jemandem haben, damit auch eine Ansatzweise, irgendwas zu machen.
Was willst du damit großartig machen?
Selbst bei irgendwelchen Leuten zu DDoSen ist es nicht so einfach.
Wo führt das Video noch hin?
Oh, Haxor, Haxor über die IP.
Jetzt geht's aber ab.
Also, KingWall, ich bezweifle, dass die meisten Leute das überhaupt hinbekommen.
Oh ja, erzähl.
Tell me more.
In that case.
So, the person has my IP address and...
And what server...
Oh, du magst das Video zur Hälfte schon rum.
...services am I running?
Am I running a web server?
Am I running...
Können wir das Video bitte überspringen?
Nee.
Wir müssen jetzt gucken, was da...
Wie er gehackt werden will.
...Ironcraft server.
Am I running some type of server?
So, what they need to do is...
Kurzwort, ja, das habe ich mitgekriegt.
Das war aber...
Der wurde nicht gehackt, Sword.
Also, wenn es der Fall ist, den ich kenne.
Der Kurzwort schreibt gerade...
Hast du mal von MontanaBlack damals mitbekommen,
da hat sich ja jemand in seinen Stream gehackten Werbung gemacht.
Soweit ich weiß, wenn es der Fall ist, den ich mitbekommen habe,
dann hat sich keiner in den Stream gehackt,
sondern Streamlabs, beziehungsweise die Seiten,
wo er Text-to-Speech-Notifications her hatte,
die hatten irgendeinen Fehler,
dass man entweder die Url, die man braucht,
um Sachen anzuzeigen, erraten konnte,
oder er hat die Url mal geleakt.
Ich weiß nicht mehr.
Es war...
Es war irgendein Fehler beim Anbieter
dieser Text-to-Speech-Notification-Geschichte.
Das war nichts wirklich, wo er gehackt wurde.
Falls es das war, was ich im Kopf habe.
Es ist eh sehr schwammig, ja.
So diese Sachen, wenn die Leute ankommen,
ich hacke dich oder irgendwas.
Was willst du mir überhaupt damit mitteilen?
Was?
Mein Google-Account, da lache ich aber mal drüber.
Mein E-Mail-Account, man, irgendwie willst du mir...
Willst du mir was einschleusen auf dem Rechner?
Was, was, was genau eigentlich?
Ey, also dieses einfach nur Hacken in den Raum werfen,
ist komplett nichtssagend eigentlich.
Zum Beispiel, wo man von Hacken in dem Sinn sprechen könnte.
Gehen wir mal von aus, viele Leute haben Discord laufen.
Ich sehe es hier unten auch gerade.
Gehen wir jetzt mal von aus, Discord oder irgendein Spiel,
hatten wir letztens mit der Safe-Game-Lücke.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr das mitgekriegt habt,
mit der Safe-Game-Lücke.
Gehen wir mal von aus, Discord oder ein Spiel bei Steam oder irgendwas.
Das, was möglichst viele Leute benutzen,
sodass es auch interessant ist, sich darauf zu konzentrieren.
Das hat irgendwie die Möglichkeit,
dass man im Kontext dieses Spiels,
beziehungsweise dann im Kontext des jeweiligen Benutzers,
Code ausführen kann.
Das ist was, wo man dann wirklich von, nennen wir es mal,
irgendwo...
Dass man gehackt wurde, in irgendeiner Art und Weise.
Und Code ausführen alleine ist ja auch noch nicht alles.
Meistens muss man auch gucken, dass man irgendwie Admin-Rechte kriegt.
Und wenn man keine Admin-Rechte kriegt,
dass man zumindest es irgendwie schafft,
dort Sachen einzuschleusen,
die dann selbst wiederum im Hintergrund laufen.
Die auch weiterlaufen, wenn das Spiel dann beispielsweise aus ist
und solche Geschichten.
Das ist deutlich schwieriger, als das immer so hingestellt wird.
So nach dem Motto, ja, jetzt wird es mal kurz gehackt.
Nein, wirst du nicht.
Das war vielleicht zu Windows 98 Zeiten so,
wo die Leute noch ein Modem direkt am Internet hatten,
ohne jegliches NAT davor, ohne jegliche Firewall davor.
Direkt mit Exposed Samba-Ports im Internet.
So nach dem Motto, ja, okay, vielleicht.
Aber das ist gar nicht so einfach, wie sich das immer anhört.
Es ist auch überhaupt kein Problem,
den...
einen Virus...
bei einem auf den Rechner zu bekommen.
Das kann dir irgendjemand eine E-Mail schicken mit einem Virus im Anhang.
Dass die Datei mit dem Virus auf dem Rechner landet, ist kein Problem.
Das ist easy as fuck.
Das Problem ist, die Datei muss ausgeführt werden.
Und das ist das eigentliche Problem.
Das ist das eigentliche Problem.
Das eigentliche Problem bei Viren ist nicht so sehr,
die Viren auf den Rechner zu bekommen, sondern dass sie ausgeführt werden.
Und dazu brauchst du meistens Sicherheitslücken
oder dämliche Benutzer,
die jeden Scheiß anklicken, also die es quasi freiwillig ausführen,
dass das überhaupt aktiv wird.
Ja, und gehen wir jetzt mal von aus, beispielsweise Discord,
das ist das, was ich sagen wollte.
Gehen wir mal beispielsweise von Discord aus.
Discord haben viele Leute.
Wenn Discord jetzt irgendeine Schwachstelle hätte,
sagen wir, im Paaren von, dass sie den Chat-Text,
den Text nicht richtig escapen.
So, das war ja der Fall beispielsweise bei MontanaBlack im Stream
mit den Einblendungen.
Also mal angenommen, die würden die Text-Nachrichten irgendwie
intern nochmal verarbeiten und die nicht richtig escapen.
Dann hättest du die Chance über, so wie es jetzt gerade bei Apple
mit den manipulierten Mails und schon oftmals mit den manipulierten
iMessages gewesen ist, dann hättest du die Chance,
dort irgendwas einzuschleusen.
Allerdings müssen da mehrere,
mehrere Sachen zusammenkommen.
Ja, nur weil die das nicht richtig escapen,
heißt auch lange nicht, dass du was einschleusen kannst.
Also das muss dann nicht richtig escaped sein.
Und es müssen noch ein paar andere Sachen glückliche,
sich glücklich fügen, sag ich mal, dass das gut funktioniert.
Einfach was nicht richtig parsen ist nicht das Problem.
Wenn ich das dann allerdings nicht richtig geparsed in,
sag mal ganz bitt' mich, in irgendeinen Exsack reinstecke,
dann wird's problematisch.
Und das ist alles nicht so,
nicht so easy, wie sich das immer anhört.
So nach dem Motto, ah, hier, easy hack, sonst wie, Rechner übernommen.
Ähm, tja.
Wie escapt man Text richtig?
Kommt drauf an, was du machen willst.
Also, wenn du mal angenommen, du hast einen,
was hat man früher so gemacht, mal angenommen, du hast eine Webseite.
Auf dieser Webseite kannst du irgendwelche Kommandos eingeben.
Und diese Kommandos werden dann auf dem Server ausgeführt.
Gehen wir vom einfachsten Fall aus, das sind Shell-Kommandos.
Äh, ein Shell-Kommando sieht ja, sieht ja so aus, so, sagen wir mal hier, so, was weiß ich,
LS, so, Shell-Kommando, LS, siehst du, ähm, den Inhalt vom Verzeichnis auf dem Server,
würdest du dann sehen.
Gut, mal angenommen, du kannst einen LS einschleusen.
Das ist ja nicht das, was du machen willst.
Du musst dann irgendwie gucken, dass du noch mehr ausführen kannst.
Und zum Beispiel kannst du, anstatt einen Befehl,
kannst du noch einen zweiten Befehl anhängen mit einem Semikolon dahinter.
Also sprich, du kannst beispielsweise sagen, LS minus LA, Semikolon,
Reboot oder so, irgendwas in der Richtung.
So, das machen wir jetzt nicht.
LS minus LA, hier, keine Ahnung, äh, Echo, blub.
So, und mal angenommen, der Server passt diesen Input hier falsch
und, ähm, escaped das, ähm, escaped hier dieses Semikolon, nicht?
Und dann siehst du an der Stelle, was passiert, ergibt jetzt nicht etwa Echo 2, Echo 1,
sondern ergibt Echo 2 aus, führt einen neuen Befehl aus, Echo 1.
So, und das ist halt, wenn das nicht escaped ist.
Wenn das Ganze escaped ist, ist kein Problem, dann führt er das Richtige aus,
nämlich Echo und das als Parameter.
Kannst du mal bitte an A minus A machen?
Warum willst du meine Kernelversion wissen?
Jetzt gucken wir, ob ich krasse Kernel-Bugs hab.
Also, die, die, ich hab schon eine Weile nicht mehr geupdatet, MonkaS.
Ähm, äh, das, was Steinex da schreibt,
ich zeig euch mal kurz was, das ist kein, kein Hack im eigentlichen Sinne oder so,
sondern, äh, ich muss nur gucken, dass ich's nicht ausführe aus Versehen.
Ich zeig, ich zeig euch das mal kurz.
Also, das, was Steinex hier geschrieben hat, äh, ist eine sehr beliebte,
sehr beliebte Sache, um Leute zu ärgern, die, äh, neu in Linux sind.
Ähm, und zwar, was es macht, ist Folgendes, das ist eine Forkbomb.
Das sorgt dafür, dass das System nach ein paar Sekunden einfriert.
Ähm.
Und zwar funktioniert das Ganze folgendermaßen.
Das ist eine Funktion mit dem Namen Doppelpunkt.
So.
Und was die Funktion macht, ist, das ist der Body von der Funktion.
Also, wir haben eine Funktion, die sich Doppelpunkt nennt.
Der Name der Funktion ist Doppelpunkt, das ist eine Funktion, das ist Klammer auf, Klammer zu.
Das ist Bash-Syntax.
Ähm, in, ich könnte es jetzt theoretisch zeigen, aber ich will mein PPGA-Board nicht, nicht, äh, kaputt machen.
Äh, der Body der Funktion, also sprich, dass das, das, was die Funktion ausführt, ist Folgendes.
Es ruft eine Funktion mit dem Namen Doppelpunkt auf, also es ruft sich selber, selber auf, pipet den Aus-, den Output nach nochmal nem Aufruf der Funktion Doppelpunkt, also was im Prinzip zweimal die Funktion Doppelpunkt ist, und macht das Ganze im Hintergrund, sodass es nicht blockiert.
So.
Das ist Abschluss der, der quasi Funktionsdefinition.
Nächstes Kommando.
Doppelpunkt.
So, und was das macht ist, hier fängt's an, das hier fängt's an, hier ruft es die Funktion mit dem Namen Doppelpunkt auf.
Die Funktion mit dem Namen Doppelpunkt ruft sich selber zweimal auf und geht in den Hintergrund und ruft sich selber zweimal auf, ruft sich selber zweimal auf, ruft sich selber zweimal auf, also sprich, von einem Funktionsaufruf sind wir bei 30, äh, Trillionen, Billiarden, Billiarden, Ionen, Zillionen, was auch immer Funktionsaufrufe.
Und deswegen, ähm, friert dir einfach dein Rechner ein.
Da passiert nichts Schlimmes, es friert dir einfach der Rechner ein.
Du musst neu starten.
Und selbst das klappt auf vielen modernen Linux-Systemen nicht mehr, weil die für normale User ein, ähm, äh, Prozess-Limit, äh, Fork-Limit, was auch immer, gesetzt haben, da passiert dann gar nichts.
Moin, Sir of Jelly.
Lange nicht gesehen.
Daniel Lull ist am Start.
Zehn Monate.
Exzellent.
Mango United Gaming.
Twitch Prime.
Zum ersten Mal Subscriber.
Dankeschön.
Easy Sub.
Easy Life.
Nice.
Scan through.
So.
They either have a private exploit or a public exploit.
So, I'm going to show you a public exploit site.
So, we're going to go to exploit DB.
Jetzt kommen die richtigen Hackertricks.
And again, this is just all public.
So, these are all exploits.
So, am I going to be running a web application, remote exploits, local and privileged exploitation exploits?
Das bringt doch keinem was, wenn du überhaupt nicht, wenn du an der NAT-IP vom Router hängen bleibst.
... all the servers and POC exploits.
POC? Es gibt POC exploits.
So, we're going to talk about web applications.
We're going to say, I'm running a web server.
For example...
POC exploits. Ich weiß, dass man es POC schreibt, bevor es die Leute wieder ankommen.
Nein, Max, das ist mein Proof of Concept.
Aber ich finde POC exploits eigentlich viel besser.
Okay, so this is the...
WordPress, ist klar.
Ich habe eine WordPress bei mir lokal auf dem Windows-Rechner laufen, in der alten Version,
und habe einen Port weitergeleitet von meinem Router zu meinem WordPress auf meinem Windows.
Excellent.
Kannst du den bitte... Ja, ich mache aus.
Das ist wirklich ein doofes Video.
Es ist gar nicht...
Also, vom Inhalt her ist das Video gar nicht so schlecht.
Ich glaube, das Problem ist nur, dass derjenige, der das Ganze präsentiert, gar nicht so richtig genau weiß, wovon er redet.
Wobei ich mir nicht sicher bin.
Es könnte auch sein, dass er es einfach nur schlecht präsentiert hat.
Was macht er denn sonst so?
Okay, der macht doch anderes Hacker-Zeug.
Also, es ist durchaus möglich, dass es einfach nur schlecht präsentiert ist.
Netz-Stat. What's on your network?
Mit Netz-Stat kann man übrigens nicht gucken, was auf seinem Netzwerk ist,
... sondern nur, was er macht.
Was man lokal hat.
Beziehungsweise Verbindungen, die man lokal hat, nicht was im Netzwerk passiert.
Okay, ob er sich jetzt auskennt oder nicht, kann ich nicht...
Keine Ahnung, kann ich nicht sagen.
Das Video war einfach nur schlecht aufbereitet.
So.
Übrigens, für die ganzen...
Ist das Ibarro eigentlich da?
Guck mal, was ich auf GitHub entdeckt habe.
Das ist was für euch, Leute.
Hab ich gestern im Chat noch gefunden hier.
Das ist was für die Weeb-Fraktion hier unter uns.
Anime Girls Holding Programming Books.
Was es nicht alles gibt auf GitHub, ja?
Und da kann man jetzt zum Beispiel mal gucken, okay.
So ein C-Sharp-Buch.
Und ich wollte schon, wenn immer, das...
Ach du große...
Ach du, wie spricht man das aus?
Kurumi...
Zawa...
Satanichia?
Wie auch immer.
Wenn ihr ein C-Sharp-Buch hält, das wollte ich schon immer mal sehen.
Was es nicht alles gibt, oder?
Auf GitHub schon den CSGO-Code gesehen, ja?
Hab ich.
Was es nicht alles gibt, oder?
Den neuen Outroid ansehen, ja?
Wollte ich, wollte ich, wollte ich, wollte ich.
Link bitte für Freund.
Ja, such hier.
Anime Girls Holding Programming Books.
2,4k Sterne.
Was es nicht alles gibt, oder?
Ähm, genau, den Outroid wollten wir uns angucken.
Gibt's da ein gutes Video zu?
Äh, was just announced?
Zwei, vor zwei Tagen, okay.
Hey, what's going on, guys?
It's ETA Prime back here again.
Now, I do wanna make this video kinda quick,
but keep an eye on the channel,
because I do have one of these new boards on the way,
and I'll have a full review video up on the channel soon.
I'll also make a couple other follow-up videos,
but I did wanna do kind of an announcement video,
because 2020's been lacking in the new single-board computer department,
but today, O-Droid just announced their O-Droid C4,
and you can actually buy this right now.
Ist C4 nicht irgendein Sprengstoff?
$50, this is gonna replace their O-Droid C2.
As it stands right now, everything's looking pretty great for the price,
but I'll have to get my hands on one and test it out.
So, I'm gonna scroll down here a little bit.
So, what we have here is the all-new O-Droid C4.
We have four USB 3.0 ports, full-size real gigabit Ethernet,
full-size HDMI port, our power input, unfortunately,
it's not USB Type-C, but it is...
Scheint mit der gleiche Formfaktor wie ein Raspberry zu sein,
das ist schon mal ganz gut.
Es ist ein Quad-Core, aber ich hoffe, die haben Krypto-Extensions,
das ist das, was mir beim Raspberry Pi 4 fehlt.
... and we also have a micro USB OTG,
which not a lot of people are gonna be really worried about,
but it's there if you need to utilize it...
Was für ein Ding? Was für ein Ding?
... and the board...
Was? Was? Was?
... we also have a micro USB OTG,
which not a lot of people are gonna be really worried about,
but it's there if you need to utilize it.
... and the board's gonna be powered by the Amlogic S905X3
with four gigs of RAM.
Now, I have done videos on Android Boxes powered by the same chip,
and I personally really like it,
and that's one thing I'm really looking forward to...
Wisst ihr, was das Problem ist von allen Raspberry Pi Clones?
Die mögen zwar manchmal vom Preis her günstiger sein,
die mögen auch von der Hardware teilweise deutlich besser sein
und durchdachter und alles,
aber der riesen Vorteil vom Raspberry Pi ist der Software Support.
Es gibt Milliarden Tutorials für Raspberry Pis,
es gibt ein super aktuelles Debian, was einfach funktioniert,
es gibt jede Menge Libraries,
die direkt die Description von den Raspberry Sachen unterstützen und alles,
der Software Support und auch der Community Support
und alles drum und dran ist das, was den Raspberry Pi ausmacht,
und da kommt ein anderes Board einfach nicht mit.
Außer es wäre komplett Raspberry Pi kompatibel,
was sie wahrscheinlich nicht sind.
Oh, das ist cool, das ist cool, das ist cool.
Das würde ich mir wünschen, dass der Raspberry auch sowas anbietet.
Geht Raspberry Pi eigentlich inzwischen mit dem normalen Upstream Kernel?
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Also, da sind ja noch viele Karten, die im Backup sind,
aber sie sind wirklich gut im Übertragen von der Wahrheit in ihren Benchmarken.
Wie ihr hier seht, wird der Raspberry Pi 4 in Blüten sein,
der Odroid C2 wird in Red sein,
wir haben den XU4 im Gelben,
den Odroid N2 im Grün
und den allneuen Odroid C4 im Orangen.
Das ist die Bench für UNIX
und wie ihr seht, kommen wir nicht wirklich bei den XU4- oder N2-Speed.
Haben wir uns dann,
den XU4, den haben wir doch hier im Stream schon mal ausprobiert.
Allerdings nicht in Form vom XU4, aber...
nicht in Form vom XO4, sondern in Form
von der Platte.
Das haben wir doch schon ausprobiert im Stream.
Da habe ich doch drüben
den
TV-Headend-Server
gebastelt. Könnt ihr euch noch dran erinnern?
Das habe ich doch im Stream gemacht, sind wir sicher.
Da haben wir einen TV-Headend installiert und das ist das Ding,
was aktuell gerade bei mir drüben im Wohnzimmer
liegt und
einen Dual-Tuner-USB-Stick
dran hat
mit einer
Platte hintendran
und was aktuell
die Aufnahme, was aktuell
TV-Server für mein Fernseher
drüben ist. Das haben wir doch im Stream
gemacht. Das ist glaube ich
ein XO4 unter der Haube
und der ist ziemlich geschwind, ja.
Da glaube ich acht Kerne sogar.
Vier langsame,
vier schnelle. Das Ding ist
richtig gut. Da hatte
ich den TV-Headend von meinem
4HE-Server drüber abgelöst,
weil ich keinen Bock mehr hatte, alles so
Single Point of Failure
in einer großen Kiste zu haben.
Das haben wir im Stream zusammengebaut,
ziemlich sicher. Da haben wir uns
TV-Headend selbst kompiliert und das hat nicht
richtig funktioniert, kann ich mich noch dunkel dran erinnern.
As for Unix-Binge,
double precision, we're right on par
with the Raspberry Pi 4, but the XU4
and the M2 still beat us out.
Moving over to 7-Zip, again,
about right now.
Right on par with the Raspberry Pi 4.
And I expected this to be a little
more than 30 higher speeds
than quick, just to give you an idea
of what's going to be available out of the box.
Oh, die haben schon mal einen Kühler drauf.
Einen ordentlichen. Das ist schon mal
eine gute Sache im Vergleich zum Raspberry Pi 4.
So, as for software,
right out of the box, as soon as you get your
board, we're going to be able to install
Android 9.
Warum sollte ich da ein Android drauf installieren?
Warum?
Ubuntu, er sagt's richtig.
Nicht Ubuntu.
20.04, so we have the Mate Desktop
and a minimal image.
Now, I know a lot of people who are reviewing my channel
might be interested in running Android.
Warum?
Warum soll ich da drauf Android laufen lassen?
Wo ist das...
Wo ist der Sinn davon?
Android benutze ich nur, wenn ich irgendwelche
Android-Apps verwenden will.
Und Android-Apps will ich auf einem Touchgerät
verwenden und nicht auf...
auf irgendeinem Single-Board-Computer-Dings,
wo ich irgendwelche Services für mich
im Netzwerk drauflaufen lasse.
They will have an Android 10 image
coming up for this in the next couple months.
Now, like I mentioned at the beginning of this video,
I have tested an Android box with the same
chipset and it actually does a really good
job with Android Pi or Android 10.
Wenn man daraus ein Info-Display
machen will mit Android-Apps, ja, vielleicht,
aber ganz ehrlich, bevor ich mir
das Ding kaufen würde, um ein Info-Display
mit Android rauszumachen, dann würde ich
mir einen 45,
40 Euro Fire-Tablet kaufen.
Sieben oder acht, das ist das kleine
oder das mittlere und dann hast du alles
in einem deutlich besser supportete
Plattform.
...win for this board because a lot of
people just want to run Android.
It's very simple to use.
It's the world's most popular...
Versteh's nicht, ich versteh's nicht.
...Amlogic CPUs, it actually works really
well, be it stock Android or Android TV.
And before I wrap this video up, I just
wanted to go over the basic specs.
For the CPU, we have that Amlogic
S905X3, this is a quad-core Cortex A55 CPU.
Das ist das gleiche wie im Raspberry, oder?
Ist das nicht auch ein A55 im Raspberry?
Vier?
Ach nee, A72 hat der, okay.
Was anderes.
Äh.
Was mit meiner Maus los?
Funktion...
Ah, jetzt, jetzt funktioniert...
What?
What the fuck?
Chrome, Chrome bugged.
Two gigahertz, hopefully we can get a
little overclock out of this.
I have heard of these running up to, I think, two gigahertz.
I've heard of these running up to 2.3.
The GPU is the Mali G31 MP2 at 650 MHz.
Das Zeug ist eh nirgendswo richtig supported.
4 GB LPDDR4 RAM running at 2133 MHz.
Die Raspberry GPU, da hast du ja auch
ein bisschen Treiberprobleme.
Und um nichts zu sagen,
Hardware-Decoding von Videos im Browser
ist unter Linux immer noch absolut unding.
...use a micro SD-Card or an eMMC-Module.
Gigabit LAN, 40 GPIO-Pins, just like on the Raspberry Pi.
4 USB 3.0-Ports und ein IR-Rechiever für das Board.
Es gibt viel mehr zu diesem Board als diese Spezies hier,
aber das war nur eine Basis-Übersetzung.
Ich werde alles überlegen, wenn ich das Board bekomme
und es für mich testen kann.
Und direkt aus der Box werden wir
Android 9.0 oder Ubuntu 20.04 installieren können.
Und einer, den ich sicherlich zu diesem Board machen werde,
wenn es schon nicht so gut sitzt, ist EMU-ELEC,
was eine tolle Frontend-Emulation ist,
so wie Badoserra, RetroPie oder RecallBox.
Und sobald die Devs einen von diesen
Boards haben, sind sie sicher, dass sie das Board werden.
Also ich muss sagen, außer dass es ein Ticken billiger ist
als der Raspberry Pi,
sehe ich da für mich jetzt nichts,
warum ich das bevorzugen würde gegenüber einem Raspberry Pi.
Der eMMC-Speicher vielleicht,
aber eine Micro-SD-Karte tut es ja im Endeffekt auch,
wenn ich nichts Großartiges an I.O. machen will.
Wenn ich was Großartiges an I.O. machen will,
mache ich da wahrscheinlich eine SSD dran oder eine Platte.
Und der Raspberry Pi ist einfach ungeschlagen, was
Community- und Software-Support angeht.
Ich glaube, damit ärgert man sich eher rum,
wenn man sich so ein Teil kauft.
Was meint ihr?
Ich glaube nicht, dass das was ist,
was ich mir kaufen würde.
Habe ich hier eigentlich so nice Chat-Messages dazwischen?
Schafft ja auch die Hannah-Montana-Distro mit Sicherheit.
Die ist so alt, die läuft wahrscheinlich nur noch in VMs.
Boah Leute, ich bin vier Stunden on.
Das ist viel zu lang für sonntags hier.
So lang war ich ja noch fast noch nie on.
Ich muss auch Essen bestellen,
aber Essen kann ich nicht im Stream bestellen,
weil da muss ich ja meine Adresse eingeben.
RIP.
Bestelle einfach mit Blackscreen.
Ne.
Ich gebe hier in den Browser nichts Privates ein.
Das ist mein Streaming-Account.
Auf dem Handy, lull.
Ja, das könnte ich tatsächlich machen.
Ich bestelle einfach
vor meinem zweiten Rechner.
Ich weiß aber nicht, was ich bestellen soll, Leute.
Ich bin unschlüssig, was ich bestellen soll.
Wir müssen jetzt mal kurz überlegen,
was ich bestellen könnte.
Können wir kurz überlegen.
Also ich guck mal, was auf hat.
Italienische Pizza in Hülle und Fülle.
Döner.
Döner hätten wir zu bieten.
Dönermann ist am Start.
Jede Menge Pizzeria, Pizzeria, Pizzeria, Pizzeria.
Fried Chicken.
Chicken.
Sushi. Ne, Sushi habe ich jetzt keinen Bock drauf.
Eis.
Pizza Hut.
Geh mal fort.
Wobei, ich muss sagen, jetzt wo ich jetzt erstmal schon gelästert habe.
Pizza Hut.
Jedes Mal, ich gehe selten zu Pizza Hut.
Ja, und ich bestelle auch selten bei Pizza Hut was.
Aber jedes Mal, wenn ich Pizza Hut bestelle,
schmeckt es mir besser,
als ich gedacht habe.
Köfte kann man bestellen.
Dominos ist richtig eklig.
Joey's Pizza ging ganz gut,
aber Dominos ist in Deutschland richtig abartig.
Indisch und China Service.
Gibt es.
Ah, nicht schlecht.
Asiatisch-Vegetarisch.
Das war es,
was jetzt auf hat.
Ich glaube, ich bestelle mir ein
Döner Teller
und gut, es ist.
Was ist der Mindestbestellwert?
Was ist Mindestbestellwert?
Döner Teller.
Knoblauchsoße, scharf, jawoll.
Pommes frites oder Reis?
Chat, Pommes frites oder Reis beim Döner Teller?
Was ist bei euch lieber?
Ich esse beides ganz gern.
Reis?
Reis.
Pommes, Pommes, Pommes, Reis, Pommes.
Oh, 50-50.
Pommes überwiegt, Reis.
Ich würde sagen so 60% Pommes,
40% Reis.
Pommes kommen weich an?
Ne, bei dem nicht.
Der ist nämlich, Luftlinie,
10 Meter von mir weg.
Ich habe das schon öfters bestellt.
Also ich bestelle jetzt wirklich online
bei einem Laden, der 10 Meter weg ist.
Keck, weh.
Kannst du selber holen.
Ja, da muss Streamer raus, Mann.
So, hinzufügen, yes.
Oh, 2 Euro Mindestbestellwert.
Fuck, was mache ich denn jetzt, was bestelle ich denn da noch?
2 Euro Mindest, ich kann doch einen Ayran
dabei bestellen oder so.
Ayran.
Ah, der kostet nur 1,30.
Tja, dann wird das nix.
Was, Uludag, was ist das?
Ist das türkisches Bier?
Ist das das türkische Bier?
Türkische Fanta Sprite, oh ne.
Ich mag ja schon NA Sprite nicht.
Weiß nicht, ob die türkische
Fake Sprite dann besser ist.
Ich weiß nicht.
Leute, wisst ihr was?
Ich bestelle jetzt nicht im Stream.
Ich mache jetzt den Stream aus.
Dann könnten jetzt alle wach sein.
Vier Stunden, drei Minuten.
Und jetzt gehe ich erstmal in Ruhe aufs Klo
kacken und dann gehe ich Essen bestellen.
Ja, siehste, Leute.
Ihr seid alle nicht wach, ich weiß.
Ja, danke für alle, die dabei waren.
Ich guck mal kurz,
ob wir irgendjemanden hosten
können, dem ich follow.
Ob da irgendjemand am Start ist, der
kleiner ist und
ähm
nicht wirklich.
Nicht wirklich.
Gut, also dann.
Ich glaube, ich habe keine Subs übersehen.
Schön, dass
heute wieder so viele Leute dabei gewesen sind.
Wir machen jetzt Schluss.
Wir sehen uns
vielleicht sogar morgen schon wieder.
Morgen habe ich ja frei.
Weil Montag.
Also bis dann, macht's gut.
See you.